Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freak Show und es hat keine drei Jahre
gedauert, bis wir mal wieder eine Sendung an den Start bringen konnten.
Ich bin Tim Pretlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 295.
Wir haben immer noch keine Idee, was wir mit der 300 machen.
Bedrohlich nah.
Bedrohlich nah. Wir schreiben den 21. August 2025 und ich begrüße Reif zu meiner Linken.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und Roddy haben wir entsorgt nach China.
Vorübergehend.
Genau. Der ist mal kurz weg, aber dafür gibt es Luca heute wieder. Hallo Luca.
Moin moin.
Ja genau, moin moin. Da sind wir wieder.
und gucken wir mal, ob wir im Sommer, den wir jetzt, was heißt,
hinter uns gebracht haben, noch ist er ja nicht vorbei, aber er war feucht und dann war er heiß,
dass wir was rausdestilliert bekommen.
Hast du denn was erlebt, Ralf?
Ich habe in der Tat ein bisschen was erlebt, ja.
Ich war zum ersten Mal seit, weiß gar nicht, zehn Jahren, 15 Jahren,
20 Jahren, habe ich mal drei Wochen am Stück im Urlaub.
Nicht nur eine Woche, nicht zwei Wochen, nein, drei Wochen.
Und mit Familie und Kindern und nach Skandinavien hoch, erst Schweden anderthalb
Wochen und dann noch anderthalb Wochen Dänemark.
So eine Kurve mit zweimal Fähre.
Erzähle ich hinterher im anderen Kontext auch noch ein bisschen, was soll ich sagen?
Das ist fantastisch, dieses Urlaub. Probiert das mal aus. Das ist völlig irre.
Es hat wirklich alles funktioniert.
Es war alles gut irgendwie vorgeplant. Wir hatten auch paartechnisch eine gute Aufgabenverteilung.
Das finde ich ja gerade bei Urlaub ganz wichtig, wenn man dann so wirklich 24-7
aufeinander hängt, dass es da nicht zu Verantwortungsdiffusion kommt. Das heißt...
Verantwortungsdiffusion.
Ja, verantwortlich alle schuld.
Genau. Oder keiner wird es gewesen sein und jeder so ein bisschen.
Und nee, ich dachte, du hast aber. Und von daher hatten wir eine glasklare Aufteilung.
Claudia macht Packen und Logistik, alles was irgendwie so mit Hardware zu tun
hat und ich mache so das ganze Eventplanungsding,
was macht man dann eigentlich vor Ort und was für Routen macht man irgendwie
und was für Aktivitäten und was guckt man sich an und was für sportliche Geschichten
und das hat alles sehr, sehr gut funktioniert.
Und ich war dann basserstaunt, ich bin ja eigentlich nicht so der Selbstvermesser,
hab aber ja seit vielen Jahren Apple Watch und da fällt ja doch das eine oder
andere so an Statistik raus.
Und wenn man dann mal so drauf guckt und sich dann diese Charts anschaut,
so Arbeitswoche, die letzten zwei und dann so nach zweieinhalb Wochen Urlaub,
was da so mit den Werten passiert.
Was passiert denn dann mit den Werten, mit welchen Werten denn überhaupt?
Also das Offensichtlichste sind erstmal die Schlafwerte. Also mein normaler
Schlaftag, das ist mal so richtig Post-Privacy hier, sieht so aus,
dass ich meistens die Racker noch ins Bett begleite und Eltern wissen,
was dann kommt, dann pennt man erstmal mit ein, weil es alles so schön gemütlich ist.
Familienbette haben wir schon länger hinter uns gelassen, aber trotzdem,
wenn der Tag irgendwie lang und anstrengend war, dann spricht nichts dagegen,
erstmal so eine anderthalb Stunden, zwei Stunden Nickerchen zu machen.
So, dann wird man aber irgendwann dann so wach um 22 Uhr.
So, dann macht man erstmal die Küche und Hausarbeit, was dann noch so alles
anliegt und dann kommt irgendwann nochmal so Paar und Me-Time hinten dran.
Dann guckt man noch irgendwie eine Serie zusammen, gerade zum Beispiel White
Lotus, gebinged, watched, sehr zu empfehlen. So und dann ist man irgendwann
so um zwei, drei Uhr, gehe ich dann ins Bett und habe in der Summe dann sechs Stunden Schlaf.
Was so gerade eben reicht, aber halt auch echt nicht so üppig ist und vor allen
Dingen ist es halt so zerschossen in mindestens zwei Schlafphasen,
wenn man dann nicht nochmal irgendwann aufwacht und nochmal wieder irgendwie
einschläft mittendrin.
Das klingt nach wenig.
So, es ist wenig und es ist irgendwie zerschossen und es führt halt dazu,
dass ich dann nicht krank bin in der Freakshow.
So, und jetzt hatten wir im Urlaub, ohne dass wir es besonders darauf angelegt
hatten, ein ziemliches Sportprogramm.
Das heißt also, wir sind richtig irgendwie so, also Raka sind ja sechs Jahre
und acht Jahre und mit dem haben wir jetzt schon so ein bisschen Wanderung mal gemacht.
So richtig 15 Kilometer am Tag, was für so einen Sechsjährigen schon ganz ordentlich
ist. Das haben die auch ohne Murren alles mitgemacht.
Und ohne das, was wir gesagt groß geplant hätten, haben wir gerade die ersten
zwei Wochen eigentlich jeden Tag irgendein richtiges Sportprogramm gehabt.
Und das hat dazu geführt, dass wir um 23 Uhr glücklich und müde im Bett lagen
und dann bis 8 Uhr durchgepennt haben.
Und das siehst du halt wirklich glasklar in der Statistik von der Apple Watch,
wie du aus einem Flickenteppich während der Arbeitszeit dann plötzlich zu einer
völlig homogenen Schlafmasse plötzlich irgendwie konvertierst.
Also du trägst deine Uhr auch konsequent immer beim Schlaf?
Ja.
Schon länger.
Das war früher anstrengend, aber jetzt gerade mit der Series 10 ist es völlig
unproblematisch, weil die sich in 20, 25 Minuten komplett auflädt.
Das hat dieses Problem, wenn ich sie über Nacht trage, dann ist sie morgens
komplett leer und dann muss ich aber zur Arbeit und wie kriege ich sie dann aufgeladen?
Genau das Problem kenne ich. Also ich habe vor kurzem meine Apple Watch Series
4 versehentlich kaputt gemacht. Die ist irgendwie bei einem Freak-Accident durch
den Raum geflogen und dann war das total im Arsch, das Ding.
Ich habe jetzt auch eine Series 10 und habe jetzt auch gemerkt,
der Reku hält einfach so viel länger.
Ich kann die auch nachts tragen. Ich kann morgens Sport machen noch und dann
nach dem Duschen ist das Ding wieder aufgeladen.
Ja, das ist schon ein Proof. Also das löst dieses, oh mein Gott,
warum hält die nicht drei, vier Tage? wenn sie halt nur 20 Minuten zum Laden
braucht, ist das halt auch die Krise morgens immer irgendwo vernünftig rein.
Und dann hält es halt wieder für den ganzen Tag.
Wenn du das neue Kabel hast mit USB-C und dann lädt er auch wirklich schnell.
Genau. Das hatten wir natürlich am Start. Naja und dann daraus leiten sich dann
halt noch so andere Werte ab.
Beispielsweise so Ruhepuls, Aktivitätspuls und sowas.
Atemfrequenz so während des Schlafes. Und egal auf welchen Chart du da jetzt
drauf guckst in der Health-App,
da siehst du also wirklich irgendwie normales Leben versus irgendwie sportlich
geführter, vernünftiger Urlaub und das ist krass und ich war drei Wochen lang
nicht krank, ja, spektakulär,
für die, die regelmäßig zuhören,
und ja, ich kann das also nur empfehlen, probiert das mal mit diesem Urlaub.
Ich hatte jetzt keinen Digital Detox wirklich gemacht, aber wenn du halt um
23 Uhr pennst, dann hast du da auch einfach mal nicht viel Zeit,
noch irgendwo Doomscrolling zu betreiben.
Und habe jetzt aber auch wirklich null irgendwie Arbeitssachen mitgenommen.
Das war so auch der klare Plan.
Nicht jetzt noch irgendwie nebenbei stressen lassen und dann doch halblich in
irgendwie Arbeits-E-Mails reingucken oder sowas.
Und da war so die klare Ansage, lasst mich in Ruhe, nur in den Tagen Katastrophen
fällen, irgendwie melden.
Und das hat auch alles gut funktioniert. Und von daher war das also in der Gesamtsumme,
wenn ich versucht zu sagen, so der entspannteste Urlaub meines Lebens.
Wann sagt man sowas schon mal? War cool.
Klima super, 23 Grad, Sonne, leicht bewölkt, ab und zu, so nichts schwül.
Wie war es mit den Mücken?
Wie war es mit den Mücken? Lustigerweise in Schweden, also im Großen und Ganzen
waren wir in Südschweden und haben da so eine kleine Rundreise quasi gemacht.
Und überall da, wo Seen waren, war es gar nicht so schlimm.
Also überhaupt Schweden, das funktionierte mit den Mücken, war kein großes Drama.
Die haben uns dann in den letzten Tagen Dänemark hart erwischt,
als wir dann am Meer waren. Da war kein See weit und breit, aber Meer.
Und aus irgendeinem Grund, so die letzten zwei, drei Tage, als die Temperatur
nochmal so auf 26, 27 Grad hochgegangen ist, da war dann echt Mückeninvasion.
Das war dann fies. Da hatte ich dann so zehn Mückenstiche parallel.
Hast du irgendwie Spray dagegen gehabt?
Was hatten wir alles? Wir hatten Spray, wir hatten diese Vaporatoren in der
Steckdose, die, glaube ich, überhaupt niemals irgendwo geholfen haben.
Und wir hatten Bite Away, so der neueren Generation.
Also diese müssen wir vielleicht mal kurz erklären für die, die es nicht kennen.
Das Gift von Mücken enthält, so jetzt müsste mal jemand schnell nachrecherchieren,
sind es die Eiweiße, die darauf reagieren.
Auf jeden Fall einen Stoff, der, wenn man ihn erhitzt,
So zu verklumpen beginnt, dass angeblich der eigentliche Giftstoff,
der dann zu den Entzündungen und Jucken und so weiter führt,
sich nicht so schnell oder so umfangreich oder gar nicht irgendwie entfaltet in dem Stich.
Der Stich ist immer noch da, aber er verläuft dann problemloser,
indem ich so ein Hitzeteil für ein paar Sekunden drauf stecke.
Das zirpt so ein bisschen. Das tut auch ein bisschen weh.
Es hört auf an der Stelle, wo man denkt, jetzt sollte es nicht doller werden.
Ja, da bin ich glaube ich generell ein bisschen unempfindlicher.
Es dürfte gerne doppelt so wehtun, wenn es denn funktionieren würde.
Meine persönliche Statistik ist irgendwie, dass es nichts bringt.
So Eiweiße schreibt der Chat, hatte ich richtig in Erinnerung.
Das ist auch die Erklärung, die ich kenne, aber ich habe auch schon irgendwo
gelesen, dass das eigentlich gar nicht so richtig erforscht sei und bekannt
sei, weshalb das wirkt und wie und überhaupt.
Aber da kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ja, also ich habe mich auf Mastodon beschwert und dann wurden mir in der Tat
auch Studien entgegengeworfen, die das also dann klinisch mal durchgetestet
haben mit viel Langzeit und wo das angeblich also dann doch signifikanten Einfluss hatte.
Also ich hatte jetzt in Testreihe zehn Stiche, die Hälfte behandelt,
die andere Hälfte nicht behandelt und am Ende war alles scheiße.
Und was wirklich nervt sind so diese Stiche, die zwei Tage später noch irgendwie Ärger machen.
Das ist so nach meinem Pi mal Daumen so ein Drittel bis ein Viertel der Stiche,
wo mir auch nicht klar ist, was dazu qualifiziert, dass solche Langzeitprobleme
wären, versus so nach zwei Stunden merkst du eigentlich nichts mehr.
Und definitiv waren bei diesen Langzeitstichen auch Behandelte mit dabei,
von daher hat es das also auch nicht irgendwie verbessert.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen war das weit von der Katastrophe entfernt, die man so mit Schweden,
Seen und Mücken verbinden würde.
Ja, da kennt man einiges. Also ich habe in Schweden mal mit einer Schwedin geredet,
die nach Deutschland ausgewandert ist, mit der Begründung, es gibt zu viele Mücken in Schweden.
Okay.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen unruhig, weil ich fahre ja noch nach Schweden.
Also zum Thema Mückenschutz, das Einzige, was ich in meinem Leben definitiv
sagen kann, was hilft, ist DEET, als Wirkstoff und so Mittelchen wie Antibrom.
Das wirkt. Das hilft sofort, nachhaltig und umfangreich.
Da kannst du auch noch in der Dämmerung kurz Nosen durch die Gegend latschen,
wenn du dich da mit eingenebelt hast.
Keine Ahnung, welchen Beitrag DEET zum Untergang der Welt beiträgt,
aber es hält einem definitiv die Mücken vor und bleibt so viel,
kann ich schon mal sagen.
Angeblich soll es auch gegen Zecken und so weiter und tropische Mücken und so auch helfen.
Aber es hilft vor allem zumindest in unseren Breiten gegen die Mücken.
Achso, eine Frage zu diesen Mücken. Sind die genauso schlimm wie in Schottland?
Also sind die so super, super klein oder sind das eigentlich nur die gleichen wie bei uns?
Von der Größe her machen sie auch so Geräusche.
Also ich hatte den Eindruck, dass die schwedischen Mücken sich signifikant unterschieben
haben von den dänischen Mücken.
Die dänischen Mücken kamen ja alle sehr bekannt vor. Das waren so diese langbeinigen,
relativ großen Viecher. Die schwedischen, da waren sehr kleine auch am Start.
Klein so wie so Tagesfliegen?
Ja, schon genau.
So Ruchtfliegen mäßig.
Schon wirklich ziemlich klein.
Kannst du die schottischen Geräusche, kannst du die nachmachen?
Es gibt keine Geräusche, die befallen dich einfach nur und du denkst so,
oh, wo kommen die ganzen Eintagsfliegen her?
Und dann habe ich irgendwie so 120 Stiche gezählt, nur während ich mein Zelt
aufgebaut habe, das mache ich nicht nochmal.
Also Schottland und Mücken ist definitiv auch so ein Thema und da ja Schottland
und Schweden so mehr oder weniger im selben Breitengrad unterwegs ist, vermute ich mal,
dass die gegebenenfalls was miteinander zu tun haben, auch wenn die natürlich
durch ein Meer getrennt sind. Keine Ahnung, wie sich das so entwickelt hat.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz erzählen, das ist D-E-E-T, das ist prophylaktisch.
Das heißt also, das appliziert man sich vorher drauf, wenn man sich in die Mücken-Gefahrenzone bedient.
Hinterher bringt es nichts.
Und einsprühen. Ja, aber Nerds, wir brauchen es exakter.
Also im Sinne von so einreiben, wie man das mit Sonnenmilch macht oder reicht
so grob über Hände und dann sind die Füße mitgeschützt.
Grob über die Zonen, die möglicherweise von Mücken befallen werden.
Also wenn du kurze Hosen trägst, auf die Beine.
Farbe Beine.
Genau.
Nacken.
Auch zu empfehlen. Vielen Dank.
Okay, nun gut. Das werde ich mir nochmal...
Also gibt es auch von verschiedenen Herstellern, ich bin mit Antibrom immer ganz zufrieden.
Ist nicht ganz billig, aber es wirkt besser als so Autan oder sowas.
Nee, das funktioniert gar nicht. Das wirkt einfach nicht.
Das wirkt einfach nicht. Vergessen.
Ja, ich wollte auch nochmal, ihr seid jetzt schon so schnell weitergerückt,
aber ich dachte mir, deine Health-Tracking.
Hast du dir dann auch mal die Langzeit-Statistiken angeschaut?
Weil mittlerweile gibt es ja dann auch so Vitalzeichen und Herzruhezustand.
Könntest du jetzt nach dem Urlaub eine langfristige Verbesserung von irgendwas messen?
Oder ist das nur so ein ich bin nicht mehr so krank?
Also ich bin jetzt erst eine Woche wieder hier. Das heißt also,
der Diff reicht da jetzt an der Stelle noch nicht.
Wieso, der Diff ist ja vor drei Wochen.
Ja, aber also was ich halt gesehen habe, ist, dass schon in der Mitte der zweiten
Woche gingen diese ganzen Vitalwerte schon wirklich signifikant in guten Bereich.
Also Ruhepuls, Aktivitätspuls und so weiter, das sah alles viel besser aus als vorher.
Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht drauf geguckt, ob die Woche das
jetzt schon alles wieder zurückgerissen hat.
Da müsste ich gleich mal schauen, ob ich das jetzt hier so finde.
Es gibt ja immer noch keine Health-App auf macOS. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Habe ich auch gerade festgestellt.
Warum?
Was erlaube, Steve?
Wegen der Sicherheit.
Ja, bestimmt. Also mein Schlaf ist schon mal wieder ruiniert. Das ist also...
Wirklich, also das seht ihr jetzt an den Empfangsgeräten nicht.
Aber hier mal so ungefähr.
Es ist einfach nur, wie viel besser es geworden ist.
Dieses Zerschossene und dann das Komprimierte.
als ob man es durch einen Audiokompressor durchgeschickt hätte.
Die Schlafzeit sah viel besser aus und jetzt ist man wieder genau in diesem
zerhackten Modus vorher.
Da hat sich natürlich jetzt langfristig überhaupt nichts verbessert.
Jetzt müsste ich mal gucken, wo haben wir denn hier irgendwo einen Wert?
Also mit anderen Worten, du hast es noch nicht reviewt und du kannst jetzt noch
keine klare Sache benennen, die jetzt besser funktioniert.
Hast du dich denn mehr bewegt?
Ja, sehr viel mehr. Also fast das Doppelte an kalorienumsatz tag das was sicherlich
sehr viel auch das ist das was ich meinte mit sehr aktiver nahezu sportlich haben wohl auch.
Dann fühlst du dich auch tatsächlich müde abends.
Genau ganz besser einschlafen das darum 23 uhr ist und im normalen tag quasi
nicht denkbar jetzt gucke ich gerade wo hier so ruhepulsen das ist ja auch eine app die irgendwie,
schwierig in der GUI ist.
Ja, das findest du unter Herz, glaube ich.
Herzfrequenztraining.
Also mit diesen Werten ist das ja so eine Sache. Also man schaut die sich mal
gerne an, wenn die sich gut entwickeln, aber kaum, dass es da mal böse wird,
dann legt man das Telefon auch schnell wieder beiseite.
Und ich habe immer so ein bisschen Angst, dass mir das Telefon irgendwie erzählt,
dass ich jetzt gleich irgendwie nur noch drei Monate zu leben habe und dann
weiß ich nicht, was ich tun soll.
Herzfrequenz habe ich jetzt, aber da sehe ich jetzt keine Zeitverlauf.
Gut, musst du das nicht jetzt machen.
Ich reiche es im Zweifelsfall nach.
Wenn ich was finde. Lass uns lieber kurz auf das Feedback zur letzten Sendung eingehen.
Da habt ihr uns ja überrollt. Also 193 Kommentare ist glaube ich Rekord.
und gut, das mag jetzt auch sein, weil die Sendung so alleine da stand,
es nichts anderes zu hören gab.
Aber ich glaube, die allgemeine Meinung zu unseren Tierlists,
dem Durchführen und den konkreten Ausprägungen derselben, lässt sich mit manche
sagen so, manche sagen so trefflich beschreiben.
Naja, also bei der ersten Sendung mit den Adaptern und Kabeln und,
Bei den Technik-Krams, da war es noch sehr durchwachsen, aber jetzt bei den
Single-Purpose-Küchengeräten.
Was ja keine Single-Purpose-Küchengeräte waren.
Ja, wie wir schon während der Sendung ahnten und dann in den Kommentaren auch
noch häufig genug um die Ohren geschlagen bekommen haben.
Da war aber das Gesamtfeedback, dass das doch mal ein gutes Segment war,
war überwältigend positiv im Vergleich zu dem Technik-Segment davor.
Ich glaube auch viele Leute, die meinten, dass es die Kapitelmarken gibt,
konnte ich mir vier Stunden Sendung sparen.
Da müssten wir jetzt doch qualitativ drauf gucken. Es waren nicht viele Leute.
Du meinst quantitativ?
Es waren quantitativ nicht viele Leute. Die wenigen, also überhaupt war die
Qualität der Kommentare von der Sendung insgesamt viel besser als bei etlichen anderen Sendungen.
Ja, also es hat auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Respons getriggert,
gar keine Frage. Weil wenn es ums Essen geht, hat jeder was beizutragen.
Das ist ja auch in Ordnung, so soll es ja auch sein.
Und grundsätzlich denke ich, würde ich das mal zusammenfassen mit Wir müssen
das noch ein bisschen schärfen, das Werkzeug.
Also es ist extrem wichtig, dass du bei einer Tierlist sehr klar sagst,
was ist die Kategorie, über die wir jetzt sprechen.
Weil wenn du dann links und rechts ausscherst, dann vergisst du die Hälfte auf
der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite hast du Sachen, die eigentlich damit
nichts zu tun haben. Und dann wird es so ein bisschen bunte Tüte.
Aber ich nehme es mal einfach mal vorweg. Wir werden auf dieses Küchenthema auch nochmal eingehen.
Dazu besorgen wir uns dann noch einen Stargast. Und jetzt lassen wir das aber erstmal außen vor.
Es sei denn, du hast noch zu bestimmten Kategorien was zu bemerken.
Und ich denke, du hast tatsächlich so was.
Ein paar Sachen fand ich dann doch interessant, was in den Kommentaren drin war.
Okay, dann mal los.
Zum Beispiel, was hatten wir hier? Knoblauchpresse. War ich ja sehr kritisch.
Und eine meiner Grundvorwürfe war ja, okay, so was mich persönlich am meisten
stresst bei Knoblauch, auch wenn ich den irgendwie schneide,
ist so, ich muss den erstmal irgendwie schälen, ja.
So, und dann hast du sowieso schon die Hände irgendwie zugesuppt.
Und ob ich dann mit den zugesuppten Fingern den dann schnell mit meinem schönen
Santoco-Messer klein hacke oder dann noch zusätzlich irgendwie stattdessen in
eine Presse, die ich dann noch irgendwie blöde reinigen muss,
so, wo ist da der Mehrwert?
Das war so ein bisschen mein Grundvorwurf bei Knoblauchpresse.
Und da kamen mehrere gute Hinweise in den Kommentaren, die gesagt haben,
nein, nein, Ralf, you're holding it wrong.
Das mit dem Schälen ist doch Quatsch. Du schneidest den Knoblauch in der Mitte
durch und tust ihn dann mit der Schale zusammen, so in die Presse rein,
dass quasi die Schnittkante an dem Pressstück ist und dann quetschst du es einfach mal aus.
Dann hast du nämlich sehr viel kürzere Zeit, als wenn du das Ganze erstmal schälst
und dann halt... Was soll ich sagen? Es stimmt, es funktioniert.
Warum hat mir das nie jemand gesagt?
Das wäre ja zu einfach.
Welche Knoblauchpresse, Ralf, welche hast du probiert?
Ich habe eine relativ gute zu Hause sogar. Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr,
ob die von, ich glaube fast die ist von Tupperware, als sie noch gab.
Wusstest du übrigens, dass das Tupperware, Tupperware, wie spricht man die eigentlich
aus, dass die nicht mehr gibt?
Nee.
Dinge, wo man denkt, die würden es doch ewig geben.
Sie haben dann doch zu lange an ihrem Vertriebsmodell festgehalten und irgendwann
war das dann nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Das ist dann so von dem Internet ein bisschen überrollt worden.
Tja, irre. Auf jeden Fall, ich weiß nicht, ich würde nicht darauf schwören,
dass es eine von denen ist, aber es ist eine, die eigentlich schon erstaunlich
gut und einfach zu reinigen ist, weil die schon vom Aufbau her clever gedacht ist.
Aber trotzdem hatte ich halt dieses Problem, wenn ich schon den Knoblauch in
den Händen habe, dann mache ich es doch mit dem Messer.
Aber durchschneiden mit Hülle einfach in die Presse rein, das ist der Clou. This is the way.
Dann gab es überwältigendes Feedback von der Reiskocher-Fraktion.
Also in einem Unmaß, in einem Ausmaß und einer Vehemenz, dass ich jetzt doch
überlege, ob man sich den vielleicht anschaffen sollte.
Ich habe mich dann aber doch in letzter Sekunde umentschieden und Platz in der
Küche war ja eine Dimension, die wir hatten.
Und bin jetzt doch in die Airfryer-Fraktion stattdessen gewechselt.
Du Hipster, du.
Ich habe mich durchgesetzt zu Hause und wir haben jetzt also einen Airfryer.
Da kann ich dann auch das eine oder andere in den nächsten Folgen vielleicht mal berichten.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viel damit getestet, aber das poste ich mal kurz
in den Chat rein, wie wir das Platzproblem mit dem gelöst haben.
Eine wichtige Kategorie der Tierlist der letzten Folge war, man hat halt nur
sehr begrenzt Platz in der Küche.
Und wir haben jetzt eine Konstruktion uns hier gebaut, wo wir Airfryer und Mikrowelle übereinander stapeln.
Mit so einem kleinen, direkt dafür angebotenen Gestell, was man in der Breite
genau so justieren kann, dass es auf die Mikrowelle und Airfryer zugeschnitten ist.
Praktisch?
Und das funktioniert sehr gut und nimmt jetzt eben nicht mehr Platz weg,
als es vorher ist, weil es ein Gerät, was vorher schon da war,
hat jetzt noch ein Gerät unten drunter.
Es ist aber jetzt auch nicht breiter. Wir haben dann unsere Mikrowelle nochmal
ausgetauscht. Wir hatten eine sehr, sehr große, die so eine spezielle Backfunktion hatte.
Das haben wir dann weggelassen dafür und haben die kleinste,
überhaupt irgendwo am Markt erhältliche Mikrowelle stattdessen genommen,
wo aber noch ein Standardteller reinpasst.
Und damit sind wir jetzt bisher ganz glücklich und jetzt, man ahnt es,
mache ich ganz viele AB-Tests, wie denn jetzt Dinge im Airfryer gelingen versus,
wenn ich sie auf dem klassischen Weg machen würde.
Weil es ist ja so die Airfryer-Fan-Fraktion sagt dann ja, oh,
da kannst du alles drin machen, so ungefähr wie hier in diesem Multimix.
Außer Reis.
Außer Reis, ja.
Den kriegst du auch mit der Mikrowelle nicht hin. Was machst du jetzt mit deinem Reis?
Ja, den koche ich immer noch im Topf wie vorher. Aber auch dazu gab es gute Rezeptvorschläge.
Kannst du auch in den Kaffee kochen, ja.
Das ist gerade von gestern Abend. Da habe ich also Hackbällchen gemacht für
die Kinder. Links aus der Pfanne, rechts aus dem Airfryer.
Links ist aber jetzt ein Stück Kohle gerade, oder?
Das sind Röstaromen. Das ist nicht Kohle. Das ist hier der Bima,
der verzerrt das so ein bisschen.
So, da würde ich schon sagen, nein, die werden aus der Pfanne doch schon noch besser.
Aber das machen wir dann irgendwann nochmal in einer der nächsten Sendungen,
wenn ich dann nochmal einen längeren Airfryer Review gebe.
Ja, so dann habe ich noch ein zweites Single-Purpose-Gerät mir mitgebracht, und zwar aus Schweden.
Da sind wir nämlich vorbeigekommen an einem Outlet-Store von einer schwedischen
Traditionsschmiede, die Gusseisenpfannen herstellt.
Und da habe ich hier mal ein schönes Stück mitgebracht von Ronneby Brooks, heißt die Firma.
Aus Ronneby ist glaube ich da die, ist das Kaff.
Und man sieht sofort, was man mit dieser Pfanne hier macht. Ich halte sie jetzt hier mal hoch.
Kleine Pfannkuchen.
Kühlchen.
Genau, das ist also eine Pfanne, die so glaube ich 24 Zentimeter Radius hat.
Und die besteht aus, ich glaube, sieben Vertiefungen.
Und darin macht man Pancakes. Das ist eine Pancake-Pfanne aus Gusseisen.
Maestro.
Und ja, das ist, glaube ich, jetzt nur irgendwie die Bezeichnung von diesen Dingen. Und wenn man...
Boah, ist die schwer.
Ja, Gusseisen halt.
Das ist ja echt jemand mit.
Das ist auch zur Selbstverteidigung.
Und die ist halt jetzt schon sehr Single-Purpose. Die Vertiefungen sind in der
Tat so klein, dass man da kein Spiegelei oder sowas drin kriegt,
sondern wirklich nur Pancakes.
Ja, Tim, so wiegen vernünftige Pfannen.
Irgendwann machen wir nochmal eine Fun-Nerd-Sendung. Da habe ich auch viel zu zu erzählen.
So, und die muss aber halt auch nicht bewegen. Das heißt, da muss sie dann nicht
aus dem Handgelenk irgendwie das Bratgut irgendwie drin schwenken oder sowas,
sondern die steht auf dem Induktionsherd und dann ist es auch gut.
Ja, die fühlt sich irgendwie toll an. Cooles Ding.
Und die werden also top, da die Pancakes natürlich alle genau gleich groß und
haben so ihre Form, also 24 Zentimeter Pfanne, sieben Vertiefungen, alle genau gleich.
Aus Schweden. Sehr gute Sache, dieses Schweden.
Ronneby-Bruck.
Genau, das war wirklich mein Outlet-Store, der sich gelohnt hat.
Da habe ich mir auch noch eine...
Welcher Stadt war das?
Das müsste... Ronneby.
Das ist der Ort, heißt so.
Ja, ich glaube, ich gucke aber gerade eben noch mal nach.
Ronneby, Schweden. Genau.
Ja, genau. Das ist so die Südost-Ecke von Südschweden, wo ich sagen würde,
auch mit Abstand die schickste Ecke in Südschweden.
Das ist so diese ganz super vielen kleinen Mini-Inseln, die man da hat.
und das ist das in der Tat dort in Rönneby eine Traditionsschmiede,
die sie da haben und die haben einen Outlet-Store, der den Namen wirklich verdient,
weil sie dann da beispielsweise,
Pfannen für ein Viertel oder Fünftel des Preises machen, die beispielsweise
dann unten am Boden irgendwie ein bisschen unplan sind, was aber auf dem Induktionsherd
einfach mal völlig wurscht ist.
So und da kann man also wenigstens mal richtig Geld sparen.
Was würdest du schätzen, wie viele Inseln Schweden hat?
Und was würdest du schätzen, wie im internationalen Inselhaben-Ranking Schweden so aufgestellt ist.
Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Länder.
Also Griechenland ist da sicherlich auch einschlägig.
Also,
ich würde sagen Anzahl an Inseln. Ich glaube, wir haben es während der Fahrt
sogar auch mal nachgeguckt.
Also auf jeden Fall mehr als tausend, da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Und im Gesamtranking, keine Ahnung, Top 10 würde ich sagen auf jeden Fall.
Die haben glaube ich schon sehr, sehr, sehr viele Inselchen.
Aber du hast die korrekten Zahlen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es korrekte Zahlen gibt, weil ich habe sehr unterschiedliche
Listen gefunden, die so dieses und jenes behaupten.
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so. Das scheint ein bisschen schwierig zu sein,
aber ich wäre bereit, bestimmte Dinge zu verallgemeinern.
Das war jetzt eine sehr diffuse Aussage.
Naja, ich dachte, du rätst noch, auf welchem Platz sozusagen Schweden ist.
Achso, hatte ich ja gesagt, auf jeden Fall Top Ten. Da wäre ich mir...
Nein, Top Ten ist jetzt ein bisschen ungenau.
Platz vier.
Platz vier. Und was wären so deine ersten drei?
Die ersten drei?
Ja. Also von welchen Ländern...
Da muss ich jetzt erstmal drüber nachdenken.
Wartest du? Naja, ich meine, okay, du sagst einfach mal Platz vier.
Ja, ich sag einfach mal eine Zahl.
Hier fällt sonst nichts ein.
Nee, ich habe da ehrlich gesagt kein Gefühl für, wie viele Inseln es so gibt.
Da habe ich mich noch nie drüber nachgedacht.
Also Wikipedia behauptet, es gibt in Schweden sage und schreibe 267.570 Inseln,
womit Schweden Platz 1 in der Welt ist.
200.000, okay.
Vorher noch Norwegen, Finnland und Indonesien und anderen so inselreichen Sachen.
Und ich glaube Griechenland ist da eher unter Ferne liefen.
Aber mehr als 1000 war schon mal ganz gut.
Naja, aber zwischen 1000 und 200.000 ist nochmal so zwei Größenordnungen dazwischen.
Also ich meine, kommt natürlich auch darauf an, wie man jetzt zählt.
Weil Schweden hat ja da so überall so kleine Steinchen, die da sozusagen im Wasser liegen.
Und dann ist es halt nochmal eine Insel. Das sind ja jetzt alles keine Rieseninseln.
Aber naja gut, es zählt halt, was von Wasser umschlossen ist,
nur das mal so nebenbei. Ohne, dass ich jetzt besonders viel Ahnung hätte von Schweden.
Auch wenn, wie schon angedeutet, auch mich die Reise dieses Jahr voraussichtlich
bald nach Schweden führen wird.
Genauer in zwei Wochen, oder?
Was machst du denn da in Schweden?
Na, ich fahre mit dir da hin.
Ach so. Und warum?
Reden wir gleich drüber. Auf jeden Fall, ja, sind wir mit der Küche.
Ich gucke nochmal.
Also ich habe ja auch noch ein Feedback.
Genau, eine Sache, da muss ich auch sofort sagen, ja stimmt, Eierschneider.
Wurde uns mehrfach vorgeworfen, dass es natürlich mitnichten Single Purpose
ist, weil man damit auch hervorragend Kartoffeln schneiden kann für Kartoffelsalat. Ja, stimmt. Punkt.
Ja, aber nur, wenn die Kartoffeln auch klein genug sind, dass sie da...
Ja, dafür nimmt man eine Mandoline eigentlich.
Eine Mandoline?
Ja, so nennt sich das, so ein Gemüseschneider-Ding. Das ist so eine Art Hobel,
wo man das Gemüse von oben so reinführt, runterdrückt und dann fällt auf der
anderen Seite ein Stück Gemüsescheibe raus.
Aha, Mandoline-Küchengereien.
Habe ich jetzt auch nicht gehört, aber gut.
Es gibt halt, ja Tatsache, es gibt offensichtlich.
Ja, da gibt es auch eine Disney-Serie zu.
Ach so, das heißt Mandoline. Also ja, einfach so ein Gemüse. Ach so ein Schaber.
Ja, aber mit Pläckertoffeln gibt es doch nur Matsche, wenn jeder rüber zieht. Das klappt nicht.
Mit dem Eierschneider nicht?
Nee. Da gehen ja die Drähte einfach glatt durch. Also die kleben danach wahrscheinlich
noch so ein bisschen ineinander, sodass man sich noch wieder ein bisschen auseinanderdividieren muss.
Ich hatte jetzt auch nicht an gekochte Kartoffeln gedacht, sondern du möchtest
vielleicht selber Kartoffelchips machen oder so.
Ja, gut, das geht nicht mehr, das ist schon klar.
Ja, aber solche praktischen Hinweise gab es da in den Kommentaren.
Von daher, also auch nochmal, wer, wem das Thema umtreibt und noch nicht in
die Kommentare reingeschaut hat, Da würde ich sagen, das lohnt sich echt mal
bei der Sendung, die mal alle durchzulesen. Da war viel Schönes dabei.
Danke auch mal nach da draußen dafür, dass ihr euch da auch die Zeit und Mühe gebt.
Ja, ich habe dann immer vor, jedes Jahr in meiner Hobbydisziplin Glamping immer
wieder neue Höhen zu erreichen.
Man kann einfach nicht luxuriös genug campen.
Aber es geht nicht einfach nur um viel, sondern man muss schon irgendwie das
richtige Zeug am Start haben.
Ich liebe es einfach, wenn irgendwie 20 Leute kommen und irgendwelche Requests
haben und ich ziehe das einfach aus einer Schublade. Das ist einfach geil.
Der Beitrag, der dieses Jahr dazu kam, war eine Eiswürfelmaschine tatsächlich,
hatte das auch glaube ich ein bisschen erwähnt, hatte noch keine Erfahrung damit
gehabt. Jetzt habe ich welche und muss sagen, ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Also es ist wirklich für so einen mobilen Bedarf, wenn es dann so heiß ist.
Selten hast du jetzt einen Kühlschrank am Start, der so viel Kühlleistung mit
sich bringt, dass er dann wirklich nennenswerte Mengen macht.
Hätte ich eigentlich auch nochmal ausprobieren können, weil ich irgendwie arg
unterschätzt habe, wie kalt ein Gefrierfach eines Absorber-Kühlschranks ist,
obwohl der Kühlraum selber nie so richtig kühl ist.
Aber irgendwie das Gefrierfach ist immer arschkalt.
Kriegt problemlos so minus 15 Grad, 17 Grad oder so hin.
Hätte vielleicht auch noch funktioniert, who knows. Aber diese Maschine ist
natürlich ganz praktisch, wenn du Strom hast, wohlgemerkt, weil du frisst ja
dann auch irgendwie 100 Watt.
Ja und dann klackern da so alle 10 Minuten die Eiswürfel raus,
was man einfach mal so eine Weile laufen lässt, dann kann man dann schnell das harvisten,
packt es dann in den Tiefkühler und dann hat man einfach Eis.
und die Entdeckung dieses Jahres für mich war einfach Eiskaffee.
Es ist einfach erstaunlich, wie viel besser Kaffee ist, wenn er kalt ist.
Das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt, das hatte ich nicht so ganz in Erinnerung.
Wie ist denn da dein Rezept?
Rezept?
Naja, du willst jetzt nicht einfach einen normalen Kaffee machen und dann da Eis reinkippen.
Was heißt normaler Kaffee? Was ist ein normaler Kaffee für dich?
Ich habe halt einfach so eine Bialetti-Kaffeekanne.
Ich darf jetzt nicht Espresso-Kaffee sagen, weil irgendein Kommentar meinte,
das wäre ja kein richtiger, was auch immer.
Also das, was da rauskommt, schöner, schwarzer, starker Kaffee,
Hafermich drauf, Eiswürfel drauf, fertig.
Okay.
Und mit Eiswürfeln ist es so ein bisschen wie mit Spanngurten und Kabelbindern und Meshbacks.
Der eigentliche Wert kommt davon, dass du viel davon hast.
So einzeln sind die irgendwie nicht so relevant. Aber wenn du viel davon hast,
dann ist das auf einmal eine ganz andere Nummer.
Weil ein paar Eiswürfel im Kaffee.
das Ding muss geradezu eigentlich nur aus Eiswürfeln bestehen,
weil erstens hält es damit dann sehr lange, auch wenn es scheiße heiß ist und
es ist einfach nochmal was ganz anderes, ob der Kaffee kühl ist oder ob er wirklich
richtig kalt ist und wenn er so richtig richtig kalt ist und du hast dann so eine schöne schwere,
Barista Hafer, die musst du auch gar nicht aufschäumen, einfach nur so in ihrer
ganzen Schwere dann ist das einfach süffig und dann hält der Kaffee auch viel
länger und kühlt auch noch dabei ab und es ist einfach grandios.
So und kein Zucker.
Ja sowieso nicht. Zucker und Kaffee.
Also wenn sich das hat einfallen lassen, hat auch nicht alle gehört.
Naja. So. So viel zum Küchenthema. Wir wollen es nicht übertreiben.
Aber ihr könnt schon mal erwartungsvoll sein, da kommt noch so einiges in Zukunft.
Genau. Ich habe hier noch einen Kommentar rausgesucht, der war ganz vielfältig
und zwar zum Thema USB-Laden.
Ich weiß nicht, ganz klar werde ich ihn jetzt nicht vorlesen,
aber Richard sagt, er kennt sich zu gut mit USB-C-Ladestandards aus und musste dazu noch was sagen.
Hat noch einen schönen Link abgeworfen, den findet ihr auch nochmal in den Shownotes.
mit der Tabelle sieht man erstmal schön, was ein USB-Port pro Version so grundsätzlich kann.
Bei USB-C ist es halt 5 Volt mit 3 Ampere, also 15 Watt.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn man einen USB-C-Port hat, dann sollten da eigentlich
laut Standard mindestens immer 15 Watt rauskommen.
Bei dem Standard USB-A ist es ja ein halbes Ampere, also kriegst du so ein paar
Watt raus. Das war es dann.
Es gibt einen Haufen Ladestandards, die dann das natürlich noch hochdrehen,
also dieses USB-Power-Delivery-Protokoll und damit kann man natürlich heutzutage
bis zu 240 Watt abrufen aus USB-C-Kabeln,
was ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich bemerkenswert finde.
Aber das heißt dann halt auch, das Gerät muss das natürlich auch können und
dann bist du irgendwie schon bei 48 Volt und es ist schon irre,
was da drüber zu übertragen ist.
Ja, lest euch den Kommentar durch. Ich lese den jetzt mal nicht komplett durch.
Ist auf jeden Fall sehr aufschlussreich. Wir verlinken da nochmal drauf.
Ja, wir waren dann auch auf Reisen, der Luca und ich und waren...
Am Hacke. Ein bisschen.
Und es gab Eiskaffee.
Und es gab auch viel Regen, was nicht so schön war. Aber wir haben ja so ein
bisschen als Hobby, als Sommerhobby, so dieses Blinklärtsprojekt,
was wir am Camp ursprünglich mal gemacht haben.
Das holen wir jetzt einmal im Jahr auf den Nation of Gondwana raus.
Das lief dieses Jahr nicht so gut, weil wir ein paar Fehler gemacht haben.
Kurz gesagt, wir haben diese Panels die wir mal fürs Camp gebaut hatten die
wir da hinter diesem Fenster gemacht haben 10 Stück und haben noch 2 dazu gebaut
und die jetzt so im Kreis aufgebaut,
so ein 20 Meter Durchmesser und dann gucken die sich irgendwie so gegenseitig an quasi wie so eine Uhr,
und du stehst in der Uhr und dann gab es noch so Buttons auch im Kreis für jedes
Panel leider haben wir dann die Buttons nicht richtig befestigt und dann ist
die durch Überbenutzung der,
Teilnehmer alle Kabel abgerissen und irgendwie nichts funktionierte und zwar
ein heilloses Desaster.
Aber wieder viel gelernt und dann haben wir schon sehr viel darüber diskutiert,
was man eigentlich hätte machen sollen.
Was wir auch noch ausprobiert haben, war mit so Ultraschallsensoren Präsenz zu messen.
Was leuchtet denn dir aus?
Die Ultraschallsensoren.
Genau, also wenn man jetzt so diesen Kreis sich imaginiert, der war ja relativ groß.
Wir hatten den ja auch schon mal in der Sendung hier mit 3D,
in der Vision Pro, Pre-Visualisierung und ähnliches.
Das war ja schon ein Radius von 20 Metern oder sowas und noch mehr.
Genau.
Was davon haben denn dann die Ultraschallsensoren ausgeleuchtet?
Quasi gar nichts.
Naja, dann.
Ultraschallsensoren, das wussten wir auch schon vorher, die kommen halt nur
so, naja, maximal so zwei Meter weit. und dann war es das eigentlich auch schon.
Die kommen theoretisch schon ein bisschen weiter, aber da werden dann die Messwerte
ziemlich noisy, haben wir festgestellt.
Und die waren an den Panels oder an den Buttons?
Ja, an den Panels.
Aber man hätte sie auch an die Buttons bauen können, weil die ja in der Mitte wahrscheinlich.
Ja, hätte aber relativ wenig an der Situation geändert.
Also uns war, sagen wir mal, die eingeschränkte Nutzbarkeit,
war uns natürlich bewusst, ob der Reichweite.
Die Hoffnung war so ein bisschen, dass man zuverlässig oder vielleicht zuverlässig,
feststellen kann, wenn Leute am Panel vorbeigehen und darauf hätte man dann
reagieren können und so weiter, was dann aus anderen Gründen nicht funktioniert hat.
Aber die sind dann doch sehr unzuverlässig und dann hast du auch noch das Problem,
so Ultraschallsensoren, Outdoor, Staub, irgendwie, also,
dann gab es halt schnell auch Ausfälle und du hattest einfach sehr unklare Messwerte
und von daher war das ein bisschen schwierig, da wirklich was rauszuholen.
Aber die Idee an sich war natürlich ganz gut und jetzt wollen wir das irgendwie fixen,
und wissen noch nicht so ganz genau, wir haben aber so ein paar Ideen und da
würde mich natürlich auch mal interessieren, was ihr alle da so für Erfahrungen
vielleicht habt, weil eigentlich wollen wir halt,
alle Personen, die sich innerhalb dieses Kreises befinden,
mehr oder weniger genau tracken können in Echtzeit.
Und das soll dann der eigentliche Input sein für das, was diese Displays von sich geben.
Also so ein lebendiges System, was quasi auf die Personenpräsenz reagiert.
Und zwar sowohl auf ihre Zahl, auf ihre Position und gegebenenfalls halt auch
noch auf ihre Bewegung, Beschleunigung, Geschwindigkeit, Richtung, was auch immer.
Was auch immer man aus diesen Daten herausziehen kann, wenn man sie eben über diese Zeit betrachtet.
Aber es ist jetzt gar nicht so einfach, sich eine Sensorik einfallen zu lassen,
die da zuverlässig funktioniert und die auch mal halbwegs bezahlbar ist.
Also bisher sind uns eigentlich nur drei verschiedene Technologien eingefallen, die da in Frage kommen.
LIDAR, genau.
LIDAR ist so die erste. LIDAR hat den Vorteil, damit kannst du natürlich super
präzise schnell messen.
Wenn du, würdest du jetzt round robin da so drei, vier, fünf,
sechs LIDARs aufstellen, dann würdest du sehr präzise jedes einzelne Bein erfassen können.
Du musst natürlich eine gewisse Kalibrationsarbeit leisten.
Damit ließe sich das tatsächlich schon machen.
Das hast du aber mit allen Sensoren. Du musst natürlich dann auch schauen,
dass du dann eben diese einzelnen Objekte auch zusammenfasst.
Also du musst zwei Beine einer Person zuordnen etc.
und musst halt irgendwie so in regelmäßigen Abständen gucken,
bewegt sich das jetzt irgendwo hin, korreliert das jetzt mit einer Position davor.
Alles machbar, aber du brauchst natürlich erstmal die Daten.
Problem bei Lida, arschteuer.
Also da kostet so ein Teil irgendwie in guter Qualität halt mal ein paar tausend
Euro und das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, für so ein kleines Spaß-Hobby-Ding,
was ein paar Tage läuft, ist das jetzt nicht so ganz die Investition, an die ich gedacht habe.
und mit teuren Geräten kommt natürlich auch das Problem, nicht nur,
dass sie teuer anschaffen muss, wenn sie dann kaputt gehen und so,
das ist alles nicht so schön.
Genau, was ist das zweite, was dir einfallen würde, Ralf?
3D Stereo Vision Sensor, die auf optischer Basis funktionieren und das dann
aber im Gerät schon umrechnen in Punkte und Punktwolken.
Also mit Licht?
Ja, sowas haben wir in der Tat jetzt bei uns im FEP, an den Bibliotheken,
bauen wir gerade ein. Wir haben da Xovis heißen die.
Ich kann den Link mal eben reinschmeißen.
So, am Ende des Tages sind das erstmal Kameras, wobei man die eigentliche Kamerafunktion
halt wirklich nur am Anfang einmal bei der Justage und Einrichtung braucht und
danach hast du dann in den ganzen Dashboards quasi nur noch Punktwolken, die du verwaltest.
Kriegst damit aber auch Höheninformationen raus.
Also wir messen beispielsweise, wie viele Kinder sind vermutlich reingelaufen,
wie viele Erwachsene. Da können einen Threshold setzen anhand der Größe.
Alles unter 1,30 gilt halt irgendwie als Kind. Hat alles Unschärfen,
alles nicht perfekt, aber hinreichend gut.
Ist das dann so ein Infrarot-Ding?
Nee, es ist wirklich eine rein optische Geschichte.
Infrarot ist ja auch...
Ja, korrekt. Also sichtbares Licht wird da ausgewertet.
Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was jetzt so ein Sensor Einzel.
Also das Ding sendet selbst keinerlei Licht aus.
Rein passiv.
Okay, interessant.
Das sind glaube ich die Teile, die auch in Supermärkten zum Einsatz kommen, kann das sein?
Das ist totale Feldwald- und Wiesentechnologie auf jeden Fall. Das ist jetzt nichts Ja.
Aber funktioniert das auch im Dunkeln.
Das funktioniert mit einiger Sicherheit nicht gut im Dunkeln.
Ja, und das natürlich für eine Lichtinstallation, die, wie du dir denken kannst,
im Dunkeln betrieben wird.
So ein bisschen so ein No-Go.
Wir brauchen halt etwas, was wirklich in tiefschwarzer Nacht funktioniert und
sich auch gegen andere Wirren wie Staub und so weiter erfolgreich durchsetzen kann.
Insofern fallen so diese rein optischen Sachen ein bisschen raus,
auch weil die natürlich so ein bisschen so ein Privacy-Problem haben.
Ja, das ist das Interessante, darum haben wir die auch ausgewählt.
Da kommst du halt nie mehr auf den Kamera-Feed drauf danach,
sondern es wird on-device umgerechnet in völlig abstrakte Punktdaten.
Nachdem der Kamera-Feed zum Hersteller geht.
Nee, das ist wirklich on-device. Also einmalig hast du wirklich ein Kamerabild
und sagst, okay, hier ist jetzt der Bereich, wo die Leute irgendwie reinlaufen,
das hier ignorier mal völlig, das konfigurierst du dir einmal und dann wird
es quasi eingebrannt von der Software her in das Gerät und dann kannst du nur
mit einem Admin-Schlüssel auch das überhaupt wieder öffnen, um wieder irgendwo
das in den ursprünglichen Setup-Kamera-Modus zu schalten.
Selbst wenn wir wollten, könnten wir da jetzt nicht auf irgendein Kamerabild
drauf. Das war bei uns als Bibliothek, ist das nicht Privacy-mäßig schon ein echtes Issue.
Aber es ist so Decken-Installationsmäßig.
Genau, das hängt oben. Vielleicht kann man es hacken, dass du damit auch ganz
andere Setups irgendwie bauen könntest.
Es wäre dann halt interessant, wenn man zum Beispiel mit Infrarotlicht arbeiten kann.
Also wenn du quasi noch dazu einen Infrarot-Sender hast, der das eben alles
in so Infrarotlicht macht und die Kameras eben damit funktionieren würden.
Das kann ich dir jetzt natürlich nicht beantworten.
Ist halt auch optisch, aber halt nicht menschenoptisch. ja genau also es gibt
tatsächlich in diesem ganzen Supermarktbereich gibt es so verschiedene Techniken,
das eine davon gibt auch noch ein paar andere die,
ja ähnlich funktionieren und optisch, naja jetzt,
wollen wir ja explizit Menschen trecken und das im Dunkeln das nächste was einem
Sinn kommt wäre natürlich Thermo,
Also dass du ein Wärmebild aufnimmst und schaust, dass du dann eben die Personen
anhand ihrer Wärmekennung.
Der ist aber schon schweineteuer, oder?
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen unklar. Also es gibt so Sensoren,
da wirklich von wenig bis extrem viel Geld.
Und funktionieren die dann auch in der Sonne? Obwohl eure Teile sind so hell,
dass sie auch tagsüber doch funktionieren.
Es muss tagsüber nicht funktionieren, weil tagsüber die Installation nicht läuft.
Du siehst sie ja eh nicht.
Also die sind nicht so hell. Naja, es gibt ja LEDs, die so hell sind,
dass du sie auch tagsüber probieren musst.
Das ist nicht quasi der Use Case, sondern erst ab Dämmerung geht das Ganze on.
Okay. Naja, kann man machen.
Ja, also,
Thermo hätte, wenn es funktioniert, den Vorteil, dass man dann mit einer relativ
einfachen Bilderkennung, du musst ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Hotspots erkennen,
die Software dafür existiert.
Die Algorithmen sind da und dann gibt es auch ein paar AI-Models,
die das wahrscheinlich irgendwie mittlerweile sogar ganz zuverlässig machen,
aber du brauchst dann auch nicht mal Machine Learning vorher,
um solche Hotspots rauszurechnen.
Also das ist schon, ich will nicht sagen gelöstes Problem, aber es ist zumindest
ein verstandenes Problem,
wo wenn man akkurate Daten bekommt und weiß, worauf man sich konzentrieren muss,
dass man dann ganz gute Ergebnisse hat.
Aber es ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig mit Outdoor und Party,
weil dann weißt du nicht, hast du eine kalte Nacht, hast du eine warme Nacht,
laufen die Leute mit T-Shirts rum oder ist es kühl und alle haben dicke Jacken an.
Wie zuverlässig ist das dann noch?
Framerates ist bei diesen Thermodingern meistens relativ niedrig.
Wenn du eine hohe Framerate hast, dann sind das sehr, sehr, sehr tolle Geräte.
Mir ist gar nicht klar, warum die eigentlich so teuer sind, um ehrlich zu sein.
Mir auch nicht.
Mich überrascht das, ehrlich gesagt. Zumal es ja, wie Roddy,
hier hat der auch so einen China-Thermo-Sensor mit einer passablen,
Auflösung, der dann halt, was weiß ich, hältst du irgendwo einen Dachstuhl und
dann weißt du, wo irgendwie die Wärme rausläuft.
Also das ist mir selber noch nicht so ganz klar, was eigentlich so die Faktoren sind.
Du hast natürlich da eine relativ große Matrix mit Framerate,
Pixelauflösung, generell Sensibilität dieser Teile, Zuverlässigkeit,
sind die irgendwie industrial oder ist das irgendwie so Konsumer-Kram?
Also da weiß ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht, ich habe keinen wirklichen Überblick,
falls da jemand was weiß.
Also das Hauptziel ist ja vor allem, dass man mehrere Personen oder möglichst
alle Personen in diesem Bereich trackt. Es muss nicht ein Sensor für alle sein.
20 Meter Durchmesser ist schon ganz schön viel Fläche.
Aber wir haben ja sowohl die Möglichkeit, auf diesen Panels außen zu installieren,
als auch vielleicht in der Mitte an einem Mast.
Den wir nicht hatten, aber haben können.
Was man auch noch bedenken muss, ist bei möglichen Aufbauten von mehreren Sensoren,
wenn du irgendwas hast, was aktiv irgendwie vielleicht Infrarot-Dots aussendet
oder so, wie dieses Kinect funktioniert.
Stört sich das gegenseitig? Oder theoretisch, die Überlegung hatten wir natürlich
auch beim Ultraschall. Können wir damit Probleme haben?
Hatten wir jetzt nicht, weil die einfach dann doch eine Distanz hatten,
die groß genug war untereinander.
Aber das ist halt was, was man auch bedenken muss.
Seriously Pascal wirft gerade in den Chat rein, Radar.
Für 9 Euro das Stück.
Ja, da kommen wir zu der nächsten Option.
Das ist genau das, was er hier meint. Das ist halt Millimeter-Wave.
Millimeter-Wave-Radarsysteme spielen so im 24 Gigahertz Frequenzspektrum ab
und sind sehr günstig zu bekommen, wie er schon erwähnt.
Also man kriegt so kleine Radar-Detektoren wirklich für relativ wenig Geld.
Kleiner Bauform auf so einer Platine.
Kannst dann schön auch in so einen Plastikcase reinmachen, weil da strahlen die sowieso durch.
Das Problem ist nur bei den Millimeter-Wave-Dingern, die sind halt gut so für
eine oder zwei oder drei Detektionen in einem bestimmten Abstrahlwinkel.
Aber es gibt auch ein paar, die sagen, ja, wir können hier auch mehrere Objekte
entdecken und da wird es dann halt knifflig.
Radar, genauso wie LIDAR, hat natürlich das Problem, du hast so Line of Sight
und du gehst auf die Reflexion.
Das heißt, du hast das Problem der Verschattung, du hast das Problem,
dass du verschiedene rückkehrende Signale eben so weit trennen musst,
dass du sagen kannst, da ist einer, da ist einer, da ist einer.
Wenn also jetzt Menschen relativ eng beieinander stehen, dann bezweifle ich,
dass selbst ein Gerät, was mit mehreren Objekten umgehen kann,
die scharf auseinanderhalten kann.
Muss nicht unbedingt ein Problem sein, aber es ist definitiv jetzt eine Anforderung.
Dann haben diese Millimeter Waves auch in der Regel, was ich gesehen habe,
einen relativ breiten Abstrahlwinkel.
Das heißt, wenn wir eh mehr als einen brauchen, weil die meistens nur so sechs
Meter Reichweite haben, oder zumindest die normalen, die ich gesehen habe,
hatten so sechs Meter Reichweite.
Müsste man sowieso einmal ganz wahrscheinlich in der Mitte und außen überall
welche anbringen und dann strahlen die sich natürlich auch gegenseitig an.
Das heißt, dann hast du wieder dieses Problem, dass du auf einmal Radarquellen hast,
die Interferenzen und Überschneidungen und Echos und so weiter erzeugen können,
da habe ich relativ wenig Erfahrung mit, ob das jetzt hier auch wirklich ein
Problem ist oder ob das irgendwie kein Problem ist.
Wenn es halt nur darum geht, so in einem Raum feststellen, bewegt sich da jemand,
dann liegt an, okay, dann ist das
irgendwie super, dann ist das genau die Technologie, die man haben will.
Aber für dieses spezifische Problem, du möchtest gerne in einem 20 Meter Durchmesser
Kreis idealerweise alle Personen einzeln tracken und,
Mit einer brauchbaren Frequenz, ich brauche jetzt keinen 30 Frames pro Sekunde, aber,
10 wäre schon ganz gut, weil letztlich möchtest du gerne auch,
wenn jetzt einer da anfängt im Kreis zu laufen, möchtest du den halt gerne verfolgen.
Und Menschen können dann schon ganz schön schnell sein und dann hast du auch
das Problem, dass dann vielleicht diese Bewegung von dem einen Sensor in den nächsten Sensor geht.
All das gesagt, würde ich sagen.
Also infrarot optisch, wo man von oben mit einem fetten Infrarotstrahler rein
strahlt, um das quasi für die Kameras hell zu machen und die machen was, wäre eine Option.
Thermo klingt eigentlich am sinnvollsten, weil da kannst du dann oben mit einem
Fischauge irgendwie alles abdecken und dann musst du nur noch die Hotspots finden,
aber da ist halt das Fragezeichen wie sensibel sind die nachts bei Leuten in Klamotten,
und Und bei MillimeterWave brauchst du halt so Multipersonenerkennung und das ist alles schwierig.
Also Thermo, also nie irgendwas damit gemacht, ja, also ganz ungesundes Halbwissen jetzt.
Aber da brauchst du wahrscheinlich eine sehr adaptive Signal-Noise-Ratio-Anpassung halt.
Dass du also verschiedene Temperaturszenarien dann einfach abgleichen kannst,
um zu sagen, so okay, was ist jetzt noch Signal und was ist Rauschen drumherum.
Aber vielleicht gut gelöstes Problem. Da würde ich mal hoffen,
dass in den Kommentaren vielleicht was dazu kommt, wo da jemand schon mal mitgebaut hat.
Es gab natürlich auch noch ein paar andere esoterische Vorschläge, wie so Katzenmatten.
Ich habe ja schon lange Katzen. Was sind Katzenmatten?
Da ist es, wenn du so eine Katzentür hast, dann gibt es so Kontaktmatten,
die kannst du dann hinter dir, also wenn du so ein Loch hast,
wo die Katze rein und raus kann durch die Tür.
Damit die Katze immer in die Wohnung kann, aber sonst keiner.
Ja.
Eine Katzenmatte legst du dann davor und das ist dann so ein Detektor,
der dir immer sagt, wenn die Katze irgendwie rein oder raus ist.
Es gibt die wildesten Produkte auf diesem Planeten.
Ich dachte, das sei auch optisch. Aber gut.
Ist es ein Drucksensor?
Ja, es gibt es irgendwie mit Kontakt auch.
Also ich kenne das nämlich, dass eine eingebaute Kamera ist und du noch gleich
einen Screenshot bekommst auf dein Handy. Das steht schon wieder vor.
Der ganze Haustierbereich ist mir eh ein Rätsel. Naja, also so läuft es.
Gut, also vielleicht hat da jemand einen Kommentar. Wir sind da eigentlich nur
auf der Suche und auf der Suche nach guten Ideen, was man nehmen könnte.
Du könntest jetzt aber, das hast du nämlich einfach mal bewusst oder unbewusst
übersprungen, mal das eigentliche Wirkungsziel sagen.
Das heißt also, wenn du denn dann diese Daten hast, was gedenkt dir denn mit
diesen Daten dann eigentlich genau zu tun?
Naja, das ist so eine Lichtinstallation. Die soll ja interaktiv sein.
Das heißt, Leute sollen in der Lage sein.
Also ihr wollt weg vom Button hin zu anderen Interaktionsmöglichkeiten?
Ja, der Button ist dann doch sehr beschränkt. Das heißt nicht,
dass der Button keine Rolle spielen kann, aber der Button ist alleine einfach zu wenig.
Das ist für so Spiele ganz gut, aber mir schwebt halt mehr so eine wabernde,
lebende Installation, die quasi ihr Inneres wie so eine Heatmap erfasst und
du kannst mit deiner Bewegung alles beeinflussen.
das Beispiel mit dem Laufen zum Beispiel, also laufen alle macht die Installation DISS,
bleiben alle stehen, macht die Installation DISS und wenn wir so richtig überdreht
sind, machen wir vielleicht auch das nochmal, was wir auf dem Camp gemacht haben
und bauen noch überall einen Lautsprecher drauf und dann,
könnte man das eben auch noch akustisch begleiten, aber ich bin mir relativ
sicher, dass ich bereuen werde, das überhaupt gesagt zu haben,
weil es ist immer so ein bisschen erst Eidern, Gag, es sind alles Überlegungen,
wie man das zusammenbringen kann, weil wir so ein bisschen,
nicht so ganz dahin gekommen sind, wo wir hinwollten, aber das Setup sah einfach echt charming aus.
Also diese Panels, diese Größe, diese Erscheinung, das zieht einen so magisch an.
Alle meinten auch so, ja, was ist denn das hier? Digitales Ton.
Und mit Ton und mit einer lebendigen,
interaktiven Grafikgestaltungen, die halt hochgradig auf diese Sensorik reagiert,
kann einfach was Schönes machen, was ein Ort ist, der zum Verweilen,
aber auch zum Spielen einlädt.
Also es soll sozusagen immer irgendwie vor sich hin blubbern, wie so was weiß ich,
leuchtende Auroren und in dem Moment, wo du aber Aktivität reinbringst,
dann merkt das System das und du sollst es halt auch merken,
dass das System das merkt und dann wird es halt spielerisch.
Es gab ja auf dem letzten Camp schon so eine ähnliche Installation,
die hatten wir jetzt hier auch auf einer anderen Party nochmal gesehen,
die auch so ähnlich funktioniert tatsächlich mit LIDAR, wo dann oben so Strahler
sind, die auf dem Boden strahlen und mit LIDAR wird halt gecheckt,
wenn sich jemand diesem Strahler nähert oder beziehungsweise dem Strahler nähert, sondern dem Ort,
wo der Strahler auf dem Boden aufschlägt, also da, wo der Lichtkegel ist.
und in dem Moment, wo du dich diesem Lichtkegel näherst, will der so von dir weg.
Das heißt, du kannst den so durch die Gegend schubsen und scheuchen und schieben,
und das ist einfach sehr schön zu sehen, was das mit Leuten macht,
weil dann alle auf einmal so, ich fang dich.
Kann man da mit Pong spielen?
Naja, man könnte vielleicht auch eine gute Idee.
Aber ja, ich finde das schön, das ist irgendwie was für den MINT und den Brein
und das ist irgendwie was auch softwaretechnisch natürlich eine wirklich schöne,
Herausforderung ist, aber es ist halt vor allem auch erstmal Hardware und Sensorik
technisch eine Herausforderung.
Keine Ahnung ob wir das dann wirklich so machen werden und hinbekommen,
vielleicht werden wir auch feststellen, das ist viel zu teuer,
das ist viel zu schwierig, keine Ahnung oder dauert zu lange,
aber ich wollte den Gedanken zumindest mal durchspielen.
Euch ist schon klar, was ihr dann, wenn ihr denn mal euch auf diesen Pfad begeben
habt, was dann der Endgegner ist. Es muss natürlich Doom drauflaufen.
Das wird schwierig?
Und durch die Bewegung im Raum steuerst du dann, wie du in deinem 360 Grad Doom
durch die Gegend läufst und mit deinem Buzzer kannst du dann nach vorne schießen.
So muss es sein. Darunter geht es jetzt nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, ob für die Zielgruppe das jetzt sozusagen das höchste Ziel ist.
Wir kommen gleich nochmal zu solchen
Ideen mit es ist die Speerspitze der Entwicklung, wenn Doom draufläuft.
Da haben wir gleich nochmal ein Beispiel zu nennen. Da kommen wir vielleicht sogar auch gleich dazu.
Da können wir vielleicht sogar gleich dazu kommen, oder?
Ja, warum nicht?
Genau, weil wir waren ja dann nochmal woanders. und zwar waren wir in Holland.
Dem Land der Freiheit. Holland. Welcher Film?
Freiheit.
Chicken Run. Der von den Machern von Wallace and Gromit. Und da gibt es noch
dieses holländische Huhn.
Ach echt?
Holländischer Akzent hat und irgendwann stürzt auch da dieser angeblich amerikanische
Hahn ab und sagt, er kommt aus dem Land der Freiheit.
Und dann sagt er so, Holland. Naja, egal.
Klingt gut.
Schöner Film.
Muss ich mir anschauen.
In der Tat, schöner Film. So, haben wir denn hier zu allem, was wir gerade gesagt
haben, schon die passenden Links im Chat? Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Wir müssen aber dafür sorgen, dass hier auch mal was ist hier.
Schicken Run und Millimeterwelle und was nicht alles.
Ja, Holland, also wir waren auf der Y 2025.
What Hackers Yearn.
What Hackers Yearn. Also es gibt ja seit 1989 diese Tradition,
in holländischen Hackerkreisen eine Sommerveranstaltung zu machen.
Und nachdem die erste Veranstaltung, die Galactic Hacker Party,
GHC, indoor stattfand in Amsterdam, hat man sich gedacht, na wir sind ja Holländer.
Was machen Holländer im Sommer?
Camping.
Campingplatz.
Deswegen wurde das 1993 zur HEU, Hacking at the End of the Universe,
wo dann das erste Mal das Ganze auf dem Campingplatz stattfand.
Das war dann, sagen wir mal, campingtechnisch noch sehr überschaubar.
Also ich meine, da waren so 20 Zelte vielleicht.
und ich hab bestimmt schon mal erzählt, also mehr war da nicht,
also es gab halt ein Veranstaltungsprogramm, es gab so ein Häuschen auf diesem Campingplatz,
was man halt mitgemietet hat, wo Vortragsraum war und man traf sich halt und
quatschte und machte und tat und,
nebenbei wurde sozusagen auf dem Gelände als besondere,
als Forschungsprojekt sozusagen versucht, ein,
Internetkabel, also ein Tenbase-T-Koaxialkabel von Zelt zu Zelt zu werfen.
Ja, so mit so diesen Steckern und so.
Um am Ende vielleicht da Datenpakete drüber zu senden, um mehr oder weniger
die Möglichkeit zu haben,
aus einem Zelt vielleicht mit einem Computer ein Datenpaket ins Internet zu
schicken, was von 2,19,2 Kilobit pro Sekunde Modems irgendwo in dem Haupthaus
theoretisch hätte ins Internet geschubst werden können.
Also das war so der Level an technischer Herausforderungen, der damals so existierte.
Hat es denn funktioniert?
Ich habe von Leuten gehört, die mal irgendwie ein paar Pakete abgesetzt bekommen haben.
Es war natürlich, diese Koaxialkabel sind natürlich für so, also es war ja für
Outdoor ist das sowieso nicht geeignet.
Es ist auch für Indoor nicht geeignet.
Es ist auch für Indoor nicht geeignet, für Outdoor schon gar nicht.
Insofern war das alles ein bisschen Hanebüchen, aber es war halt irgendwie vor Selals.
Und irgendwie hat es wohl auch mal irgendwie funktioniert, aber das ist einfach
so ein Wackelscheiß, der kann eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Darum ging es aber letzten Endes nicht. Naja, dann ging es weiter,
verschiedenste Iterationen und sie finden halt alle vier Jahre so eine dreibuchstabige
Abkürzung, wo ein H drin ist, irgendwas mit Hackern.
So, dann ging es irgendwie weiter mit HIP und What the Hack und Hacking at Random
und HELL und kriegst du jetzt gar nicht an zusammen.
Und SHA und OOM und was war das letzte? MCH.
Genau, und jetzt gab es halt die Y.
Naja.
Was soll man dazu sagen? Also es war Mixed Bag, würde ich sagen.
Also die Veranstaltung hatte schon ihren Reiz, aber es,
man kann, wenn man jetzt so die anderen Veranstaltungen, die gerade so stattfinden,
so Camp und Electromagnetic Field da so als Maßstab ranlegt,
weil es nicht hatte es nicht so denselben visuellen Reiz.
Also viele weiße Zelte und irgendwie alles sehr so straight aufgebaut,
aber es hatte jetzt nicht so diese wilde Abenteuer Optik und es gab zwar ein paar nette,
Feuerinstallationen hier und da,
Aber naja, also ich weiß nicht, kannst du ja mal sagen, Luca, was dein Eindruck war.
Also ich habe jetzt den Vergleich eigentlich nur mit dem Camp.
EMF habe ich bis jetzt noch nie erlebt. Das Camp ist, wenn ich jetzt mit dem
letzten Camp vergleiche, das Camp ist einfach deutlich bunter.
Was einem sofort auffällt ist, dass das Y war eher weniger bunt beleuchtet,
eher funktional beleuchtet als dekorativ würde ich sagen.
Das ist so eine Sache, die, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass es einfach ist,
das irgendwie besser zu machen, aber man kann es besser machen.
die Installationen hast du gerade gesagt Feuer gab es da es gab zwei doch finde
ich ziemlich coole Installationen,
eine hieß die Firewall das war so eine Strecke von 100 Metern bestimmt auf.
So einem Deich.
Entlang eines kleinen Weges das waren bestimmt 10 bis 20 Flammenwerfer würde
ich sagen die nach oben in die Luft Flammen geschossen haben.
Drei Meter hoch, denke ich.
Und das war dann in verschiedenen Patterns, wie dann da Flammen sich ausgebreitet haben.
Also von dem einen Ende des Weges schießen die Flammen hoch und dann geht das
wie so eine Laola-Welle rüber ans andere Ende.
Das sah schon ziemlich cool aus in der Nacht. Also im Dunkeln sah das super aus.
Und das lief durchgängig? Nee, das lief.
Ich weiß nicht, wann das genau lief.
Ab und zu.
Genau, also man hat es immer mal gesehen.
Weil ansonsten teuer und Pff, Kammwelt und so.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Das ist auch ein guter Punkt, ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Je nachdem, was sie da so verbrennen.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also das andere, was es an Feuer noch gab, war der Ring of Fire.
Das war so eine Konstruktion, so 5, 6 Meter Durchmesser.
Auf so einem Gerüst standen oben, ja oben standen die Propangasflaschen,
glaube ich. Nee, Propangas war unten.
Propangasflaschen waren, also du hast so eine runde Trass gehabt,
die halt so 5, 6 Meter hoch war, wo dann so zehn Feuer-Outlets ungefähr waren,
so in der größten Ordnung.
Und ja, die konnten quasi ferngestellt werden über so ein Relais,
da konntest du dann nochmal mehr dazu machen, damit es halt macht.
Und das ging ja nach oben oder nach unten?
Nach oben. Aber der Clou war, das Ganze war mit so einer, auf dem Rechner lief
so eine Lichtkontrollsoftware und da war dann wiederum ein MIDI-Keyboard angeschlossen.
Das stand dann so in der Mitte und dann konnten da die Kids irgendwie quasi
mit MIDI-Tasten drücken, die dann dazu führten, dass die eine oder die andere
so und ich glaube die Idee war auch so ein bisschen, dass sie so unterschiedlich
getunt war, dass sie unterschiedliche Töne machen soll, dass man da Lied machen konnte.
Das war so, na, ja, könnte man raushören.
Letztlich konnte man also über den Rhythmus schon genug Eindruck erzeugen.
Das hat dann auch großen Spaß gemacht.
Und da habe ich auch mal wieder was über Physik gelernt, weil wir hatten uns
vorher die Installation angeschaut, als es noch nicht so ganz klar war,
da war das noch nicht so ganz zusammengebaut und haben uns überlegt,
was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich genau?
Und dann gab es da halt diese Gasflaschen, also Propangasflaschen,
die so sechs oder acht Stück, die diese gesamte Installation quasi gemeinsam
versorgen sollten, weil du brauchst ja mal relativ viel Gas auf einmal,
so gerade wenn mehrere an sind.
Und naja, Und diese ganzen Gasflaschen standen in so einem halb aufgeschnittenen IBC-Container.
Weißt du, diese großen Wasserwürfel-Container, wo meistens noch so ein Gitter
drumherum ist. Weißt du, was ich meine, oder?
Ich gucke gerade. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Also diese IBC-Container, das ist ja so der Standard. Wofür steht das nochmal?
Intermediate Bulk-Container, genau.
Das passt so ungefähr auf eine Palette drauf.
Ziemlich exakt auf eine Palette.
Ja, genau so. Und stell dir den halt einfach so in der Mitte durchgeschnitten
vor, also wie so eine Wanne und da standen dann halt diese Dinger da drin.
Und das in der Nähe eines Teichs.
Und ja.
Also die Vermutung lag ja irgendwie nahe, dass da ist ein Teich,
da ist Wasser. Wahrscheinlich pumpt man irgendwie Wasser irgendwo hin.
Aber warum?
Genau.
Jetzt für die Feuerinstallation?
Ja, wir haben diese Installation, als sie nicht im Betrieb war und es keiner
erklären konnte, haben wir die Einzelteile da so stehen gesehen und haben uns
halt gefragt, was ist das, was macht das, wie funktioniert das?
Was man halt so macht auf so einem Hackercamp.
Da waren dann halt einfach diese sechs oder acht Propangasflaschen,
die über so einen Mechanismus quasi zu einer großen zusammengeschalt wurden.
Also quer liefen da so Rohre über alle Propangasflaschen, dass das letzten Endes
alles in einen einzelnen Schlauch mündete, um einfach die Gesamtperformance
dieser Probangasflaschen zentral irgendwie zu dieser Installation zu leiten.
Jetzt standen die aber in diesem IBC-Container. Warum?
Warum standen die in einer Wanne?
Um mit dem Wasserdruck irgendwas auf Höhe zu kriegen oder so.
Also Kühlung denke ich mal nicht.
Nee, keine Kühlung.
Aber ist auch nicht so weit weg.
Wofür brauchst du Wasser? Also entweder Verkühlung oder...
Was passiert denn, wenn du Gas aus einer Flasche nimmst?
Was meinst du mit Gas aus einer Flasche?
Du hast eine Gasflasche und du drehst sie auf und das Gas kommt raus.
Und das Gas wird ja dann dekomprimiert.
Ja.
Was passiert, wenn...
Es dehnt sich aus.
Und was tut es dann noch?
Meistens nach oben steigen, weil es leichter ist als Luft.
Ja gut, das hängt dann vom Gas ab, aber... Aber wenn Gas expandiert, was tut es dann?
Naja, es nimmt Wärme auf.
Wenn du das Gas komprimierst, wird es heiß. Wenn du das Gas ausdehnst, wird es kalt.
Die Gasflasche wird kalt. Also wenn du, kennst das doch auch,
wenn du so eine Luftflasche hast, wo einfach so Pressluft ist,
um deine Tastatur sauber zu machen. Dann fängst du an so, pschschsch.
Und dann wird die Flasche kühler.
Dann wird die Flasche auf einmal scheiße kalt.
Was ja dafür auch wichtig ist, dass Gas ist in Flüssigform.
Genau, es ist komprimiert, sodass es eine Zustandsänderung macht.
Durch den Druck wird das Gas flüssig.
Und dann lässt es aus der Flasche raus und dadurch, dass es sich ausdehnen kann,
wird es gasförmig. Und in dem Moment findet sozusagen ein Wärmeaustausch statt
und deswegen wird diese Flasche kalt.
Wenn du also jetzt eine halbe Stunde da stehst und die ganze Zeit so machst
und Unmengen an Propangas in diese Flammen da rein haust, damit es irgendwie
geil aussieht, werden diese Propangasflaschen arschkalt.
Und die werden so kalt.
Dass die außerhalb ihrer Spezifikationen laufen.
Außerhalb, die werden einfach super, super kalt. Da ist dann irgendwie Fetteis drumherum.
Und irgendwann gehen dann die Ventile auch zu. Und dann kommt da einfach nicht mehr genug Gas raus.
Und dann das Wasser, um nicht zu kühlen, sondern um zu wärmen.
Genau, das Wasser ist nämlich zum Wärmen gedacht. Das heißt,
wir betrugen dann aus dem Teich das Wasser da rein.
Und die Flaschen stehen in diesem Wasser. Und während halt das Gas expandiert
und die Flaschen kalt werden, übernimmt sozusagen das Wasser den Transport seiner
Wärme in diese Flaschen.
Also ein inverses Atomkraftwerk quasi. Genau.
Und wieder ein schönes Beispiel für eine Wärmepumpe.
Was ja sozusagen, finde ich ja, man kann das ja nicht oft genug betonen,
der Kühlschrank ist ja die Zukunft dieses Planeten.
Weil ich nochmal kurz den Schritt zurück will, also außerhalb der Spezifikation,
sowas macht mich natürlich nervös.
Ich würde jetzt ja als Laie davon angehen, so du kaufst so eine Propangasflasche
und die hat ein Ventil und egal wie weit ich dieses Ventil aufdrehe,
ich kann die komplette Flasche leerlaufen lassen, ohne dass es jemals aus irgendeiner
Spezifikation noch ausläuft.
Kommt sicherlich drauf an, wie doll du die aufdrehen kannst, so eine Flasche.
Oder haben die die Ventile dann ausgetauscht, um da irgendwie mehr Druck schnell rauszukriegen?
Würde ich alles nicht ausschließen?
Hm. Na gut. Ja, aber prinzipiell verstanden.
Nur wie gesagt, dieses Sicherheitsding überzeugt mich nicht so ganz,
weil ich vermuten würde, dass es so durchreguliert ist, dass man sowas nicht
verkaufen dürfte, wenn man es nicht volle Pulle über eine halbe Stunde auftreten kann.
Na gut, aber was meinst du könnte passieren? Es ist ja jetzt nicht so,
dass die heiß werden. Da würde ich mir auch große Gedanken machen.
Naja, es werden halt sehr kalt. Also so what. Sie frieren sich dann kaum bis zum Erdinneren durch.
Aber nun gut, es wird irgendeinen Grund geben.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall immer wieder begeistert, wenn ich Geräte sehe,
wo Dinge die ganze Zeit zwischen gasförmigen und flüssigen Zustand hin und her
alternieren, weil es einfach eine wunderbare Brücke ist, um Leuten zu erklären,
dass der Kühlschrank die Zukunft dieses Planetens ist.
Ist dir das klar, Ralf?
Ja, durch die Wärmepumpe.
Durch die Wärmepumpe. Die Wärmepumpe ist überall und die Wärmepumpe ist toll
und die Wärmepumpe wird uns alle retten.
Und es ist auch immer erstaunlich, wo es überall schon Wärmepumpen gibt,
nämlich nicht nur in Kühlschränken und in Klimaanlagen.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile Wärmepumpen in Flussdimensionen. Ist dir das aber bewusst?
Es gibt riesige Wärmepumpeninstallationen in Flüssen mittlerweile,
mit denen komplette Stadtteile geheizt werden.
Du versenkst halt einfach Platten in den Fluss, das macht weder dem Fluss noch
was, noch tintieren irgendwas aus,
aber du pumpst halt diese Wärmedifferenz mit demselben Prinzip eines Kühlschranks
aus dem Fluss in dieses Kühlmittel,
und durch einen Kompressor und durch diesen permanenten Kreislauf pumpst du
quasi Wärme von da, wo es die im Überschuss gibt und der Fluss hat einfach mal
extrem viel Wärme einfach raus und damit kannst du irgendwie heizen.
Das ist einfach grandios. Früher haben wir Atomkraftwerke gehabt,
die haben die Flüsse aufgeheizt.
Jetzt machen wir es andersrum.
Auf jeden Fall zurück zu der Installation und überhaupt zu diesem gesamten Ding. Die Y war,
insofern ganz auch interessant, weil es ein paar schöne Installationen gab.
Es hätte auch gerne mehr sein können.
Vielleicht können wir nochmal die eine erwähnen, die fand ich ja wirklich sehr cool.
Ein kleines Häuschen stand auf einem Anhänger.
Also das Häuschen oder so, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht zweimal vier Meter in
der Fläche und vielleicht zweieinhalb Meter hoch oder so.
Es sah wirklich aus wie so ein bisschen wie so ein Hexenhäuschen, So ein spitzen Dach.
Es war glaube ich auch kein echtes Holz. Es war ein verkleideter Trailer oder
so, ein Anhänger, denke ich.
Es sah ganz urig aus und es hatte Augen.
Es hatte Halbkugeln vorne drauf, wo dann hinter, dahinter dann,
genau Tim, danke fürs Bild.
Wir hatten dahinter dann so Augen, die aus diesen Halbkugeln rausguckten und
diese Augen haben rumgeguckt, geblinzelt und auch diverse Emotionen,
also nur über diese Augen dargestellt.
Es hat auch Geräusche gemacht und es war irgendwie ziemlich,
relativ creepy ehrlich gesagt, aber cool.
War cool. Und was das Ding dann auch noch konnte war, es stand irgendwie auf
so einem kleinen Scherenlift.
Es konnte sich ungefähr, glaube ich, so einen halben Meter bis Meter hochfahren.
Was es auch manchmal scheinbar random getan hat.
Da konnte man einfach vorstehen und es war seltsam, aber cool.
Ha, ha, ha.
Ja, sieht gut aus.
Das gab es auch noch. Ja, jenseits der coolen Installation, achso,
ja, es gab noch eine andere Installation, wo auch Millimeter Wave zum Einsatz
kam, von dem Martin und seinen Freunden.
Das muss man auch noch erwähnen, das war auch ganz nice und zwar haben die so,
wie beschreibt man denn das,
so runde Glaslampenkugeln Kugeln gehabt, zehn Stück, die sie auf einer Holzkonstruktion
auf so Ständer gestellt haben und haben mit einem,
Lasertaschenprojektor, den sie irgendwie günstig auf Ebay geschossen haben,
was schon ein paar Jahre alt ist, weißt du, so diese kleinen Mini Laserprojektoren,
die zwar ein super scharfes Bild machen und der auch nicht in der Optik eingestellt
werden müssen, sondern immer scharf sind, egal wie weit du die schickst,
haben sie irgendwie auf Ebay gekapert und quasi von hinten in diese Kugeln reinleuchten lassen.
Was dann im Dunkeln ganz gut funktioniert. Mit dem speziellen Clou,
dass sie vor diesem Laserprojektor, also ein bisschen wie so eine SSD-Festplatte,
irgendwie so in der Größenordnung.
Die können ziemlich klein gebaut werden.
Relativ klein. Aber davor haben sie dann noch so ein Fischaugenobjektiv dazu gebracht.
Das heißt, mit diesem Laser, der halt scharf projiziert, ins Fischauge rein
und damit sozusagen diese komplette Lampenkugel auch ausgefüllt und dort dann
einfach so ein Auge rein projiziert.
Und an diesen Ständern waren dann auch nochmal diese Millimeter-Wave-Sensoren,
die, glaube ich, drei Punkte tracken konnte und haben das halt so im Verbund
laufen lassen und wenn dann halt Leute dran vorbeigingen,
haben halt alle Augen in die Richtung dieser Person geschaut.
Also auch wirklich super nice und sehr schick gemacht und so schön einfach auch.
Also wirklich eine geile Idee. Also das waren so, würde ich sagen,
so ein bisschen die Highlights von dem, was uns aufgefallen ist.
Dann kommen wir erstmal zu den guten Sachen. Was auch ganz cool war, ist die Y-Map.
Also es gab halt eine Karte, eine Online-Karte, die gibt es auch immer noch unter map.y2025.org.
und diese Karte enthält, wie man sich das so denken kann, halt alle.
Infrastrukturelemente, also alle Zelte, alle Villages, alles,
wo kann man parken, wo kann man zelten,
wo sind die Workshop-Zelte, wo ist das Infodex, Pipapo, also wirklich eine richtig
gute Karte, die dann eben auch noch verschiedene Layer hat, das gab es ja auch schon auf dem Camp,
soweit erstmal auch nichts sonderlich Überraschendes.
Genau, auf dem Streetmap sehe ich hier als Infrastruktur.
Klar, auf dem Streetmap basiert und sie haben auch spezielle GPS-Geräte verwendet.
Das habe ich leider nur so am Rande mitbekommen, aber ich glaube,
die haben so hochpräzise Vermessungen vorgenommen vorher.
Also wirklich mit so kalibrierten GPS-Geräten das ganze Gelände und den Teil
ausgemessen, sodass die Karte also auch wirklich super akkurat war.
aber der absolute Brüller war es gibt auch noch ein Vehicle Layer,
den man einschalten konnte, das kann man auch mal noch einschalten,
aber da kommt jetzt leider nichts aber es gab halt jedes Fahrzeug was dort rumfuhr
und irgendwie einen offiziellen Auftrag hatte also diese ganzen kleinen Trucks
teilweise Diesel, teilweise elektrisch,
die also irgendwas hin und her transportiert haben oder vielleicht auch das
ein oder andere waren die auch Fahrräder dabei?
Fahrräder und glaube ich auch noch ein paar Personen, die auch noch mit so einem
Trecker rumgelaufen sind.
Ja, ein Helikopter auch.
Und das war eigentlich ganz geil und das ist vor allem relativ günstig zu haben.
Was also nämlich hier zum Einsatz kam, war ein,
Sino, wie heißt das Teil? Sino Track 4G GDS.
ST915L. Ich hab hier mal so einen Amazon-Link.
Ohne Affiliate-Code.
Und ja, stehen jetzt hier mal so für 46 Euro. Kriegst du sicherlich irgendwie
ein Dutzend billiger. Keine Ahnung. Und das sind so Teile.
Das hat so die Größe, so eine Handvoll Geräte ist das.
Und da kannst du eine SIM-Karte reinstecken.
Ah, okay.
Die hat halt LTE und hat GPS und dann kannst du das Ding konfigurieren,
ob es permanent oder nur, wenn es sich bewegt, eine,
Meldung abgibt, dass sich die Position geändert hat.
Fette Magnete dran.
Richtig, mit Magneten kannst du einfach unten irgendwo an so ein Metallgehäuse
ranbammeln, musst es nicht groß festschrauben, keine Ahnung,
wie sie es ja jetzt im Einzelnen gemacht haben, aber davon hatten sie irgendwie
so einen Satz von, weiß nicht,
wie viele Geräte haben wir gesehen, so 30 in der Größenordnung?
Ja, kommt hin, ja.
So in etwa, ne? Und das war halt dann wirklich sehr cool mit anzuschauen,
weil du konntest dann einfach diese Map aufmachen und du sahst halt die Fahrzeuge
rumfahren und abgesehen davon,
dass das halt ganz lustig anzusehen war, wir haben nochmal bei der Projektleitung
gefragt, wieso ihre Erfahrungen so sind und meinte so, ja, es wäre einfach total super,
vor allem, wenn die Geräte halt irgendwo abgestellt, also die Fahrzeuge irgendwo
abgestellt wurden und erstmal keiner weiß, wo die sind.
Klar, ich meine, auf so einem riesen Gelände und dann, wo ist der Transporter?
Und dann hast du es halt einfach in Echtzeit gesehen und es war wirklich in Echtzeit.
Also es war echt interessant zu sehen, wie so das Treiben da sich auf dem Gelände
abgespielt hat, aber du konntest dann eben nebenbei auf dem Laptop-Bildschirm
auch noch sehen, so ja, da fährt er gerade, der Gator.
Das war ganz cool und das Ganze wurde dann auch, und das ist auch auf jeden
Fall so eine Sache, also sowas muss auf jeden Fall auf ein Camp auch kommen. Also das,
schrie so nach Willhabentechnologie.
Und zusätzlich zu diesen GPS-Trackern und dieser Y-Map gab es dann auch noch einen MQTT-Server.
Und ich muss sagen, ich hatte mit MQTT noch gar nicht so viel praktische Erfahrung bisher.
Sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was das ist. Luca,
das wäre doch mal was für dich.
Ja genau, also MQTT, ich habe das vorher immerhin schon mal benutzt, jetzt nicht oft,
aber es ist der Message-Bus oder der Message-Broker, der in der IoT-Welt eigentlich der Standard ist.
Also IoT gleich Internet of Things.
Genau, du hast kleine Geräte, die wenig Strom verbrauchen und kleine Nachrichten hin und her schicken.
Dafür eignet sich MQTT gut, weil es hat einen relativ geringen Overhead,
also simples Protokoll einigermaßen, kleine Pakete, wenig drumherum.
Also jetzt halt nicht zu vergleichen mit irgendwie den anderen Message-Brokern
wie, keine Ahnung, Kafka, RabbitMQ, was es da sonst noch alles gibt,
auch in den Clouds gemanaged, gehostet, was auch immer.
MQTT ist ein kleines, leichtgewichtiges Ding und es funktioniert so,
dass du Messages auf einen Broker publishst und diese Messages,
die haben alle ein Topic.
Und so ein Topic ist so eine Hierarchie, so ein Segment, also aus einzelnen Segmenten bestehend.
Das kann dann das sein wie bei der Y war es jetzt beispielsweise,
es gab das Topic GPS slash Vehicles, glaube ich.
Und dann dahinter wurden die ganzen Messages gepublished, die die GPS-Informationen hatten.
Und das war nicht alles. Also es gab noch viel mehr Informationen neben GPS auf diesem MQTT.
Aber das hast du erstmal eingesammelt, mal mitgelockt für eine Weile und dann
konnten wir so eine Heatmap bauen aus diesen ganzen Aktivitäten der Fahrzeuge
und das war dann sehr interessant,
weil es sich das auch über das Gelände hinaus erstreckte,
weil du konntest dann eben sehen, dass bestimmte Fahrzeuge auch Routen in die
benachbarte Stadt nach Alkmaar gemacht haben und du konntest halt genau sehen, ah,
hier, der ist also der Bahn-Shuttle, der fährt immer so zum Bahnhof und holt
die Leute am Bahnhof ab und eine andere Route,
die sehr beliebt war, führte dann zu dem nächstgrößeren,
Jumbo-Supermarkt, wo dann viel eingekauft wurde und so weiter.
Ich habe hier übrigens auch nochmal geschaut, was denn die Kategorien waren
an GPS-getrackten Items.
Truck, Person, Crane, Helikopter, Ship Tractor, Bus, Car.
Trailer Bicycle Also wer hat mal nach diesem Helikopter gefragt,
was es denn damit auf sich hat.
Aber irgendwie Keiner, nee, also es sind auch nur zwei Datenpunkte da drin gewesen
also zwei GPS Punkte glaube ich.
Drohne wäre ja auch noch ganz nett gewesen.
Klar.
Es gab ab und zu mal welche. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass man die ganze Zeit
da so Ukraine-Front-Feeling hatte, aber es wird einem immer schon so ein bisschen
anders, muss ich sagen, wenn man jetzt so drohend über sich rüberfliegen gehört
nach den letzten Jahren.
Und ja, also dieses MQTT ist echt wirklich sehr ergiebig und sie haben halt
wirklich jeden Scheiß da reingeballert.
Also nicht alles, was irgendwie sinnvoll war, würde ich mal sagen.
Also du hast auch die ganzen Ticket-Sales und wie viele T-Shirts verkauft wurden,
waren alle bei MQTT abrufbar.
Keine Ahnung, ob das Finanzamt das mittlerweile auch per MQTT überprüft,
aber naja, war halt einfach drin.
Was viel interessanter gewesen wäre, wären dann die Check-Ins,
die haben sie dann komischerweise nicht drin gehabt.
Also das wäre ja mal interessant gewesen, wirklich in Realtime.
Wann die Leute anreisen und so weiter, wo sie eingecheckt werden,
wann sie eingecheckt werden.
Das wäre in der Tat mal ganz interessant gewesen, aber das wiederum wurde nicht generiert.
Gab es noch einen anderen Bereich, der aktiv war?
Ja, ich glaube, da gab es noch andere Sachen, die benutzt wurden,
aber die habe ich mir nicht genau angeschaut.
Also beim Camp gäbe es noch so viele Sachen, Stromverbrauch und all diese ganzen
Sachen könnte man halt darüber in Echtzeit channeln und auch in Echtzeit dann eben noch realisieren.
Nutzung der Access Points, wenn man das so durchsuchen will.
Ja, alles. Also eigentlich willst du halt alles, du willst alles über MQTT rausballern,
was jetzt nicht potenziell ein bisschen so Privacy-Probleme hat.
Security Nightmares produziert.
Ja, aber es ist halt spannend, weil es halt einfach dem ganzen Camp dann die Möglichkeit gibt,
in Echtzeit auch mit diesen Daten zu arbeiten und sie aufzubereiten und nicht so, ja,
dann warten wir mal am Schluss, wenn die dann ein paar Slides zeigen,
sondern du kannst halt alles mögliche monitoren und es ist einfach ein schönes
Spielzeug, würde ich sagen, für die Zeit der Veranstaltung.
Ja, soviel zu MQTT vielleicht. Achso, ich habe dann auch noch ein bisschen MQTT gemacht.
Ich habe ja irgendwie so meinen Teltonika-Router in meinem Wohnwagen und mein
Victron-System und während der Teltonika GPS hat, konnte der andere,
ich habe es nicht mit MQTT gemacht, genau, es hat mit MQTT nicht funktioniert,
aber es hätte fast funktioniert.
Ja, egal. Ich habe da ein bisschen rumgehackt und dann irgendwie auch noch GPS-Experimente gemacht. Ja, was,
auch noch gut war, es gab einen Supermarkt.
Der war fantastisch, ja. Ich habe jeden Morgen frische Brötchen geholt.
Einfach geil. Also so ein Supermarkt ist schon ein Feature auf so einem Hacker-Event,
was ich eigentlich nicht mehr missen möchte.
Also die hatten nicht nur Brötchen, sondern auch so Fla.
Genau, Fla hatten sie jede Menge Schweinereien in der Richtung gab es.
Dann so Sachen wie, keine Ahnung, Konservendosen mit Bohnen oder anderen Sachen.
Getränke, aber auch so Hygieneartikel natürlich.
Zahnpasta, der ganze Kram. Das ist schon sehr praktisch. Relativ früh aufgehabt scheinbar.
Und frische Eier, frische Brötchen. Alles. alles.
Ja, das war wirklich gut. Also kann ich dir anders sagen.
Ja, und dann gab es aber auch noch so ein paar Sachen, die waren nicht so geil gelaufen.
Und das muss man auch nochmal aufgreifen, weil das einfach so eine komische Tradition auch ist.
Nämlich äh,
Die Badges. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Das Giveaway, mehr oder weniger finanziert von Sony Ben.
Das ist ja so eine amerikanische Hacker-Konferenz-Geschichte.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wo das so seinen Anfang genommen hat,
aber ich würde mal vermuten,
das erste Device war halt auch wirklich einfach nur ein Badge in elektronisch,
wo du deinen Namen quasi auf einem Display anzeigen konntest mit irgendwie einem kleinen LCD.
oder was weiß ich, was da die erste Iteration von gewesen sein mag. Vermute mal sowas.
Und dann haha, hast du es halt irgendwie elektronisch und es ist irgendwie ein
geiles Elektronikprojekt und dann gibst du das auch noch an alle Teilnehmer
aus und jeder hat so ein bisschen was mit nach Hause nehmen und hier guck mal mein Badge.
Und irgendwie ist das mit diesem Badge halt so eine Sache, die so komplett überhand
genommen hat, weil sich dadurch dann so dieses ist,
oh, wenn wir so eine Hacker-Konferenz machen, dann müssen wir da auch so ein
Elektronikteil produzieren, was es so vorher noch nicht gegeben hat und was irgendwas tut.
Und das wäre ja geil, wenn man da Punkt, Punkt, Punkt mitmachen könnte.
Doom drauflaufen!
Meinetwegen auch. Doom drauflaufen lässt, aber...
Ich bin alt genug, dass ich das Original Doom noch selber live bei Release gespielt habe.
Das ist schon wichtig.
Ich bin genug, dass ich das schon ignoriert habe bei seinem Release.
93 war das glaube ich, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ja, da war ich schon zehn Jahre über Spiele hinweg gekommen.
Anyway, worauf wollte ich hinaus?
Soll ich irgendwas tun und es uferte aus.
Naja und auch auf dem Camp und auch beim Electromagnetic Field gibt es halt
diese Tradition und wir haben da auch schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen über
das eine oder andere Projekt.
Und ich muss sagen,
Während ich es generell sehr erstrebenswert finde,
so Projekte zu verfolgen, wo Leute Custom-Hardware bauen,
die dann auf das Interesse von Leuten, die damit was anderes bauen wollen oder
damit rumspielen wollen oder rumexperimentieren wollen, Also wo du sozusagen
ein Gerät hast, was Komponenten kombiniert, die du jetzt in so den Alltagsgeräten,
wie jetzt im Smartphone oder früher mit Laptops hatten,
so in dieser Kombination nicht gibt oder nicht in dieser Portabilität gibt oder
nicht in dieser Anordnung gibt oder mit so Bells und Whistles und kleinen Interfaces
und Schnittstellen und Outputs und was halt auch immer drin ist.
über die Jahre gab es da bestimmten so ein paar honorable mentions auf dem Camp
gab es ja mal so ein Teil, das war dann irgendwie so ein Software Defined Radio
mit ganz viel Funk und das war irgendwie super nerdy.
Da dachte ich mir schon so, ja okay gut ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz
sicher seht es mir nach, also manchmal war es so dieses Gerät wurde gebaut Und
es wurde danach jedem Teilnehmer eins zur Verfügung gestellt.
Also man hat quasi mit in den Eintrittspreis das reinkalkuliert,
dass dann auch die Baukosten von diesem Device mit abgedeckt sind.
Und dann hatte man aber auch quasi das Anrecht, sich eins abzuholen und dann
hat man das dann irgendwo vor Ort eingesammelt.
Ich glaube, bei den letzten beiden auf dem Camp war das nicht der Fall.
Bei den letzten beiden nicht mehr. Das hat man dann irgendwann auch sein gelassen
und hat gesagt, nur wenn du eins haben willst, kannst du jetzt hier mit deinem
Ticket gleich eins mitbestellen und dann liegt halt auch eins für dich da.
Das finde ich auch sinnvoll.
Das war diesmal jetzt nicht so.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das irgendwie Sponsoren gab, die das dann irgendwie komplett
finanziert haben und dann hat man halt gesagt, wir machen dann irgendwie für
jeden eins. Spoiler, hat nicht jeder eins bekommen.
Trotzdem, diese Badges, ähm.
Sind dann irgendwie so ein bisschen ausgeartet in verschiedenen Richtungen.
Vor allem sind sie immer sehr viel größer geworden.
Also diese Flower-Batch, so schön es auch war, also das war ja schon so eine
Flavor-Flav-Installation.
Also da musste man eigentlich noch dazu rappen, wenn man das Ding um den Hals hatte.
Aber es hat manchen Leuten gefallen. Es hat auch ein erstaunlich schickes Goui gehabt.
Und vor allem war es mal insofern was Innovatives, als dass es eben so speziell
so mit Musik und Optik und so weiter gearbeitet hat.
Also eine schöne Idee und ein schönes Ding.
Nichts, was ich jetzt Badge nennen würde, auch wenn man irgendwie diesen Begriff
für dieses Default-Hacker-Konferenz-Device irgendwie immer noch so im Hinterkopf hat.
Naja, also auf der Y gab es auf jeden Fall ein Badge. Das hieß auch Badge.
Das Badge-Team hat dann irgendwie dieses Ding entwickelt und.
Die Ziele waren mir nicht so ganz klar. Also ich weiß nicht so genau,
worauf man hinaus wollte.
Ah, du hast es dabei.
Ich habe eins.
In einem Meshback, wie es sich gehört.
In einem Meshback, wie es sich das gehört. Und,
naja, du kannst es ja mal in die Hand nehmen und deine Eindrücke schildern.
Ich mag ja sowas.
Du magst sowas, okay gut.
Ich mag sowas. Also es hat so den Formfaktor von einem Palm.
Also ich würde so Postkarte sagen.
Hat der jetzt Game Boy gesagt?
Game Boy ist kleiner, oder?
Da bin ich zu alt. Also so ein Palm Pre oder so ähnlich.
Der originale Game Boy kommt von der Größe schon ganz gut hin. Vielleicht dicker.
Also es,
mich spricht das an.
Okay, dich spricht das an.
Also was sehen wir? Wir haben halt ein quadratisches Display. Das ist ungefähr,
3x3 cm, hätte ich gesagt, 2,5 x 2,5 cm und unten drunter halt eine vollständige
QWERTY Tastatur, so und das ist halt schon mal irgendwie geil, die drückt sich gut,
das ist nicht irgendwie sowas Gummiertes oder so, sondern das ist so ATM Style,
das sind gute, auch mit meinen großen Fingern gerade noch zu drückende Taster.
Und ja, es ist halt jetzt mal irgendwie so ein Mini-Laptop-Computer-Dingsy.
Das wäre so die erste Reaktion.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was man sich um den Hals hängt, sondern es ist ein Mini-Computer,
mit dem man irgendwelche Dinge tun kann.
Naja, es hat unten aber einen Anschluss für ein Lanyard.
Also es sind extra nochmal so zwei Klemmen, wo du so ein...
Aber es ist schwer.
Es ist schwer, ja.
Ist das jetzt hier die Standardausstattung mit diesen zwei großen Batterien? Okay.
Also ich habe dieses Lanyard auch mal zum Testen bei MIME angeschlossen und
geguckt, wie sich das um den Hals anfühlt.
Also schwer heißt 300 Gramm, 400 Gramm?
Fühlt sich echt schwer an, wenn man es um den Hals trägt.
Das baumelt vor allem halt rum.
Diese Antenne hier, die eine einer...
Ja, die Antenne gehört zu einem der echt coolen Hardware-Features,
die das Ding zu bieten hat. Es hat ein LORA-Modul drauf.
Long Range, LORA, der Funkstandard.
Ich poste mal schnell dem Bild im Slack, damit die Leute überhaupt wissen.
Diese Antenne, das war auch...
Machen wir einen Kronkorken daneben, damit man den Maßstab hat.
Das ist eine Banane, Ralf, eine Banane, for scale.
Ja, haben wir jetzt hier aber nun mal keine.
Bananen sind nicht einheitlich groß.
Ja, doch, doch, doch.
So, also die Antenne ist...
Genau, bei der Antenne waren wir, das war das einzige Ding, was man tatsächlich assemblen musste.
Man musste den Connector für die Antenne die man draufschraubt,
den Connector, den musstest du einmal dran löten.
Das ist jetzt nicht, glaube ich, das Problem, wenn man schon mal gelötet hat
oder jemand kennt, der das macht.
Ja, das war die Lora-Antenne.
Das Blöde an dieser Lora-Antenne ist, am Ende hatte sie eigentlich gar keine Funktion.
Es gab keine Verwendung dafür.
Wie auch für viele andere Komponenten dieses Geräts.
Wie auch die andere Komponente, die du da gerade schon angefasst hast,
es gab einen Vibrationsmotor da dran.
Der aber irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert.
Weiß nicht, ob der funktioniert. Er wurde nicht benutzt.
Ja, ich habe auch gehört, dass er irgendwie wohl...
Wo ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Ein-Ausschalter?
Der ist an der linken Seite. Oder an der rechten Seite, sorry.
Einmal drauf drücken, dann geht's an.
Oh, eine beleuchtete Tastatur. Ihr seid ja wahnsinnig.
Ja, die Tastatur ist auch noch hintergrundbeleuchtet.
Also die ist aber schon geil, Tim. Diese Tastatur, die macht mich echt an.
Ich finde die eigentlich auch cool.
Ob man sie braucht und wofür aber vom Formfaktor her und wie sich das anfühlt, ist das super.
Okay, und dieses Display ist auch erstaunlich hochauflösend. Snake. Ich hab Snake.
Es gibt auch Doom, bevor die Frage kommt.
Ja, ja, das hoffe ich doch. Das las ich.
Also man kann es nicht gut spielen, aber es startet irgendwie. Und naja.
Also es war auf jeden Fall schon ein ziemlicher Kampf, dieses Gerät überhaupt
in diesen Zustand zu bringen, dem du jetzt hier irgendwie gerade versuchst zu benutzen.
Aber dir wird auch auffallen, viel ist da nicht drauf.
Also du hast halt irgendwie eine App, mit der du deinen Namen eingeben kannst
und naja, dann irgendwie so Snake und Doom und Also Doom ist.
Jetzt hier nicht mehr drauf. Ich prangere das an.
Wie?
Was? Doom ist wieder weg?
Ist nicht mehr drauf?
Also ich habe hier sechs Apps drauf. Das ist Sponsors, OTA-Updater,
Name-Tag, Snake, Hello und System Settings.
Ja, dann gibt es kein Doom mehr. Dann ist das mit dem letzten Update rausgespielt.
Ja, die Lizenz ist ausgelaufen.
Ja, aber das war ja die Shareware-Version da drauf.
Checking for Updates. Connecting to WiFi.
Ja, da müssen wir erstmal noch...
Das war kein Touch-Display, ne?
Kein Touch-Display. Ja, naja. Es hat sich also leider um dieses Batch ein längeres
Drama auf dieser Veranstaltung auch ergeben.
Also ich sag mal gleich vorneweg, ich will das, ich kann das alles nicht bewerten,
weil ich nicht genau weiß, wie es genau gelaufen ist und mir ist es auch ehrlich
gesagt am Ende ziemlich egal,
wer da mit wem wie umgegangen ist.
Auf jeden Fall hatten die Leute sich in den Haaren.
Und das ursprüngliche Team, was dieses Batch entwickelt hat mit dem ersten Design,
hat sich wohl an Entscheidungen von Organisationsgruppen gerieben.
Und es gab Menschen, die nicht einverstanden waren mit bestimmten Entscheidungen,
was dann dazu führte, dass dann irgendwann dieses ganze Team den Löffel hat
fallen lassen und ein anderes Team diese Arbeit von diesem Batch fortsetzte,
ein paar Design-Umentscheidungen gemacht hat.
Unter anderem diese Batterien, die da hinten drauf kamen, haben wohl ein anderes
Batteriekonzept ersetzt und so weiter.
Noch ein paar andere Entscheidungen, von denen ich jetzt nicht genau weiß,
wann, wie, wo, welche, von wem getroffen wurden. Auf jeden Fall hatte das alles...
Zur Folge, dass die Fertigstellung dieses Gerätes sich dann doch sehr verzögert hat.
Und ich finde es auch schön, mit welcher Beherzhaftigkeit du das jetzt so in
die Hand nimmst und da so hinten reingreifst, weil es gab nämlich einen riesen…
Du spielst mit dem Feuer. Du spielst mit dem Feuer.
Wortwörtlich.
Die Hauptverzögerung war natürlich, dass das neue Design ein bisschen flott
war und man so verschiedene Firehazards ausfindig gemacht hat,
wo so Kontakte nicht richtig abgedeckt waren und die Batterien sind auch relativ powerful.
Man hält hier eine Platine in der Hand, über die Strom läuft.
Ja, man greift sie auch so direkt an den Batterien, wenn da jetzt erstmal kein Gehäuse ist.
Das kam natürlich nicht mit, auch wenn es natürlich so 3D-Druckvorlagen ohne Ende gibt.
Aber weil man dann eben auf den letzten Metern diesen Firehazard erkannt hat,
wurden dann irgendwie all diese ganzen Platinen nochmal an Bestimmungen gestellt.
Mit Warnhinweisen versehen.
Nee, nicht mit Warnhinweisen.
Naja, das aber auch. Warnhinweise gab es nur wirklich viele.
Ja, das auch noch, aber das nicht alleine.
Es wurden einfach strategisch verschiedene Stellen mit Epoxidharz noch überstrichen,
sodass sie dann also noch am ersten und zweiten Tag dort mit diesen Platinen
saßen und das Epoxidharz in so UV-Lampen aus dem Nagelstudio ausgertet.
Ja, ich sehe es jetzt an den Batterien vorne dran. Ach du meine Güte. Naja, nun.
Tja, also da hätte er einfach in der Enclosure halt noch drum gemusst, ne?
Ja.
Hätte, hätte, hätte. Das Ding ist...
Doom Generic. So, ich arbeite mich vor. Ich habe das übrigens jetzt gerade hier
mal in dein WLAN reingebracht und jetzt lade ich mal Doom runter.
Wie? Du kannst das jetzt runterladen?
Na, ich hoffe doch. Ich bin jetzt hier in dem System Updates und mir wird es
hier angeboten. Dann gucken wir doch mal, ob das geht.
Und Doom wird dir in den System-Updates angeboten? Ja. Ah, okay.
Wir haben vorhin noch die neueste Version draufgeladen, die wir jetzt noch gar
nicht ausprobiert haben, weil die davor waren einfach alle nicht benutzbar.
Ich habe das jetzt mal als App-Store interpretiert und es scheint zulässig gewesen zu sein.
Und er lädt jetzt hier Doom runter.
Ah ja, okay. Dann gucken wir mal. Genau. Wir hatten so unterschiedliche Erfolge mit Updates.
Spaß am Gerät, Tim.
Ja, ja. Das war ein bisschen schwierig am Anfang. Also man merkte auf jeden Fall.
Dass ich… Currently updating CrackMe. Okay.
Es gab jetzt nicht überbordend viel Dokumentation für dieses Gerät und es dauerte
einfach sehr lange, bis man es überhaupt erstmal in Betrieb nehmen konnte.
Es lief irgendwie tausendmal in Buttschleifen und was nicht alles.
Also das war insgesamt keine besonders schöne Experience.
Aber das Hauptproblem, was ich einfach mit diesem Teil habe, es ist halt kein Badge.
Und es ist vor allem auch kein Gerät, was irgendwie sagt, ich löse ein Problem auf diesem Event.
außer mein Name, ich meine da kann man sich natürlich auch wirklich einfach
ein Badge ranhängen ans T-Shirt, aber wenn es dann halt irgendwie so krass kompliziert
und aufwendig wird und dann noch ein Firehizard ist dann ist man schon so ein
bisschen am Ziel vorbeigeschossen,
und das ist irgendwie das, was ich mir wünschen würde dass wenn man jetzt für
so ein Event nachdenkt was man da haben will dass man sich Gedanken darüber
macht, was tut wirklich Not Tut überhaupt irgendwas Not?
Muss man jetzt hier noch mehr Elektronik, die nur in Schubladen landet, produzieren?
Oder schafft man halt irgendwas langfristiges, was wirklich über einen langen
Zeitraum entwickelt wird und so eine Iteration durchmacht?
So machen das im Übrigen die Engländer, sagen wir gleich nochmal was zu.
Oder beschränkt man sich auf so eine Kernfunktion und schafft etwas,
was wirklich eine Hilfe ist.
Und dann muss man sich natürlich fragen, okay, was wäre eine Hilfe?
Und ich habe das Thema hier glaube ich auch schon mal gehabt.
Wir hatten das schon ein, zweimal sogar.
Genau. Muss mich auch nicht unbedingt wiederholen, aber so im Kern,
man will Leute finden, man will benachrichtigt werden, also es geht im Wesentlichen
ums Finden, Gefunden, Werden, etc.
so eine Map im Web zu haben, wunderbar aber eine Map auf so einem Device wäre
halt sehr viel sinnvoller,
GPS oder Lokalisierung mit WLAN oder mit Lora, das wäre dann halt ganz sinnvoll
und da kann man dann hindenken, aber ich finde dieses Gerät ist viel zu groß, viel zu bulky,
man trägt das nicht mit sich rum, diese riesigen Batterien, also da sind einfach
sehr viele Entscheidungen gefällt worden, wo ich mich halt frage lohnt es, den Aufwand.
Also es ist, ich meine, man setzt ja hier eine Plattform in die Welt,
die sehr wenig User hat und die naja, nach dem Event halt dann auch erstmal
keine Rolle mehr spielt.
Das ist dann auch so ein bisschen schade zu sehen, dass Leute da so viel Energie
reinstecken und dann kommt es nicht wirklich zu so einer Anwendung,
weil es sich verzögert auf der ganzen,
Komplexität und dazu kommt halt auch noch dieser ganze andere Stress,
der dann halt auf der sich dann auch leider am Ende der Veranstaltung auch nochmal
fortgesetzt hat, dass sich da wieder Gruppen in die Haare bekommen haben.
Dann gab es dann irgendwie noch so ein Ragequid von dem Lagerteam und es war
einfach alles ganz furcht.
Naja, also jetzt hast du dein Doom gestartet, ja?
Jetzt haben wir hier Doom einen Start, genau.
Kannst du es auch spielen?
Und ich kann es auch spielen. Dann hat das auch WASD-Steuerung. Was?
Keine WASD-Steuerung?
Was soll das denn sein?
Gleich einschmelzen.
Ja, weil dann ist es natürlich irgendwie wirklich bescheuert spielbar.
Da hat wieder jemand nicht nachgedacht.
Ja, vielleicht noch ein Satz zu dem ähnlichen Ansatz. Die entwickeln dann die
Plattformen immer wieder weiter und hatten ja, das habe ich glaube ich beim
Bericht vom letzten EMF letztes Jahr schon berichtet,
gab es ja sogar so Hardware-Module und so, das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Also ich will jetzt eigentlich nicht alles schlecht reden, ich war nur so ein bisschen,
underwhelmed von dem Ansatz, weil man es sinnvoller wäre, was zu bauen,
was wirklich cool ist und zwar nicht cool im Sinne von, oh guck mal,
was das hier für Tech-Specs hat.
Ja, oh der Bildschirm ist groß, er hat viele Pixel und die Tastatur ist hinterher
und beleuchtet, aber die Tastatur benutzt du halt die Hälfte der Zeit irgendwie nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich wäre ein anderer Formfaktor, der einfach kompakter ist, sehr viel einladender.
Aber es hat einen C64-Emulator drauf.
Ja, aber ohne das Kettenlaufwerk.
Ja, also wir hatten das Thema ja in der Tat schon ein, zwei Mal.
So sehr mich jetzt gerade dieses Gadget hier erfreut, In der Sache bin ich da ganz bei dir.
Das ist toll, dass sowas jetzt irgendwie geht und diese Tastatur ist wirklich
cool, aber es löst halt irgendwie kein Problem.
Ich finde die Grundfrage muss sein, welches Problem löse ich,
was mein Handy nicht besser kann.
Richtig.
So und daran muss man sich abarbeiten. Was ist ein Formfaktor,
was ist irgendwie ein Feature, wo ein Handy einfach zu unpraktisch,
klobig, nicht drauf spezialisiert, batteriesparend genug, was auch immer ist.
die Grundfrage, an der muss man sich abarbeiten.
Das sehe ich genauso. So, jetzt
will ich hier aber endlich wieder Basic programmieren. So, 10 Print hallo.
20 Goto 10. So, kann mal einer die guten Poke-Befehle nochmal posten.
Wie die gingen? 53 280.
Gab da so manches.
Mach mal 53 280.
Ja, ich bin jetzt gerade erst nochmal bei meinem Print hier.
Wo ist denn hier die Anführungszeichen? Macht schon mal weiter.
Vielleicht kriegst du ja dieses Maze hin. Kennt ihr das? Dieses Maze,
was so die Backslashes und Forward Slashes ausgibt zufällig.
Ich hab recht gehabt. Ich hab recht gehabt.
Womit?
Mit dem Poke.
Ich habe es mir echt gemerkt, nach 30, 40 Jahren.
Ja, irre, ne?
Jetzt musst du es auch eintippen.
Ja, ja, sofort. Warte mal. 10-Print, hallo. Mal gucken, ob das hier auch alles
geht. So, 20, gut, oh, 10.
Das hat man noch damals bei Carstadt.
Jetzt hast du aber keine Run-Stop-Taste.
Die du dann auf den Programm anhalten kannst.
Und auch keine Restore-Taste.
Das sehen wir dann danach. So, Run war das. Oder musste man Run 10?
Weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Na, Run funktioniert. Na, guck.
Okay. So, Escape.
Kannst du wieder neu starten. So, und jetzt nehmen wir nochmal deinen Poke.
Moment, jetzt muss er sich erstmal wieder zusammenbooten hier.
Na?
Ach, damals. So. Jetzt ist er jetzt hier schon startklar. Ja,
so, Poke. Was hast du gesagt?
5-3-2-8-0.
5-3 Was?
5-2-8-0.
2-8-0. Ich gehöre zu dem die sich nur noch vier Zahlen merken kann. Komma eins.
Ein weißer Hintergrund.
Der Rahmen ist weiß.
Fantastisch.
Und ich glaube 53281 ist dann die Hintergrundfarbe für den Innenbereich.
Gut, okay. Genug der C4. Ich habe irgendwo zu Hause auch einen C64 Hardware-Emulator.
Ein Hardware-Emulator? Ja, so eine dieser Mini-Teile, die es so vor ein paar Jahren mal gab.
So ein Viertelformfaktor vom Original C64, aber so, dass du noch so gerade eben
die Tastatur bedienen kannst und dann mit so voreingestellten 50 Klassiker-Games,
die dann über Emulator laufen. Das ist schon eine lustige Welt.
Da läuft dann ein kleiner Computer drin, der das macht.
Genau.
Ich habe nämlich...
Der auch so einigermaßen vom Timing her so getunt ist, dass er dann mit dem
Spielen und dem Joystick, den gab es dann auch mit dabei.
Also worauf ich gerade gestoßen bin, ist auf Commodore.net verkaufen die so
ein Crowdfunding-Projekt scheinbar.
Ein FPGA-basierter C64.
Nee, ich glaube das ist kein Crowdfunding. Das ist tatsächlich eine Firma,
die jetzt mal wieder die ganzen Commodore-Rechte gekauft hat und dann tatsächlich
dieses Produkt jetzt auf den Markt wirft.
Okay.
So habe ich das gelesen.
Ja, also okay, stimmt. Das ist so ein Batch, den die hier verkaufen.
Ich habe das als Crowdfunding interpretiert.
Also kurzer Nachtrag zu diesem Badge. Ich weiß schon, ich werde mit diesem Badge
nicht wirklich irgendwas anfangen können.
Wenn es Leute gibt, die der Meinung sind, ja, ich will das jetzt auch wirklich
programmieren und ich habe da auch eine geile Idee und ich habe mir auch die
Doku vorher angeschaut und ich weiß, was auf mich zukommt, dann könnt ihr mir
gerne eine Mail schreiben, dann spende ich das Ding vielleicht weiter,
aber bevor es bei mir einfach nur in der Schublade versauert.
Wie fährt man das denn runter?
Zweimal den Anschalter.
Genau.
Hm.
Ja, ja. So viel vielleicht zur Why. Es sei denn, du hast noch Fragen.
Fragen nicht, aber einen kleinen Nachtrag, der da vielleicht inhaltlich gerade
reinpackt zur Hacker-Installation.
Jetzt nicht Outdoor, sondern auf einem Kongress. Was darf auf keinem Kongress fehlen?
An Event Space?
Ein Bällebad.
Genau. Ein Bällebad. Wisst ihr eigentlich, Das war es wirklich?
Ja.
Das war nicht abgesprochen. Wisst ihr denn eigentlich, wer das Bällebad erfunden hat?
So generell.
So ganz generell. Wer eigentlich auf die Idee gekommen ist und das als erstes
implementiert hat. So, jetzt war ich ja in Schweden.
Ikea.
Richtig.
Richtig, zwei Frauen haben das Bällebad erfunden.
Ich war nämlich im Ikea-Museum in Schweden. Im Geburts bin ich hingepilgert.
Trotz meiner schlimmen Erfahrung mit dem Smallland Freakshow berichtete.
Lag das einfach sehr, sehr günstig. Und was soll ich sagen?
Dort war eine Ausstellung über so unbekannte Designerinnen im Wesentlichen auch,
die viel zu wenig Street Credibility bekommen haben.
Und dann dachte ich wirklich, ich traue meinen Augen nicht, dass dort also die
Erfinderinnen des Bällebards promotet wurden und ratet doch mal, in welchem Jahr das war.
Seit wann gibt es ein Ikea? Seit den 50ern?
Mhm, ungefähr.
Bällebart, Plastik, also ich würde sagen nicht vor den 70er oder 80er Jahren
so Plastik in so Mengen rund irgendwie,
Ende 70er, Anfang 80er.
Das ist das, was ChatGPT daher gelogen hat. Die habe ich dann nämlich gefragt, als ich da vorstand.
Ich habe jetzt nicht ChatGPT gefragt.
Natürlich nicht. Wir hatten eigentlich das Bellewart erfunden.
Da hieß es ein Amerikaner,
irgendwie 74, 76, aber in der Tat waren es eben zwei Frauen,
auch deren Namen wollen wir jetzt hier mal verlesen, nämlich Charlotte Rude und Jördis Olson-Une.
Auch wirklich coole Bilder, die sie da mit am Start haben. Das war 1971.
Also so konzeptionell haben sie es 1969 erfunden und dann die erste Installation
davon in einem Ikea war dann 1971.
71, so früh schon.
Was hat Ikea je für uns getan? Sie haben uns das Bällebad gebracht. Vielen Dank dafür.
Ja doch stimmt, Plastik war schon früher,
Okay.
Und die waren von Anfang an auch schon da in diesen bunten Primärfarben?
Also auf jeden Fall waren sie farbig. Also man sieht jetzt hier auf den entsprechenden
Dokus jetzt erstmal nur ein Schwarz-Weiß-Bild von 71 Jahren.
Also generell, dieses Museum ist schon halt natürlich erwartbar.
Es ist halt ein Propaganda-Instrument.
So machen wir uns jetzt mal nichts vor. Natürlich gibt es auch die ganzen kritischen
Seiten, was alles nicht funktioniert hat bei Ikea und so, aber halt alles durch einen Filter.
Am Ende des Tages sind wir dann doch die Größten.
Aber wenn man sich ein bisschen so für Design interessiert, Geschichte von Küchen,
wie Küchenphilosophie sich geändert hat, gerade auch so in den 70ern,
diese berühmten schwedischen Studien,
wo dann irgendwie Leute dazugesetzt haben, wie sind eigentlich die Laufwege
in den Küchen, das wurde ja systematisch mal erhoben, warum müssen die Leute
immer irgendwie vom Abwaschen zum Herd so weit laufen und was kann man da optimieren.
da war Ikea ja auch relativ weit vorne das ist schon alles ganz spannend also
da kann man gut schon mal so 3-4 Stunden rumbringen Ikea Museum Wo ist das?
Hattest du das gesagt?
Das ist auch in Süd also ich schmeiß den Link mal rein das ist eine Geburtsstadt
von dem Ikea Gründer wo in der Tat dann auch der erste Ikea Store dann war,
und das ist mal eben gucken wo Anfahrt Also in Almhült.
Plätterröd. Plätterröd in Almhült.
Plan your visit. Da ist doch bestimmt irgendwo...
Webseiten, auf denen man wieder die...
Also da ist er zumindest geboren worden.
Die historische Provinzname von diesem Ort heißt,
Smallland.
Ja, das ist die Region, in der das ist. Genau.
Das ist wild. Ich finde jetzt hier wirklich die Adresse nicht.
Das darf ja nicht wahr sein. Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann. Gut, aber ihr habt es schon
irgendwo gefunden im Chat und so.
Ich habe einfach geguckt, wo irgendwann Kamprad geboren ist. Das ist da.
Also es ist wohl in Elmhult.
Oder so.
Tim schon sagte eben.
Es gibt da auch das Ikea Hotel. Direkt nebenan.
Da hatten wir überlegt, ob wir da Just for Fun irgendwie auch eine Nacht drin verbringen.
Hat uns dann aber dagegen entschieden, weil es relativ teuer war.
Und der einzige Gag ist halt, dass es in dem Hotel halt nichts gibt,
was nicht irgendwie von Ikea ist.
Das habe ich auch zu Hause.
Und als wir davor standen, haben wir uns nochmal beglückwünscht,
dass wir das nicht getan haben, weil das sieht von außen so scheiße aus.
Jedes Regal wackelt, jeder Schrank klemmt.
Nee, das sah so richtig irgendwie so nach Industriebrache aus von außen.
Das war wirklich designtechnisch nicht schön.
Ja, mal gucken, kann sogar sein, dass wir da vorbeikommen irgendwie in der Gegend.
Weißt du, das lohnt sich?
Also wenn man da in der Gegend ist und generell halt ein bisschen einen Fable
hat für Industriedesign im weiteren Sinne.
Die machen viel mit Materialkunde, das fand ich ganz spannend.
Würdest du sagen, so Overall, das hat sich sehr gelohnt, das würdest du weiterempfehlen?
Die Drei-Sterne-Skala-Umweg lohnt sich oder ist eine Reise wert?
Also in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass ähnlich wie Lego,
ich habe ja auch das Lego Museum sehr gepriesen, da Ikea in meinem Leben einfach
eine gewisse Rolle gespielt hat und auch spielt und ich das so auch als popkulturelles
Phänomen schon wichtig finde, so für die Welt,
ist das jetzt auf meiner Bucketlist definitiv ein Gut, dass ich da war. Punkt.
So und dieses Museum ist jetzt nicht spektakulär, aber wie gesagt,
Materialkunde fand ich zum Beispiel cool.
Also was machen die mit dem Holz? Was haben die für ökologische Ansätze,
um Dinge irgendwie anders auszutauschen?
Wenn man auch Zeit hat.
Dieses ganze Verpackungswesen, die waren ja nicht die ersten,
die diese Flachverpackung wirklich erfunden haben, aber die ersten,
die es quasi so im Industriestandard ausgepackt haben.
Was ich schade fand, das ist eine verpasste Chance, ich hätte gerne was zu Anleitungen
gehabt da. Weil ich finde ja, das ist einer der wesentlichen Merkmale,
dieses so, wie sind diese Anleitungen eigentlich aufgebaut, wie sind sie da
hingekommen, was waren so Zwischenstadien, was haben sie gelernt?
Also da hätte ich gerne was für gehabt, weil das finde ich auch bei Lego immer
wichtig, so, wie macht man das so niedrigschwellig, wie überhaupt nur irgendwie
möglich, dass wirklich alle kapieren.
Stimmt, Lego-Anleitungen und Ikea-Anleitungen haben eigentlich eine Menge DNA gemeinsam.
Und das zweite, was mir da gefehlt hat, das prangere ich auch an,
die haben so einen kleinen Ausstellungsbereich über Joints, also Verbindungen.
So was, wie sich Verbindungen von zwei Holzteilen einfach verändert haben.
Und dass man das nicht ausprobieren kann.
So, da bist du also mitten in einem riesigen Ikea-Laden, die 10.000 dieser Elemente
irgendwo rumstehen haben für Umme, dann mache ich doch da einen Selbstbaubereich,
wo ich dann einfach mal eben so die 20,
30 gängigsten Joint-Varianten der letzten Dekaden einfach mal zusammen und wieder
auseinanderschrauben kann.
und zu gucken, was war denn jetzt der Vorteil und der Nachteil.
Ich weiß nicht, wann habt ihr zum letzten Mal eine Küche aufgebaut?
Muss es gar nicht unbedingt eine
IKEA-Küche sein? Die Systeme sind ja alle relativ ähnlich mittlerweile.
Wie lange ist das her?
Konkret Küche oder überhaupt irgendwas?
Schon Küche.
Ja, wie selbst gemacht.
Weil da würde ich behaupten, so alle fünf, maximal zehn Jahre hast du dann einen
totalen Paradigmenwechsel, wie diese ganzen Elemente eigentlich aufgebaut werden.
Also du kannst, glaube ich, mittlerweile eine Küche weitestgehend ohne Schraubenzieher
zusammenbauen, weil es alles nur noch geklickt wird mittlerweile.
Das sind alles Konstruktionen, die ineinander gesteckt und dann mit Klickverbindungen funktionieren.
Schubladen schraubst du nicht mehr.
Du hast noch die Elemente, die Halterung der Schubladen, die musst du natürlich
noch reinschrauben in die Korpusgeschichte.
Aber auch die Korpuselemente selber schraubst du nicht mehr.
Auch Klickkonstruktionen mittlerweile. Also ich weiß das, weil wir von einem
Jahr mal einen Schrank uns dazu gebastelt haben.
Und sowas stärker noch irgendwie so, was ja auch irgendwie so diese Kultcharakter
irgendwie transportiert von so dieses selber zusammenschrauben.
Das war mir unterbelichtet.
Also von daher, falls jemand von Ikea zuhört, ich hätte da noch ein paar Ideen,
was man da… Kein Zweifel.
Irgendwann macht ja auch irgendwie Spaß, die Sachen zusammenzubauen und also
das ist ja wohl auch irgendwie, die Leute wertschätzen es mehr,
was sie da haben, wenn sie es selbst zusammengebaut haben.
Der Chat schreibt gerade, Joint-Varianten ausprobieren. Gut,
ihr wisst, wovon ich rede.
Also die Verbindungen zwischen und so.
Ich meine, wenn man schon auf Joints eingeht, dann sollte man natürlich auch
gleich, Ich meine, haben sie dann nur Ikea beleuchtet oder sagen wir mal generell
eine Architekturbetrachtung gemacht?
Also sie versuchen das schon relativ auch in diesen schwedischen Kontext einzubetten.
Also angefangen damit, dieses Smallland war wohl eine schwierige Gegend.
Damals in der Zeit, was so den Entwicklungsstatus anging und daraus leiten sie
dann halt auch so dieses Prinzip so mit ganz begrenzten Ressourcen und für ganz
günstig dann trotzdem was Wertiges machen, so bis wir überhaupt erstmal einen
Acker bestellen konnten.
Da im Smallland mussten wir diese ganzen riesigen Felssteiner erstmal von den
Ackern wegrollen und das prägt die Menschen über Jahrhunderte,
dass sie also entbehrungsreich und ressourcenerfinderisch sind.
So ein Charakter ist drin und was sie relativ gut beleuchten ist so der Bruch
der schwedischen Gesellschaft.
Das heißt es gab in Schweden, ich glaube in den 60ern ja dieses riesige Wohnungsbauprogramm,
irgendwie eine Million quasi in Anführungszeichen Sozialwohnungen in kurzer
Zeit hochgezogen und dafür brauchten sie halt irgendwie Möbel.
und wo kommen die eigentlich her und hat sich halt Ikea total draufgeworfen
und solche Zusammenhänge, ich hätte also gerne noch mehr gelesen,
wenn ich nicht zwei Kiddies gehabt hätte, die muss man ja auch immer irgendwie
so ein bisschen bespaßen, die kannst du nicht irgendwie sagen,
guck dir mal vier Stunden jetzt hier die Tafeln an.
Probier doch mal die Joints aus.
Ja, das entspannt dich, geh mal da. Sie hatten dann in der Tat auch kein Bällebad
da, wo ich also auch sagen würde, so okay, dann hätte man doch da jetzt auch
diese Smallland-Geschichte noch mal ein bisschen feiern können.
Also da ist noch Luft nach oben in diesem Museum. Von daher zögere ich da etwas
auf deine Frage zurückzukommen. Würde ich es jetzt empfehlen oder nicht?
Ich könnte mir viele Dinge vorstellen, wie man dieses Museum noch sehr viel
geiler machen würde, aber ich bin trotzdem sehr froh, dass ich mal da war.
Okay, gut. Das war eine aufwendige Antwort auf unsere einfache Frage.
Mal schauen, was sich so ergibt.
Ja, ähm,
Wo sind wir denn jetzt? Ach ja, vielleicht sollten wir auch noch mal erzählen, wo wir hinwollen.
Du ahnst es schon, wir wollen wieder auf...
Wenn ihr beide irgendwo hinfahrt, wo fahrt ihr wohl hin?
Das ist ein Hacker-Camp.
Und um welche Programmiersprache wird es da wohl gehen? Keine Ahnung.
Ich hole mir mal noch ein Bier.
Bringst du mir eins mit?
Ja, mir auch, bitte. Ja, naja, wir fahren wieder auf eine Elixier-Konferenz.
Das wäre ein bisschen monothematisch.
Aber das Schöne ist, das ist halt diesmal eine,
Community-Konferenz. Das wäre eher noch so.
Ja, schon irgendwie. Das ist eher eine kleinere, intimere.
Ein paar hundert Leute. Alles ganz kuschelig. Stellen wir uns das zumindest vor.
Das Ganze ist in Warberg. Hast du davon schon mal was gehört?
Nein? Ich muss mal dein Mikrofon aufsetzen.
Der Herr Klaschenöffner hat es nicht gerade ein fotografiert.
Da liegt doch einer direkt bei dir.
Unter deinem Mikro quasi.
Genau. Ja, Warberg ist so ein kleines Kaff irgendwie auf einem halben Weg nach Göteborg.
Wo ich auch noch nie war. Ich war überhaupt noch nie in Schweden jenseits von Malmö.
Von daher ist mir das das ist alles noch Neuland.
Also ich war da tatsächlich schon mal, habe ich erfahren.
Wo?
In Warberg.
Ach.
Aber da war ich halt noch nicht mal ein Jahr alt.
Ach so.
Deshalb kann ich mich da auch nicht so gut dran erinnern.
Ja, das ist der ganze Anlass. Und danach wollen wir noch so ein bisschen irgendwie
durch die Gegend gucken und mal schauen, was wir mit unserem frisch erworbenen
Wissen alles so anstellen können.
Wie schreibt sich das?
V-A-R und dann Berg.
Okay.
Naja, und da haben wir schon relativ viele Elixierkonferenzen mitgenommen dieses Jahr.
Also mehr geht, aber es wäre schwierig.
Ah, das ist die Westküste. Okay, ich sehe gerade hier. Ja, nee,
da waren wir in der Tat genau halb nach Göteborg hoch.
Nee, da kann ich euch im Umland in der Tat jetzt auch nichts empfehlen, weil da war ich nicht.
Ich kann aber mal meine, ich mache ja auf Apple Maps immer so Rhön mit Kindern,
Schweden mit Kindern, Dänemark mit Kindern Connections, da poste ich mal die
Links in die Shownotes rein.
Falls also irgendjemand in Südschweden ist und irgendwie Locations sucht,
das sind Sachen, die haben wir selber ausprobiert und für gut befunden. Aber nix in der Ecke.
Ja, mal gucken. Wenn man es mit den Mücken übernimmt, dann hauen wir auch gleich wieder ab.
Nee, dann trinken wir Diet.
Prost.
So, Prost. Womit machen wir denn weiter? Wir haben noch so ein paar kleine Rans
hier, glaube ich, vorbereitet.
Ich muss erstmal ein paar Haken setzen in unseren Notizen.
was wir denn hier alles schon weggeschafft haben.
Was nervt dich denn am Internet am meisten gerade, Ralf?
Am Internet?
Ja, ist ja irgendwo aufgefallen, dass vor so ein paar Monaten hat was angefangen,
was jetzt irgendwie auf einmal so komplett überhanden nimmt.
Die allgemeine Entschitification.
Ja, die allgemeine Entschitification natürlich, aber Abteilung Login.
Ich habe es ja in den Shownotes gesehen, aber konnte mit wenig anfangen.
Ja, ist ja auch schon passiert, dass du dich irgendwo eingeloggt hast und anstatt
dass du ein Passwort eingibst, kam ein, ich habe dir eine E-Mail geschickt.
Klick auf diesen Link, gib diese Zahl ein.
Das fällt und dann bist du angemeldet.
Also du bist auch kein Fan davon.
Nein, ich bin kein Fan.
Wir suchen den Fan davon, weil irgendwie muss ja jemand das auf einmal ganz
toll gefunden haben, das überall einzubauen.
Tim, das ist interessant, dass du sowas aufbringst. Warum?
Weil ich sehe das bei irgendwie drei, vier Diensten in der Tat seit ein paar
Monaten, wo ich denke, was ist das denn jetzt für eine Idee?
Ich sehe das nicht bei drei, vier, ich sehe das bei 30, 40 Diensten pro Monat
und das ist wirklich anstrengend.
Es nervt.
Also ist das irgendein Framework, was irgendjemand rausgeworfen hat?
Das setzt sich gerade so ein bisschen durch als Default-Authentication.
Ich könnte kotzen, es ist so nervig. Lasst mich einfach ein Passwort benutzen, bitte.
Naja, die Leute wollen sich halt einfach Accounts sparen. Ich würde sagen, das ist so ein Teil.
Das tust du damit ja nicht. Also Accounts sparen,
das machst du mit einem Authentication-Provider. Log in with Facebook.
Und der Account ist ja persistent, zumindest bei den Sachen.
Also der Account ist angelegt.
Ihr habt recht.
Du löst kein Problem.
Nee, man, ja, also sagen wir mal so,
ich kann ja verstehen, wenn man so ein einfaches System baut,
wo man keine Accounts haben will und sagt einfach, ich merke mir einfach nur
deine E-Mail-Adresse und du bestätigst das durch diesen Klick und dann gilt
das, ja, dann muss ich nicht wirklich einen User anlegen.
Da habe ich da irgendwie so meinen authentifizierten, Anführungsstrichen,
authentifizierten Cookie und damit könnte ich schon mal starten.
Das wäre ja noch eine Erklärung.
Aber weil es ja ohnehin diese Accounts gibt und auch schon bestehende Passwörter
gibt und so weiter, fragt man sich halt wirklich, warum gibt es das?
Also was führt eigentlich dazu, dass das jetzt alle einbauen?
Also wenn bei dir irgendwie ein Surprise-Backup gemacht wird,
irgendwie Daten fließen ab plötzlich, dann steht immerhin nicht in den Nachrichten,
die Hacker sind an Passwörter gekommen.
Naja, das setzt ja voraus, dass es gar keine Passwörter gibt.
Es gibt ja oft auch schon Passwörter.
Ja, zum Teil. Also ich habe jetzt auch schon Dienste gesehen,
wo es keine Möglichkeit gibt, ein Passwort überhaupt noch zu konfigurieren.
Ja.
Also das ist das Allerschlimmste.
Genau, sie wollen irgendwie Passwörter loswerden und in gewisser Hinsicht das
ist ja auch ein erstrebenswertes Ziel und man hat sich ja gedacht,
naja, dann nehmen wir doch Passkeys stattdessen.
Und Passkeys sind ja eigentlich eine gute Idee. Du hast halt da Kryptografie
und das Public-Private-Key und so wie man das halt eigentlich seit langer,
langer Zeit mit Verschlüsselung und Authentifizierungssystemen,
die auf Verschlüsselung basieren,
macht, dass man eben dieses getrennte Schlüsselpaar hat und seit ein paar Betriebssystem-Releases
haben die großen Plattformen halt auch überall in ihren Key-Managern.
Pass-Key-Support. Also der Mac hat das, Windows hat es sicherlich auch,
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal an. Ich beschäftige mich damit ja nicht.
Ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall, das war quasi die Idee.
Aber das Problem mit Pass-Keys ist natürlich, dass keiner genau definiert hat,
was sind jetzt, also wofür soll man Pass-Keys jetzt verwenden.
Weil klar denkt man aber erstmal, ja wenn wir keine Passworte haben,
nehmen wir halt einfach Passkeys stattdessen. Das ist so ein bisschen die Nerd-View.
Das Problem ist natürlich, ein Passkey hast du nicht im Kopf.
Du kannst nicht ein Passwort, was die Leute nur im Kopf haben,
ersetzen mit einem Passkey, weil den Passkey kannst du nicht im Kopf haben.
Also musst du den Passkey auf der Platte haben.
Und auf einem, in Anführungsstrichen, normalen Computer, wenn du so ein Passkey
hast, dann musst du den ja auch irgendwo hinspeichern und da muss er dann auch
irgendwie beschützt werden.
Gilt in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch für Passwort, also gibt es Passwortmanager,
die das dann vielleicht auch definiert abspeichern und im Idealfall auch definiert
aufrufen, wenn du auf der Webseite eine entsprechende URL anwählst und das matcht
dann eben mit diesem Passkey über die Domain, dann kann das System halt sagen,
ja, guck mal, ich hab ja hier einen Passkey.
Bloß dann hast du halt Multidevice, hast du einen Computer, hast einen Desktop,
hast einen Laptop, hast ein Telefon, hast ein iPad, so.
dann bist du eben auch angewiesen darauf, dass dieser Passkey ordentlich synkt.
Solche Syncing-Mechanismen gibt es natürlich.
iCloud Keychain macht das. Ich weiß nicht, ist das eigentlich mittlerweile immer noch optional?
Dass es synkt?
Ja, dass man die iCloud Keychain benutzt, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das war auf jeden Fall mal optional.
Ich verwende das und würde es auch empfehlen sowas zu verwenden.
Trotzdem, dieses Problem existiert.
Man darf halt auch einmal nicht unterschätzen, was ist für Menschen zu kompliziert.
Und so ein Passkey ist halt irgendwie etwas, das kannst du nicht sehen.
Der Computer sagt dir, es gibt das und er überträgt das und das Schöne ist auch,
eigentlich müsste er komplett ausreichen.
Du müsstest eigentlich nur den Passkey schicken und sonst gar nichts eingeben,
nicht deine E-Mail-Adresse und dann wirst du erst nach dem Passkey gefragt oder du hast beide Felder.
Kannst aber irgendwo noch draufklicken und sagen, kannst auch ein Passkey nehmen
oder dass man einfach generell erstmal Passkey automatisch ausprobiert.
Jede Webseite macht das irgendwie anders. Also gibt es auf einmal überhaupt
gar keinen klaren Flow mehr, wo die Leute wissen so, ah ja, hier muss ich jetzt
meinen Schlüssel reinstecken.
Das ist zwar das eigentlich erklärte Ziel, aber wir haben so das Problem,
es gibt jetzt keine erlernte Methode mehr, wie man damit jetzt umgehen soll.
Und es gibt keine Möglichkeiten für diese Webseiten auch sicherzustellen,
dass die Leute die entsprechenden Tools haben, um mit diesen Passkeys umzugehen.
Und deswegen ist das derzeit so ein Eiertanz, dass du das dann auswählen kannst
und das optional erstellen kannst.
Manche machen das, manche bieten es dir an, manche fragen dich,
was du möchtest oder auch nicht.
Irgendwo ist es vielleicht ein verstecktes Feature, was du erstmal entdecken musst.
Das ist irgendwie unklar, wie man die Leute heranführt und das führt natürlich
dazu, dass die Passkeys nicht in der Lage sind, die Passwörter komplett abzulösen,
aber trotzdem will man irgendwie dieses,
Eingeben des abschneuchelbaren Passworts irgendwie weghaben,
weil es offensichtlich wohl so viele Probleme gibt.
Und jetzt kollabieren alle und sagen, ey, schick doch den Leuten einfach eine
Scheiß-Mail, dann klicken die auf den Link drauf, das können sie ja eh gut.
So, das ist das Einzige, was sie können. Und dann passt das schon.
Das ist einfach so der lowest common denominator.
Ja, das heißt, der Versuch, es besser zu machen, macht alles noch irgendwie
viel schlimmer und es ist anstrengend, das alles mit anzusehen und ich frage
mich halt wirklich, was man dagegen tun kann.
Also das Grundproblem, was ich damit schon habe, ist, dass es halt irgendwie E-Mails voll müllt.
Du hast einfach auf einem Kommunikationskanal, der dafür nicht vorgesehen ist,
plötzlich irgendwie so viermal pro Tag irgendeinen Login misst,
der einfach überflüssig ist und da nicht hingehört.
Und klar, dann kannst du wieder irgendwelche E-Mail-Regeln bauen,
die das dann wieder weglöschen und hinverschieben und so.
Aber es ist natürlich alles ein Elend. Es wäre schon mal ein Schritt einfacher,
wenn iOS, macOS, ähnlich wie sie das bei SMS machen, aus den E-Mails das schon mal extrahieren.
Ich habe das schon gesehen.
Also ihr weißt, was ich meine.
Dass sie über dem Keyboard angezeigt wird, wenn es jetzt ein SMS-Code ist.
Und die auch automatisch gelöscht wird, aber dazu müssen die Mails zu bestimmten
Formatierungsregeln genügen, was natürlich nicht alle tun.
Ja und du musst sie, nehme ich an, also der E-Mail-Client, wenn du jetzt nicht
Apple Mail, wenn du jetzt nicht das verwendest, dann musst du hoffen.
Dass der das implementiert hat. Das ist nämlich das andere Problem.
Mail ist nicht so ein klar definierter Dienst, sondern du kannst halt verschiedene
Programme haben und manche machen das und haben dafür ein Interface.
Apple Mail hat das, verwendest einen anderen Mailer, was zugegebenermaßen die
wenigsten machen auf dem Mac, aber geht halt. Und das ist halt auch das Problem
so ein bisschen mit Mail.
Mail ist eigentlich der Dienst, der vom Web am weitesten entfernt ist und trotzdem
am engsten mit ihm verbunden ist jetzt.
weil wir auf einmal Mail, was mit Abstand der unsicherste, am schwierigsten
zu bereinigende, Spam immer noch ein Thema und wird es auch wahrscheinlich immer bleiben,
also der am schwierigsten aufzusetzende, selbst zu betreibende,
am schwierigsten mit umzugehende Service des Internets, der älteste,
der irgendwie kaum Security hat, wo es noch nicht mal eine klare Definition
dafür gibt, wie Fehlermeldungen übertragen werden.
das ist dann das Backup für auf einmal alles, was mit deiner Sicherheit zu tun
hat und das zwingt dich halt dann auch immer so diese beiden vollständig disjunkten
Systeme immer gleichzeitig zu benutzen,
nur um dich mal auf einer scheiß Webseite anzumelden die dann auch noch,
die Traute hat, dann zu fragen soll ich mir das merken?
Und du sagst ja, bitte, merk's dir und am nächsten Tag lockst du dich da wieder
ein und dann so, wer bist du denn?
Keine Ahnung Ich sag nur DHL, schöne Grüße.
Ihr könntet mal langsam aufhören, ein neues Fenster aufzumachen zum Anmelden. Wo leben wir denn?
Die 90er Jahre wollen ihre Pop-Up-Fenster wiederhaben.
Oh Gott, also das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ja, es ist ein Schmerz.
Und es geht ja noch schlimmer, denn diese Webseiten, die einem Copy und Paste
von Passwörtern auch noch verbieten.
Weil, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Ja, da könntest du ja von irgendwoher dein Passwort haben.
Nein, du musst es abtippen, aus dem Kopf am besten.
Aber vielleicht druckst du es vorher noch aus und dann tippst du es irgendwie
ab. Man darf das auf gar keinen Fall einfach machen, so ein Passwort einzugeben. Das ist verboten.
Naja, aber Webformulare waren halt schon immer kurzer aus der Hölle.
Also nimm alleine mal einen Dienst, wo du eine Telefonnummer eintragen musst.
Wie ist jetzt der Regex dahinter gebaut? Habe ich jetzt irgendwie plus 4,9 davor?
Oder habe ich davor einen Selektor, wo das plus 4,9 ist? So und nehme ich trotzdem
aus meinem Adressbuch meine Telefonnummer, wo ein Plus 49 ist,
füge das dahinter ein, lösche die Plus 49 weg.
Glaubt mal nicht, dass es dann noch durch die Validierung kommt,
weil irgendwann stand da mal eine Plus 49.
Zu lang auch. Und da sind Spaces drin. Oder Minusse. Wie haben Sie die Sonderzeichen?
Wie schwer kann es sein, eine Form zu bauen, was einfach mal eine gewisse Grundintelligenz
für Telefonnummern mitsingt?
Leider, also ich meine, es gibt halt kein, es gibt nicht das standardisierte
Telefonnummernformat oder gibt es das vielleicht doch?
Gibt es E100? Gibt es einen ISO-Standard? Was ist das? E100,
E100, E100, nee, warte mal, was ist das?
Gut, das setzt dann natürlich auch voraus, dass Leute wissen,
wie dieses Format funktioniert und das dann auch so eingeben können.
Ja, am besten einfach keine Nutzerdaten akzeptieren.
E164 von der ITU beschreibt, wie eine Telefonnummer auszusehen hat und außerdem
gibt es noch ein RFC 3966 für URIs,
wie da Telefonnummern notiert werden und es gibt auch DIN 5008,
die auch noch die Formatierung einschließlich der Spaces dazwischen deklariert.
aber mit E164 ist einfach mal klar eine Telefonnummer ist einfach plus Ländercode
und dann dahinter alles, ja oder für eine Null eingeben oder nicht überhaupt
und dann ist es wirklich zum Korbzellen Aber.
Wirklich der Gipfel ist wirklich halt,
Dass du gesagt bekommst, diese Nummer akzeptieren wir so nicht,
weil ich sie über Copy & Paste eingefügt habe und dann halt korrigiert habe.
Und dann löscht du alles weg und tippst Zahl für Zahl alles händisch ein und
dann wird es akzeptiert.
Aber sie ist falsch.
Wo mir wirklich unerklärlich ist, was läuft da falsch bei den Leuten.
Naja gut, die einen jammern, die anderen klagen.
Ja, zu Recht. und ich meine, da sind wir ja noch gar nicht bei den Webseiten,
die ja immer noch irgendwelche Sonderzeichen einfordern in deinen Passwörtern.
Oder nicht erlauben. Das gibt's auch noch.
Wir erlauben hier nur folgende Sonderzeichen.
Dafür mag es manchmal ja Gründe geben.
Nein.
Behold. Hear me out. Passt auf Folgendes.
Wir haben gerade eben im FÖB, unserem Verband Berliner Bibliotheken,
die Passwortregeln umgestellt.
Nein. Ich schmeiß dich raus.
So, weil Security.
Das Passwort darf nur die Zeichen I, 1, O und 0 enthalten.
Und wir erlauben Sonderzeichen, aber nicht alle.
Und jetzt gibt es wie von euch auch Spott und Hohn und großes Misstrauen.
Weißt du warum? Weil wir recht haben.
Okay, und wie machst du das bitteschön mit dem Selbstverbucherautomaten,
der eine Tastatur hat, wo einfach nicht alle Sonderzeichen drauf sind, du Schlauberger?
Das ist doch nicht mein Problem.
Ja, wir haben Hardware.
Wie oft verbuchst du dich denn selbst am Tag?
Pro im Föp, 10.000 Mal pro Tag, dass Leute an dieser Maschine sind.
Wir haben einfach mal Hardware, die Tastaturen hat.
Und auf diesen Tastaturen sind einfach, wie bei einem Bankterminal,
nicht alle Sonderzeichen vorhanden. Darum unterstützt unsere neue Passwortregel
nur vier Sonderzeichen und nicht alle Denkbaren.
Und das hat einen sehr guten Grundpunkt.
Welche?
Ich müsste jetzt ein Bild rauskramen von unseren Selbstverbuchern.
Vier Sonderzeichen habt ihr auf der Tastatur?
Ja, kann auch sein, dass es sechs sind.
Also es ist eine Erklärung auf jeden Fall.
So, manchmal ist, ne, sich drüber lustig machen immer ein guter Reflex,
aber es hat einfach mal, ne, wir können jetzt natürlich auch hingehen und irgendwie
tausend Hardware-Teile austauschen, ohne Sinn und Verstand, ohne dass sie danach
irgendwas besser könnten.
Also auch wenn deine Erklärung das jetzt erklärt alles, können wir uns ja trotzdem drüber lustig machen.
Ja, also warum, ich meine, Warum muss man da Passwörter eingeben?
Das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Das haben wir in dem Zuge jetzt auch abgeschafft.
Ach so, ihr habt die Passwörter abgeschafft.
Aber vorher musste man halt Passwörter eingeben, aber die hatten halt quasi
gar keine Regeln. Und jetzt ist es halt optional.
Der Preset ist halt der, dass du ohne Passwort jetzt einfach nur mit deiner
Karte entleihen kannst.
Automagisch. Aber für Leute mit erhöhtem Sicherheitsbewusstsein,
die können sich das nach wie vor in ihrem Account aktivieren.
Ich möchte nicht, dass der Selbstverbucher das ohne Passwort macht.
Was hat denn die Karte für die Technologie?
Das ist RFID.
Und die Bücher auch alle. Das ist schon ganz cool. Du hast einen Stapel Bücher,
die schiebst du als Stapel in den Selbstverbucher rein und kriegst schön auf
dem großen Display eine Liste.
Diese sechs Bücher liegen hier gerade, halt einmal deine Karte dran und dann
trägst du die aus der Bibliothek.
Und von 100 Leuten, die an diesen Terminals sind, wie viele davon benutzen die
Karte und wie viele benutzen die Passwort?
Im Moment benutzen alle die Karte, weil es halt einfach erst mal der Preset ist.
Und wie viele jetzt sagen, ich möchte dieses zusätzliche Sicherheitsbedürfnis
haben und möchte nach wie vor mein Passwort eingeben.
Wir haben das erst seit drei Tagen jetzt scharf geschaltet. Das heißt also,
da kann ich jetzt noch keine Statistiken zu rausgeben.
Okay, also im Prinzip ist das Passwort aber on its way out, kann man sagen.
Genau, also für Online-Dienste ist es dann jetzt verpflichtend,
um in sein Konto reinzukommen und zu gucken, wo muss ich mal ein Gebühren bezahlen und sowas.
Da brauchst du jetzt verpflichtend das komplizierte Passwort,
aber in dem eigentlichen Handling in der Bibliothek ist es einfacher als vorher.
Das Beste aus allen Welten.
Ja, da ist es dann auch wieder schwierig für die Passkeys, weil wenn du sozusagen
auch noch einen Zugang erlauben möchtest, der ohne Passkeys auskommt,
kannst du natürlich nicht auf Passkeys setzen.
Und okay, dann die Karte.
So, und dann gibt es natürlich solche Szenarien wie, ah, was ist,
wenn ich dann meine Karte verliere und jemand anders lehrt dann die halbe Bibliothek
aus. Aber da gibt es halt auch Limits.
Du kannst also jetzt nicht die ganze Bibliothek da raus tragen.
Und diverse andere, wir sind ja late to the party in Berlin,
ganz viele andere Bibliotheken in Deutschland haben das schon so umgestellt.
Achtung, du brauchst kein Passwort mehr am Selbstverbucher. Und jetzt haben
wir einfach nachgezogen.
Ich gebe dir einen Pass auf diesen Umstand und bestimmte Sonderzeichen nicht
erlauben ist auch nicht ganz so ein Verbrechen wie darauf bestehen,
dass bestimmte Sonderzeichen enthalten sind. Das ist nämlich das Schlimmste.
Also ich glaube ja, dass bei ganz vielen Diensten, dass es dann nicht so eine
Erklärung gibt, wie Ralf sie uns jetzt gegeben hat.
Nein, es wird auch gar keine Erklärung, weil es kann auch dafür gar keine Erklärung geben.
Warum muss ich in meinem Passwort eins von folgenden Zeichen enthalten,
wenn ich einfach nur fünf Buchstaben hinzufügen kann und damit die Randomness
meines Passworts ins Unermessliche steigt und das einfach totaler Unsinn ist.
Also die Annahme, ein Sonderzeichen würde jetzt ein Passwort irgendwie per se
irgendwas vereinfachen.
Also insofern würde ich sogar noch extremer machen und sagen,
gar keine Sonderzeichen, außer vielleicht ein Bindestrich oder so und alles
andere kannst du vergessen.
Einfach Buchstaben, fertig.
Also ich meine, es gibt ja so bestimmte Ansätze, um in einem Formular,
bei einem Registrierungsformular oder so zu sagen, dieses Passwort,
was du jetzt gerade setzen willst, das solltest du nicht nehmen,
weil es ist in der Liste der Top 1000 geliebte Passwörter.
Also Ansätze in die Richtung, die halt sagen, wir sind uns ziemlich sicher,
dass dieses Passwort, was du gerade benutzt, scheiße ist, mach mal ein anderes.
also ich meine, da muss man jetzt nicht super harte Passwortregeln für einen.
Denke ich. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen, auf der einen Seite wollen wir von
Passwort dann weg, weil entweder können sich die Leute, die nicht merken oder,
sie können sie nicht merken.
Ja.
Oder sie sind unsicher.
Aber wir wollen nicht zu E-Mail hin.
Nee, aber was ist jetzt die Lösung? Ich meine, mit Login bei E-Mail könnte man
jetzt an diesen Terminals natürlich auch nichts erreichen.
Weil das ja, Login bei E-Mail setzt ja auch immer voraus, ich trage so einen
kompletten E-Mail-Client mit mir herum.
Und zwar in jedem Moment, wenn ich da bin. Ich kann mir ja nicht an irgendeinem
Web-Terminal, wo ich mein Gerät nicht habe, kann ich mich ja nicht mehr einloggen.
Wenn alles, was ich noch weiß, mein Passwort ist und ich will mich da einloggen
oder sagt, weil ich habe jetzt alle meine Geräte verloren, ich muss mich jetzt
hier unbedingt einloggen oder so.
Ja, ich habe an deinem Gerät, habe ich dir immer was geschickt,
das musst du jetzt mal eintippen. Das ist immer so ein totaler Horror.
Das erinnert mich irgendwie an Banken.
Ja, so an so die ganzen Apps.
Das ist genau das, was du hast, wenn du dein Telefon verlierst oder so.
Ach ja, es ist hart.
Naja, dann gibt es ja immer noch ein Backup, ne? Du kriegst einen Brief zugeschickt.
Wir schicken dir einen Magic-Auslink per Brief.
Das ist im Prinzip die Vorschrift der Briefzustellung mit anderen Mitteln, könnte man sagen.
Ja, so.
Wenn wir so bei Randstrecken sind, da hätte ich in der Tat dann auch den nächsten Kandidaten dafür.
Okay.
Der sich auch ableitet aus jetzt meinem Urlaub.
Und zwar, ich suche einen Begriff.
Irgendeinen?
Nee, ich suche einen Begriff für etwas, was man gefühlt irgendwie ständig hat, aber wo...
wo es, finde ich, ein gutes, catchy Wort für fehlt.
Und ich beschreibe erst mal das Phänomen und dann können wir uns rantasten,
ob uns irgendwie was Gutes einfällt.
Also, und zwar eine Kette von Entscheidungen, die alle schlecht sind,
aber auf eine Art auch alternativlos, weil die Welt so scheiße ist.
So, es fängt also an mit der Entscheidung, dass ich sage, okay,
regelmäßige Hörerinnen werden es wissen, ich bin Fahrradmensch hier,
Ich mache quasi alles auf dem Fahrrad in Berlin, aber im Urlaub liebe ich es,
mit dem Auto unterwegs zu sein, mit dem eigenen Auto.
Kannst du doch mal diesen Satz sagen, eine Kette von Entscheidungen,
die alle schlecht sind, aber alternativlos?
Genau.
Also man hat ein Ziel klar vor Augen und in einer perfekten Welt wäre es ein
sehr einfach zu erreichendes Ziel.
Du musst aber sechs schlechte Zwischenschritte gehen, um dich diesem Ziel ansatzweise anzunähern.
Was war mein Ziel? Also man kann natürlich sagen, die Grundsetzung ist schon
mal falsch, selber Schuld, verhalten nicht mit dem Auto in den Urlaub.
Aber ja, die Kröte muss man jetzt schlucken.
Ich mag es, mit dem eigenen Auto in den Urlaub zu fahren.
Ich habe Kinder im Auto.
Ich habe weitestgehend alle didaktischen Ansätze über Bord geworfen.
Keine iPads im Auto und Kinder nicht länger als zwei Stunden Medienzeit und
so. So wäre irgendwie ein paar Stunden mit Kindern.
Sind das die schlechten Entscheidungen, die du gerade aufgehst?
Vergessen. Ich komme jetzt gleich zu der ersten.
Ich bin da relativ schmerzbefreit. Trotzdem habe ich wahrgenommen,
dass meine Kinder in letzter Zeit zunehmend gut auf Musik reagieren.
Okay.
Die fangen sich an, für gewisse Musik zu interessieren.
Zum Beispiel so in dem neuen Pokémon-Spiel auf der Switch. Was läuft denn da
eigentlich für Musik im Hintergrund? Die ist ja ganz cool.
Oder dieses Harry Potter-Motiv in diesen Filmen. Spiel doch nochmal den Soundtrack.
So, ich also als fürsorglicher Familienvater habe mir was überlegt.
So, wir nutzen diese Reise auch ein bisschen musikpädagogisch und ich stelle
fürs Auto gute Playlists zusammen, die wir dann gemeinsam als Familie wertschätzen können.
Kinderkompatibel, aber auch Erwachsenenkompatibel.
So zum Beispiel Best of Star Wars. Hervorragende Playlist.
Auf zwei CDs, ich habe es nicht auf eine gekriegt, sondern also wirklich alle
neuen Filme, alle Serien, alles was irgendwie Rang und Namen hat,
da kommt man eben schon auf drei Stunden, fantastische Playlist.
Kein Wunder, dass du nicht schlaf findest.
Wie kriege ich die in meinem Auto aber abgespielt?
Die CD?
Crickets and Tumbleweeds.
Wie du eine CD abgespielt hast?
So, ich habe halt, naja, also erstmal ist ja die Frage so, ich will ja gar keine
CD eigentlich mehr haben.
Achso, also du kannst jetzt jedes beliebige Medium nehmen und wie kriegst du es abgespielt?
Genau. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Welche technischen Voraussetzungen das Auto hat.
So, das ist eben das Problem, es ist halt mal ein altes Auto.
Mercedes B-Klasse, wir erinnern uns, diese Schlüsselgeschichte und so weiter,
der ist glaube ich 19 Jahre alt.
So, da ist ein sogenanntes Audio 5 verbaut von Mercedes.
Hat der noch so einen Standard-Radio-Slot?
Nee, eben nicht.
Was hat er denn?
Kassettendeck? Das nicht, aber er hat wirklich nur Audio-CD.
Das heißt, er kann keine MP3-CDs abspielen. Was zu dem Zeitpunkt vor 19 Jahren schon völlig Usus war.
Ich hatte zwei andere in anderen Autos, zwei Radios, die problemlos MP3-CDs
abgegeben. Weil dann hätte ich eine einzige MP3-CD gebrannt.
Und da wären alle Playlists drauf gewesen, ein Problem wäre gelöst gewesen. So, ging nicht.
So, erster Instinkt ist natürlich okay.
Aux In?
Gibt es es gibt sogar im handschuhfach der b klasse ein,
Anschluss dafür, der aber nicht belegt ist von Mercedes in seiner unglaublichen Weisheit.
Weil wer weiß, was die Leute da anschließen könnten. Wir bauen mal einen Adapter
rein, mit schönen, sogar Staubschutz, seitlich Verschiebeöffnung.
Aber dahinter ist nur ein großes, schwarzes, klaffendes Loch.
So, und jetzt kann man überlegen, na gut.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Art Altar, da du dem Adapter danken kannst.
Dank des Adapters, genau. Jetzt wäre es eine Variante gewesen,
eine Entscheidung auf dieser Strecke.
Na gut, dann fährt man jetzt zu irgendeinem Audioschrauberbude und der legt
dann hinten den Kabel an dem AUX-Eingang, den es durchaus gibt in dem Audio
5 von Mercedes und baut das dann da hin.
Ist aber auch alles nicht so trivial, weil glaubt man nicht,
dass dieser AUX-Eingang dann standardmäßig erreichbar ist über das Frontend.
Das heißt, man muss dann erst wieder irgendwelche Systemcodes von Mercedes in
einer bestimmten Reihenfolge und so und dachte ich, oh mein Gott,
ob das nach 19 Jahren noch irgendjemand weiß und ob das noch funktioniert.
Gibt es überhaupt irgendetwas, führt irgendwas hinein in dieses System?
Nein. Also nächster Ansatz wäre ja rausreißen, irgendwas normales reinbauen.
Also ich hätte jetzt noch gesagt.
Dieses Radio, kennt ihr das noch? Das ist so Adapter.
Komme ich gleich zu. Haben wir durchgespielt, habe ich schon durchgespielt.
Also rausreißen, was anderes reinbauen, geht halt nicht, weil kein Standardslot
bei Mercedes, welche Überraschung, sondern so eine integrierte Mittelkonsole.
Ja, du kriegst es raus. Man kann sich irgendwie 3D-gedruckt einen Adapter irgendwie
da reinsetzen, aber es ist auch alles irgendwie Fledermausland.
Und dann geht die ganze Fernbedienung auf dem Lenkrad nicht mehr,
die ich auch nicht wirklich nutze, aber trotzdem, er hat irgendwie auch alles Issues.
Okay, FM-Adapter ist in der Tat ein Punkt,
das heißt also du kannst in den Zigaretten-Anschluss kannst du einen Mini-FM-Sender reinstellen,
den du auf irgendeine Frequenz einstellst, UKW und wo du dann quasi über eine
Mini-Klinke was rein spielst und der das dann dir einen lokalen Radiosender
auch baut, den du dann oben mit der Dachantenne empfängst.
Habe ich zwei Modelle mal durchprobiert, ist schon etwas länger her.
Kann sein, dass sie seitdem große Evolutionssprünge gemacht haben,
ich glaube es nicht. Die Qualität ist beschissen.
Echt?
Ja, du musst erstmal eine Frequenz finden, wo nichts los ist.
Du fährst durch die Gegend, ständig ändern sich die Frequenzen, weil UKW.
Und obwohl es irgendwie gefühlt 50 Zentimeter Luftlinie nur sind,
das war weit vom Sound her unter dem, was ich halt bei der CD bekomme.
So habe ich es auch in Erinnerung, dass es dermaßen schlecht war,
aber das ist halt 20 Jahre her gewesen eigentlich.
Bin ich dann doch irgendwie zu audiophil, um das irgendwie hinzunehmen.
Das heißt also, der erste Zwischenboxen-Stop jetzt auf dieser Ursache- Wirkungskette
war so, okay, ich komme um Audio-CDs nicht drum rum, ich muss also jetzt Audio-CDs brennen.
Wieso? Quatsch.
Im Jahr 2025.
Das hätte ja noch einen anderen Vorschlag.
Ja, sag.
Anderes Auto gehaufen.
Ne, Klettband mit irgendwie,
Doppelklebesystem, klebst halt die eine Seite drauf und auf die andere Seite
klett und dann machst du da einfach eine Bluetooth Boombox drauf,
die ordentlich wummert.
Was sagt denn überhaupt, dass du die Lautsprecher benutzt, die Mercedes da in
deine B-Klasse eingebaut sind? Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch eher so B-Klasse.
Hab ich mal probiert mit der Boombox.
Da war ich also auch schon vor fünf, sechs Jahren oder sowas.
Ich habe eine relativ gute Zuhause und die war nicht in der Lage,
sich gegen den Innenraum Lärm durchzusetzen. Mag sein.
Was ist denn relativ gut, wenn die so leise ist?
Naja, also in einem normalen Raum ist die irre laut, aber unterschätzt mal nicht,
wie krawallig so ein Auto in einem Raum von so einem alten Benziner ist.
Ja, das stimmt. Ach, Benziner.
Da hatte ich auch große Hoffnungen reingesetzt und dachte aber,
okay, was ich dann da wiederum jetzt an Boombox-Geld investieren müsste und
dann hast du das auch irgendwie nur eine Punktquelle, verteilt sich nicht,
die Kinder hinten, denen ist es zu leise, vorne ist es viel zu laut.
Also auch die Anlage, die verbaut ist, ist relativ gut von Mercedes.
Die Boxen sind echt okay. Da muss man nicht noch irgendwie groß was in den Kofferraum
legen. Hatte ich auch schon mal in einem anderen Auto. Aber damit kann man schon leben.
Okay, CDs.
Das heißt, wir waren also auf CDs.
Also ich dachte eben, die Geschichte geht damit aus, dass du ein neues Auto gekauft hast.
Aber einfach nicht.
Also CDs. Wie brennt man eigentlich im Jahr 2025 CDs?
Man kauft sich erstmal einen CD-Brenner, wenn man keinen mehr hat.
Richtig. So, das heißt, ich kann jetzt also stolz aus meiner...
Apple USB-CD Laufwerk.
Von Apple muss es nicht sein. Ich bin jetzt also in den Mediamarkt meines Vertrauens
gefahren, beziehungsweise Saturn war es, glaube ich, und habe jetzt für stolze 24 Euro,
einen Verbatim extern Slimline CD DVD Writer gekaukelt.
Minus R oder Plus R?
Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt scheißegal an der Stelle, weil ich die ja nur einmal beschreibe.
Also DVDs kann er auch nicht lesen, dein Fahrzeug.
Nee.
Das wäre ja auch ein Teil der Lösung gewesen. Also da gehen wirklich nur Audio-CDs rein.
So, das ist noch irgendein USB-A. Nee, das ist kein USB-A. Was ist das? Mikro-USB, glaube ich.
Mikro-USB? Du kaufst dir ein Mikro-USB-Gerät? Ist das dein Ernst?
Ja, was anderes gab es halt in der Price-Range. Ich hätte jetzt auch für 100
Euro irgendwas mit USB-C.
Was kostet das USB-C-Laufwerk von Apple?
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach ein Kabel auf USB-C und alles ist gut.
Apple hat ein eigenes?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich wollte jetzt so wenig Geld dem noch hinterher. werfen, wie irgendwie möglich.
Das von Apple wird ja sicherlich nicht günstig sein.
Hat Apple da überhaupt noch was im Angebot?
Ich gucke gerade mal, wie das aussieht. Das würde mich jetzt fast überraschen.
Also ich habe hier auf jeden Fall noch eins im Regal liegen.
Also ich habe so ein USB-externes Laufwerk.
Naja, also für 24 Euro hat es jetzt genau das getan, was es halt irgendwie sollte.
Es hat also CDs gebrannt. Dann habe ich, weil ich ja schon immer so ein bisschen,
nostalgischer Typ bin hier von Verbatin, dann auch gleich die passenden CD-Rohlinge,
die noch diese Vinyl-Optik haben. Kennt ihr die?
Die habe ich noch nie gesehen. Sieht ganz witzig aus.
Das sieht man auch gleich, dass es eine Audio-CD wird.
Rohlinge mit Vinyl-Optik? Nein.
Ja.
Das ist ja geil.
Die gibt es in der Tat bei jedem Saturn- und Media Markt.
Echt? Das ist ja hübsch.
Immer noch.
Ich habe die noch nie gesehen.
Also wir müssen wieder beschreiben, was wir sehen.
Sieht aus wie eine Schallplatte.
Es ist eine CD, die aber auf der Oberseite bedruckt ist wie eine Schallplatte.
Ein bisschen bedruckt ist, aber auch mit ein bisschen richtig so Rillen zum Durchfühlen.
Es ist also nicht nur irgendwie jetzt ein Papier, was drauf ist,
sondern es ist schon ein bisschen mühreig.
Aber wenn ich die auf dem Planenspieler lege, ist es schon kaputt, oder?
Es sind konzentrische Kreise.
Genau, es ist keine Spirale.
Es ist also wirklich...
Okay, also die Rohlinge waren kein Problem.
So, jetzt ist aber die nächste Frage. Jetzt habe ich ja diese ganzen Playlists
in iTunes oder beziehungsweise Apple Music heißt es ja jetzt.
Wie brennt man die denn da jetzt eigentlich?
Tja, keine Ahnung.
Normalerweise, wenn du jetzt das Apple Super Drive Laufwerk,
anschließt, dann mountet der Rohling sich quasi auf dem Desktop automatisch als Laufwerk.
Dann dragst du da deine Sachen drauf und dann ejectest du das und dann brennt er das.
So, grundsätzlich geht das. So, du kannst auch, selbst aus dem aktuellsten Mac OS 26, Dev Beta 6.
Aber du willst ja Audio-CDs bringen.
Immer noch kannst du aus Apple Music heraus Audio-CDs.
Auch noch aus Apple Music raus, okay.
So, und ich habe das rechts unten Apple One rundum sorglos Paket,
was irgendwie Medien angeht.
Das heißt also den kompletten Musikkatalog plus dieses Legalisierungspaket.
Alle Sachen, die ich jemals irgendwie selber gerippt habe oder gekauft habe,
sind dann legalisiert und so weiter.
Aber glaub mal nicht, dass man die Sachen jetzt vom DRM her auf eine Audio-CD drauf bekommt.
Ich habe da so wirklich einen halben Abend Zeit rein investiert,
um raus zu kriegen, nach was für einer Logik einem Apple Music das erlaubt oder
nicht erlaubt, daraus jetzt eine Audio-CD zu machen.
Das heißt also, wenn ich einen Song kaufe, nicht nur die Streaming-Rechte dafür
habe, das habe ich ja quasi immer in meinem Abo, sondern wenn ich nochmal dezidiert
sage, ich zahle jetzt hier 1,49 Euro.
Bei zwei von drei Songs, die ich gekauft habe, ließen die sich danach nicht
auf eine Audio-CD brennen. und es wird einem überhaupt nicht angezeigt,
wann das geht oder wann das nicht geht. Es ist komplettes Fledermausland.
So, das heißt also, das, was ich doch eigentlich erwarten würde an der Stelle,
ist, ich habe eine Playlist, da sind irgendwie 15 Nieder drauf.
Er sagt mir, hey, ich mache dir einen Sonderpreis, 1 Euro pro Song,
ja, zahle hier 15 Euro und dann darf es eine Audio-CD brennen. Gibt's nicht.
15 Euro?
Ja, 10 Euro, was weiß ich. Also, weil versuch mal, eine gute Star-Wars-CD zu
kriegen, ja, wo wirklich mal so, wirklich nur die Hits drauf sind.
Willst du mir jetzt gerade sagen, du bist nicht in der Lage,
aus Apple Music eine CD zu brennen?
Richtig.
Weil die Lizenz das auf einmal nicht mehr erlaubt?
Aber das war doch immer so bei Apple Music.
Und das ist intransparent, weil manche Playlists gehen oder einzelne Songs kann
man brennen, die ich aber auf dieselbe Art und Weise gekauft habe wie andere Songs.
Und was kommt da für eine Fehlermeldung?
Du kannst, der Brennendialog ist ausgeblendet. Du kommst gar nicht erst in den
Dialog rein. Das ist einfach im Menü dann ausgegraut.
Du kriegst überhaupt keine Fehlermeldung.
So, was machst du jetzt? Du hast immer noch deine Kinder und deinen musikpädagogischen Ansatz.
Naja, ich meine, du kannst natürlich immer noch deine Musik irgendwie über Audio Capture.
Mit einfacher Geschwindigkeit, hurra.
Mit einfacher Geschwindigkeit nochmal rausrippen.
Das ist das, was ich getan habe.
Und wie oft musstest du die Aufnahme neu starten oder jemand dazwischen gequatscht hat?
Und der Audio-Stack zu wackelig wurde.
Oh Mann, ins Essen gequatscht.
Hier ist es jetzt allerdings von Vorteil, dass ich ja in einer meiner vielen
Nebenwelten noch so eine gewisse Software entwickle.
Sprich, da hilft ein Reaper Ultraschall. Wir haben nämlich vor langen,
langen Jahren mal ein virtuelles Sound-Device mitentwickelt für Ultraschall,
um Skype N-1 schalten zu machen.
Ich erinnere mich, ja.
Und da haben wir dann jetzt also ein virtuelles Soundausgang AUX.
Den kannst du nach wie vor auch in Apple Music einstellen. So spiel das mal
auf AUX aus und nicht auf den Neutsprecher.
In Reaper Ultraschall sage ich hier Stereospur 44.1 16 Bit.
Nimm mal den AUX Kanal und dann überspielst du das zwar nicht lossless 1 zu 1.
Aber schon Wieso ist es nicht lossless?
Naja, du hast ja schon irgendwie so der, also es ist wenn du den Lautstärkeregler
verschiebst, hast du halt eine unterschiedliche Aufnahme.
Ach so, ja okay.
Aber das passt ja nicht. Dinge passieren, aber das ist nicht mehr hörbar.
Kommen später noch dazu.
Aber so Lautstärkeregler dürfte doch bei dem AUX gar nicht möglich sein.
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht volume controllable.
Das ist ja ein Feature von Audio-Devices, was die meisten nicht haben.
Aber also in Music macht es einen Unterschied, wo ich den Auto-Trackler...
Achso, der Music.
Genau, da gibt es quasi keinen...
Den darfst du einfach nicht anfassen.
Aber da ist halt auch bei diesem Regler nicht klar, wo es ist eigentlich 100%.
Was ist das jetzt? Eine Kette schlechter Entscheidung.
Es könnte schon passieren, dass du irgendwie an deine Apple Watch kommst und
aus Versehen ein Volume runter gehst.
Die Music ist so scheiße. So, jetzt bin ich hingegangen und habe Also jede einzelne
meiner Playlist in Realtime, abends, 80 Minuten, passend auf so eine CD drauf,
in Reaper reingespielt.
Wie viele CDs hast du gebrannt?
Don't hold your breath.
Das ist aus Rip Mix Burn geworden.
So, jetzt haben wir aber natürlich, willst du ja schon auch,
oh Papa, können wir dir das Lied bitte nochmal hören?
Das heißt, du willst natürlich skippen können in deiner Audio-CD.
Das heißt, jetzt musst du natürlich aus dieser langen Sound-Schlange,
80 Minuten, musst du jetzt natürlich noch die einzelnen Tracks separieren.
Klar.
So, da hilft einem dann allerdings Reaper ganz erheblich, weil du kannst halt
in Apple Music einstellen, nein, blende nicht die Tracks ineinander,
sondern mach irgendwie drei Sekunden Pause dazwischen.
Dann machst du unsere Pause-Detection, die du dir ja auch immer sehr anprallst
zum automatischen Zerschneiden unserer Podcast.
Dann sagst du, setz da an jedem dieser Stellen einen Marker rein.
Und dann hat Reaper in der Tat die tolle Funktion, dass du wirklich Audio-CDs brennen kannst.
Und zwar mit Nimm-die-Kapitel-Marken als einzelne Sprummarken.
Man kann direkt aus Reaper brennen?
Ja, natürlich, Tim. Du kannst aus Reaper alles machen, auch Videoschnitt.
Audio-CD. Sprich direkt mit dem CD-Laufwerk?
Ja. Das ist Export auf CD und dann kannst du anklicken, brenn mir diese CD.
Und zwar mit den Einzeltracks, nimm die Kapitelmarken oder nimm irgendeinen
anderen Qualifizierenden.
Das hat schon seinen Grund, dass wir diese Software als Grundlage nehmen.
Das ist schon Nerd-Kram.
Dann habe ich noch eine Normalisierung drüber laufen lassen,
damit auch die Lautness einigermaßen gleichmäßig ist. Jetzt habe ich das schön
alles auf Minus 16 LUFS noch drauf normalisiert, weil das mich auch Riesenunterschiede
macht, je nachdem, wie die Sachen da aus Apple Music rauskommen.
Und die Normalisierung, die Apple Music selber anbietet, ist totaler Schrott.
Also keine Ahnung nach, was für ein Messverfahren die da herangehen,
aber das taugt nix. Also nochmal schön in Reaper normalisiert und alles war gut.
Ja, was heißt alles war gut? Dann hatte ich also am Ende in der Tat Audio-CDs,
so wie ich sie haben wollte, konnte noch ein Cover brennen. Das klappt dann
immerhin noch irgendwie aus Apple Music heraus.
Aber am Ende des Tages, wie viele Zwischenschritte waren das jetzt,
wo es eigentlich in einer perfekten Welt hätte alles so einfach sein können?
Leider Kinder werden es denen nie danken.
Richtig. An ein paar der Playlists hatten sie dann schon Spaß,
an ein paar andere haben sie dann ignoriert.
Aber ich hatte zum Beispiel eine Playlist auch mit den besten Computerspiele, Songs.
Das ist auch so verdammt schwierig, da gute Aufnahmen zu kriegen.
Also glaub mal nicht, dass man so einfach irgendwie an die Zelda-Soundtracks oder sowas rankommt.
Also klar, es gibt immer irgendwelche Leute, die das dann nachspielen auf Klavier
und mit Querflöte und weiß der Geier was und sich da viel Mühe geben,
aber auch so eine Marktlücke, warum da so die Gaming-Studios nicht standardmäßig
ihren Soundtrack irgendwie mit rausgehen.
Also zum Teil ist es ja so, dass sie den OST mit dazu bringen.
Aber am Ende fuhren wir also durch Schweden und haben also fucking Star Wars
vernünftig irgendwie hören können.
Aber diese ganze Kette, um da hinzukommen, wie benennt man das?
Kompletter Wahnsinn.
Suchst du noch wirklich ein Wort oder ist das eine Frage, für die du die Antwort schon hast?
Also ich habe, man ahnt es, mich mit ChatGBT darüber ein bisschen unterhalten.
Ich bin darauf gekommen, ja. Und?
Und der beste Vorschlag, der da kam, war Pragmageddon. Das fand ich ganz gut.
Okay, das Wort habe ich hier schon gesehen, aber das hat mich nicht angesprochen.
Aber wie nennt man es? Weil es ist doch irgendwie etwas, was man aus vielen Kontexten kennt.
Dass man Kompromiss auf Kompromiss stapeln muss, um irgendwie zu einem scheinbar
einfachen Ziel zu kommen. Wie benennt man das?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich für eine spontane Antwort zu haben bin.
Ich auch nicht. Dann muss ich aber erstmal Chat-GPT fragen.
Kette von schlechten Entscheidungen?
Also einfach Kompromiss auf Kompromiss halt gestapelt.
Aber man muss durch. Man muss irgendwie durchkrabbeln.
So wie durch so ein Abwasserrohr durch.
Im Militärischen gibt es ja immer so schöne Begriffe wie Clusterfuck und sowas,
aber das trifft es halt nicht.
Fuba halt, ne? Also es ist halt eigentlich so eine Fuba-Entscheidung.
Fucked up beyond all recognition heißt das.
Genau, aber es ist, oder beyond repair, aber es ist halt irgendwie,
diese Kette hintereinander ist halt jetzt irgendwie nochmal,
bringt eine andere Qualität rein.
Ja, das ist wahr, dieses serielle Aufeinanderaufbauende.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich würde da mal drüber nachdenken.
Genau, also ihr Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, denkt bitte auch drüber nach,
schreibt es uns auf den gängigen Kanälen.
Ich wäre wirklich dankbar, wenn die deutsche Sprache hierfür ein vernünftiges
Wort hätte. Wegen wie auch Englisch, könnte es ja auch sein.
Ja, wo wir gerade beim Ranten sind, da wollte ich auch nochmal einen Appell
machen, weil ich glaube, das ist irgendwie vielen Leuten nicht so klar.
Wenn du einen Strand lang gehst und dann kommen dir so Kinder entgegen mit Luftballons,
die so lustig über den Köpfen fliegen, was denkst du dir dann?
Dass da Helium drin ist. Also irgendwas, was es halt hochzieht auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer Helium sein muss.
Okay, und wie geht es dir dann so dabei?
Ganz gut, hoffe ich.
Warum?
Du freust dich an dem Bild?
In der Regel glaube ich schon, ja. Weil ich ignoriere, dass.
Helium ein sehr seltenes Zeug ist.
Es handelt sich bei Helium um eine nicht oder im Prinzip fast nicht erneuerbare
Ressource auf diesem Planeten ist.
Und wenn wir weiterhin so viele Luftballons steigen lassen und der Meinung sind,
man müsste jetzt Helium zum Spaß überall in Menschen oder in… Ich.
Wollte gerade sagen, für die Stimme wird es ja wohl noch okay sein.
Ja, also das Ding ist, Helium, der Name sagt es ja schon, wird hergestellt in der Sonne.
Da wird es wirklich in Mast produziert und deswegen heißt es ja auch Helium
und als man es entdeckt hat in der Sonne, hat man es Helium genannt,
weil man kannte es ja nicht von der Erde.
Von Helios heißt es glaube ich, ne?
Ja, erst später hast du dann sozusagen Helium auch in Höhlen und so weiter.
Es gibt halt so verschiedene wenige Quellen auf diesem Planeten,
wo es Helium gibt, weil Helium entsteht halt auch in der Erde,
aber durch radioaktiven Zerfall.
Also es ist sozusagen ein schleichendes Abfallprodukt durch radioaktiven Zerfall.
Das dauert aber eben so eher im Bereich von Hunderttausenden und Millionen Jahren,
bis da nennenswerte Mengen zusammenkommen.
und Helium ist aber super, super wichtig zum Entwickeln von medizinischen Geräten
und anderer Anwendungen,
wo es keine Alternative gibt oder zumindest keine einfache Alternative gibt
zu Helium, weil halt einfach Helium als non-reaktives Edelgas,
einfach perfekt geeignet ist und nichts anderes ohne weiteres dafür perfekt geeignet ist.
Deswegen wollte ich einfach mal nur Awareness schaffen für das Helium-Problem.
Und bitte macht kein Helium in Luftballons. Das ist furchtbar.
Kannst du dann irgendwas zur Größenordnung sagen?
Ich habe mal so ein bisschen hinterher geklickt und mir mal so ein bisschen
was auswerten lassen und die Intelligenz befragt.
Und es war irgendwas so von, wenn wir so weitermachen, dann hält das noch irgendwie 100 Jahre.
Okay, cool.
Vorausgesetzt, dass man keine
neuen Vorkommen findet oder nur in dem Tempo weitere findet wie bisher.
Ja, klar, kann natürlich sein, dass man dann irgendwo nochmal was findet,
aber es ist einfach derzeit nicht absehbar, dass es sich dabei um eine beliebig
auffrischbare Ressource handelt, sondern es ist eher absehbar,
dass es genauso nicht so ist.
Jetzt sehe ich natürlich meine traurigen Kinderaugen gleich vor mir.
Gäbe es denn eine Alternative zu Helium? Also ein anderes Gas,
was leichter als Luft ist und den Job auch machen könnte?
Habe ich auch geguckt, aber ehrlich gesagt ist mir ja nichts eingefallen.
Also Wasserstoff würde wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut funktionieren.
Aber... Mäßig gute Idee.
Methan?
Es ist weniger dichter als Luft.
Ja, das stimmt eigentlich. Methan.
Ich meine das jetzt auch nicht, dass man unbedingt in die Atmosphäre lassen will.
Aber ich glaube, da kann man auch einfach aufhören Milch zu trinken und dann
gleich das gleich wieder aus, weil dann irgendwie weniger Kühe Methan in die Luft pupsen.
Ja, könnte mir fast vorstellen, dass das irgendwie eine Option ist.
Ja, füllst du deinen Ballon an der Kuh auf und dann geht's los.
Ja, aber so Ballons sind so Sachen, die braucht man halt nicht.
Also es ist einfach so ein bisschen Plastik an der Schnur mit einer Ressource,
die sich nicht erneuert.
Für so einen kurzen Fun, das hält dann so ein paar Tage und dann fliegt's davon
oder sinkt langsam ab und dann war's das.
Also ich glaube, im Chat gibt's den Hinweis Wasserstoff.
Ja, so super.
Achso, hatte die gerade, sorry.
Ja, aber dann hast du halt irgendwie diesen Hindenburg-Effekt.
Dann wollen natürlich dann alle ihr Feuerzeug ranhalten. Das ist keine gute Idee.
Luftballons brauchen wir halt nicht. Millionen Kinder would disagree.
Wofür ich werben würde...
Millionen Kinder können auch ohne Luftballons groß werden.
Ich würde sagen, man kann doch einfach zu anderen Luftballon-Arten migrieren.
Also ihr kennt sicherlich,
Diese länglichen Luftballonschlangen, die man dann zu Blumen formen kann und ähnliches.
Das habe ich in der Tat, wir haben ja in der Winzstraße so zweimal im Jahr irgendwie
so ein Straßenfest-Dingsi, wo die irgendwie einen Teil der Winzstraße hier absperren
und dann machen Leute irgendwie Spielaktionen auf der Straße.
Und ein Stand, den ich da immer besetze, ist in der Tat so ein Luftballon-Bastel-Ding,
wo ich aus so langen Luftballonschlangen, die ich mit so einer Handpumpe schnell
aufgepumpt bekomme, dann irgendwie schnell.
Den… Kannst du das mit so einem Knoten oder machst du da eine Schlange?
Es ist sau einfach. So, darauf will ich gerade hinaus. So, traut euch das einfach mal.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist, wie so häufig, das Equipment. Das heißt,
du brauchst die richtige Art von Luftballon.
Das geht natürlich nicht mit 0815 Luftballon, sondern welche,
die direkt dafür spezialisiert sind.
Die halt einfach das aushalten, dass du sie quasi beliebig lang und beliebig
hart zusammendrehen kannst, ohne dass die jemals platzen.
Also irgendwann platzen sie dann auch, aber da kommst du eigentlich nie hin.
Und es gibt, man ahnt es auf YouTube, unendlich viele Tutorials,
wie man also binnen 20 Sekunden irgendwie einen lustigen Hund daraus zusammenfaltet und es funktioniert.
Muss da nicht besonders geschickt für sein, sondern muss nur dir einmal merken,
in welchen Abständen musst du die Sachen halt abdrehen und dann miteinander verknoten.
Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt, da waren wir irgendwie in so einem...
Bei irgendeinem Spiele-Ressort halt und da war einer von diesen Typen,
die das gemacht haben und dem habe ich mich einfach mal 20 Minuten unterhalten
und der hat mir mal gezeigt und ausprobiert und das schafft wirklich jeder und
dann braucht ihr kein Helium mehr.
Ich suche mal so einen beliebigen YouTube-Video dazu raus.
Kann man immer noch anprangern, hier Gummi und auch alles Umweltverschwendung
oder so, aber wenn ihr also leuchtende Kinderaugen mit Luftballons haben wollt,
damit kommt ihr weiter als mit Helium.
Was ich gerade eben meinte mit Yps-Heft war so ein typisches Gimmick,
war im Prinzip eigentlich ein sehr großer schwarzer Müllsack,
den du so auf, machst die Öffnung auf,
bewegst das Ding ein bisschen, sodass Luft reinkommt,
dann knotest du das Ding zu und dann heizt sich die Luft da drin auf durch die Sonne.
Ah, oh Gott, das hat bei mir nie funktioniert.
Okay, dann lag es nicht nur an mir.
Ich hatte es, ich bin in der Tat auch Yps-Generation. Nee, also weder die Urzeitkrebse
haben bei mir jemals gelebt.
Die haben niemals die Urzeit gewusst, nee.
So, ich habe jetzt mal einen beliebigen Link in die Shownotes abgeworfen.
Beginner's Guide to Making a Dog Balloon.
Das geht also wirklich in 20 bis 30 Sekunden und dann skaliert das auch auf
seinem Straßenfest ganz gut.
Also ich habe dann innerhalb von, ich habe dann immer so drei,
vier Stunden Schichten, die ich dann da mache und habe am Ende,
glaube ich, so 300, 400 solcher Viecher gemacht.
Man macht dann ein Repertoire, irgendwie zwei Blumen, zwei Tiere,
ein Schwert, Säbel, so mäßig, Piraten.
Dann können die Leute sich das aussuchen. Jedes Kind ist happy,
wenn es dann Viech in die Hand kriegt.
Probiert es mal aus.
Also Methan ist übrigens auch
nicht so geeignet, weil das irgendwie noch explosiver ist als Wasserstoff.
Und es wurde auch noch Argon genannt, aber Argon ist nicht geeignet,
weil das ist schon heiß als Luft.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber es explodiert nicht, ne? Das ist irgendwie so komplett in Erd.
Ja, diese Edelgase sind ja überhaupt so die coolsten.
Ja, die sind edel, ne?
Ja, die macht vor allem irgendwie nichts, übrigens nichts außer Rohr.
Genau, das ist einfach richtig cool.
Insofern ist Helium ja auch ganz toll, aber wir sollten bitte Helium für was
Sinnvolles verwenden. Nicht so ein Quatsch.
Ja, apropos nicht so ein Quatsch. Wollen wir nochmal über AI-Coding reden?
Ein bisschen? Ralf?
Ein bisschen. Können wir.
Damit wir das noch vom Tisch kriegen.
Also ich werde jetzt, ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen,
AI als Käse im Ziel. Also Also es wird mir jetzt nicht durchgehend gelingen,
es wird jetzt keine Fastenkur,
aber ich habe so das Gefühl, ich habe so meine ersten Danen erreicht und die
Dinge werden schon fast so einfach,
beziehungsweise merke ich halt jetzt einfach, dass es Zeit wird zu konsolidieren.
also ich habe das jetzt im Wesentlichen
verwendet um so meine das was ich aufzuholen habe aufzuholen und.
Zwinge mich jetzt quasi das Wissen was ich jetzt meine erworben zu haben auch
so zu manifestieren in mir, indem man es halt dann auch wirklich manuell macht
oder zumindest erstmal manuell probiert,
weil man merkt halt einfach dass wer zu viel Assistenz hat,
lernt ja nicht selber das Handwerk sondern du lernst ja nur wie du es,
in Auftrag gibst und während aber der positive Aspekt natürlich war,
dass man all diese ganzen Prototypen machen kann all diese ganzen Sachen die
so Wegwerfsoftware sind dafür ist wunderbar und es ist halt auch super geeignet
um erstmal die eigenen Lerndefizite,
zu überwinden, die einen davon abhalten, andere Sachen zu lernen.
Das ist echt gut. Und ja, insofern bin ich mal gespannt, was so die nächste
Zeit in der Hinsicht bringt und ob ich da irgendwie die gleiche Energie aufgebracht bekomme.
Würde mich auch mal interessieren. Also ich mache das jetzt nicht über längere
Strecken, dass ich sage, so jetzt mache ich kein AI-Coding mehr,
sondern hauptsächlich, wenn ich zum Spaß programmiere,
wenn ich irgendwie was Neues ausprobiere, wo ich halt ganz gezielt was lernen
möchte, irgendwie neue Library, neues Framework, neue Sprache, was auch immer.
dass ich dort dann tatsächlich, also ich benutze normalerweise Cursor,
und wenn ich dann keinen Bock habe auf diesen ganzen AI-Coding-Kram,
dann benutze ich halt auch einfach einen anderen Editor, wo mich das gar nicht,
die ganze Zeit ins Gesicht lacht.
Finde ich halt dann immer ganz spaßig, weil mir geht es wie dir,
also ähnliche Motivation würde ich sagen, ich will das auch weiterhin alles
können, ohne dass mir der Computer das vorsagt.
Und vor allem auch selber nachdenken müssen.
Also es gab jetzt in den letzten Monaten etliche Studien. Ich wollte für eine
der nächsten Sendung das nochmal ein bisschen vorbereiten, was wieder so der
aktuelle Stand der Forschung und der ganzen Paper eigentlich ist so im AI-Bereich.
Da tut sich auch ständig was.
Und es gibt jetzt vermehrt so Doomsday-Studien so, Achtung, Leute XY haben ein
halbes Jahr lang nur mit AI gearbeitet und so ist ihr Gehirn geschrumpft.
Kein Scheiß.
Was?
Okay.
Das Gehirn ist geschrumpft.
Das Gehirn ist nachweislich geschrumpft und weniger Synapsen gebildet.
Es gab jetzt vor zwei Wochen eine Studie, dass im Medizinbereich bei der Krebserkennung
die Mediziner, die sich jetzt auf AI verlassen,
kurzfristig bessere Prognosen schalten, aber dann nach ein paar Monaten auch
so einen stumpfen Effekt haben, dass sie zu sehr darauf vertrauen und ihre eigenen
Skills der Erkennung irgendwie runterfahren.
Also es gibt da jetzt Signale in die Richtung, dass das mittelfristig für Menschen
schwierig ist. Es überrascht mich ehrlich gesagt null.
Wir kennen diese Zusammenhänge beispielsweise, wenn ihr euch mal daran erinnert,
als die Smartphones anfingen gute Maps und Navigationssysteme zu haben.
Dass Leute plötzlich verlernt haben, irgendwie noch eine analoge Karte zu lesen.
Oder sich überhaupt selbst zu orientieren.
Zu orientieren, irgendwie wo sind eigentlich die Himmelsrichtungen und sowas.
Wo steht die Sonne gerade und welche Merkmale sehe ich hier in der Umgebung,
in der Stadt und wo muss ich langlaufen.
Wundern tut mich das alles nicht, ob das dann gleich immer in diese Doomsday-Szenarien
reinmünden müssen und das Gehirn wirklich schrumpft. Wie gesagt,
das würde ich gerne nochmal ein bisschen systematischer aufbereiten. Aber ...
Dass wir hier grundsätzlich jetzt, wir haben das ja schon häufiger mal postuliert,
wir sind die letzte Generation, die, das sagt natürlich jede Generation von sich, aber.
Wir sind die letzte Generation, wir sind die letzte Generation.
Wie die alten weißen Männer hier.
Wenn wir erst tot sind, dann habt ihr ja nichts mehr zu lachen.
Aber das hat ja vorhin irgendwie beim Abendessen schon aufgebracht,
wie fühlt sich jetzt eigentlich ein Informatikstudium an im Jahr 2025,
wenn du jetzt Erstsemester bist.
was schaffst du dir da noch drauf und
wo sagst du einfach mal ihr habt sie doch nicht alle das ist jetzt wie der Taschenrechner
im Matheunterricht sobald du in der Mittelstufe bist rechnest du den Kram nicht
mehr auf Papier sondern rechnest du den mit dem Taschenrechner und genauso möchte
ich das auch bitteschön mit meinem Boiler Template Code auch halten könnt ihr
seid doch bescheuert wenn ihr mir das irgendwie hier wegnimmt,
tja mal schauen.
Also es ist ich habe auch die Frage von so ein paar Einsteigern bekommen.
So, was bedeutet denn das jetzt?
Werden wir denn jetzt irgendwie abgelöst? Ja, braucht's uns noch?
Das ist ja so diese andere Befürchtung, ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Und ich bin eigentlich jetzt auch nach einem Jahr intensiven Vibe-Codings der
Meinung oder fast sogar noch mehr der Überzeugung wie schon zu Beginn, dass,
Nichts dran vorbeigeht, dass du dir selber die Grundlagen von so niedrig wie
möglich drauf tust, wie es irgendwie geht.
Und das gilt natürlich im Computerbereich noch radikaler, finde ich,
als in vielen anderen Bereichen. Also du musst jetzt irgendwie,
wenn du Tisch lasst, nicht unbedingt die Grundlagen der Physik drauf haben.
Aber so im Computerbereich lohnt es sich wirklich möglichst niedrig anzusetzen.
Unter anderem auch schon bei Physik.
Wie funktioniert ein Transistor?
Ja, wie funktioniert Strom? Also man sollte das Atom sich schon mal ein bisschen
genauer angeschaut haben.
Das heißt nicht, man muss alles verstehen und man muss auch nicht irgendwie
in allem eine Prüfung haben oder ein Diplom abholen oder 30 Studiengänge machen.
Das ist nicht das, was ich meine, sondern vor allem muss man seine Neugier am Start haben.
Und das ist irgendwie das, was mir immer ein bisschen auffällt bei so Leuten,
die programmieren, aber wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, die wollen das eigentlich gar nicht.
Die sind auch nicht neugierig. Die wollen nicht wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Die wollen nicht wissen, wie man es anders machen kann.
Da ist überhaupt gar kein, ja, weiß ich nicht, da krabbelt irgendwie nichts.
Und das ist schon mal ein schlechtes Zeichen. Und wenn man diese Neugier in
sich spürt, dann ist man vielleicht auch im richtigen Job oder auf dem richtigen
Weg zu einer richtigen Profession.
Aber nichts macht es einfacher, als die Grundlagen zu kennen.
Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur so diese physikalischen Grundlagen und so
Sachen, die dem Programmieren fern sind, sondern eben auch wirklich das Programmieren
als solches versuchen zu verstehen und möglichst niedrig anzufangen.
Und da gehört auch mal dazu, sowas wie C mal erlernen ist ein großes Wort,
aber man muss mal so mit C ein bisschen rumgemacht haben und mal versuchen, was sehr einfach ist,
vielleicht wirklich mal den Taschenrechner programmieren, um einfach mal ein
Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie schabt man so direkt am Prozessor entlang.
Also klar, man kann ja auch so Maschinensprache und solche Sachen machen,
kann man auch machen, aber das ist jetzt nicht so ganz der entscheidende Faktor.
Und wenn man dann in seine Programmiersprache einsteigt, dann gilt halt erst mal,
Dickes, gutes Buch lesen. Das Beste, was es gibt, wo so lange rumfragen,
bis man das weiß und das dann wirklich von vorne bis hinten komplett durchwälzen.
Davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt. Das hilft einfach enorm.
Und natürlich generell fürs Programmieren
gilt, sich jedes Jahr eine neue Programmiersprache anschauen.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt viel damit machen, aber sich mal so konzeptionell damit
beschäftigen, mal die Syntax versuchen zu verstehen.
Ein kleines Beispielprogramm, damit zu machen, versuchen zu begreifen,
wo die Sprache anders ist, als die, die man gerade benutzt.
Das kann man auch wieder beiseite legen. Niemand muss jetzt in 30 Programmiersprachen
programmieren können und die wenigsten können das.
Aber all das hilft, weil dann sind auf einmal diese ganzen AI-Tools für dich
auch wirklich wertvoll, weil die sich einfach direkt andocken an dem,
was du ohnehin schon weißt und wenn du auch so eigenes Muscle Memory hast,
dann bist du überhaupt auch erst in der Lage zu bewerten,
was da rauskommt, ob das was taugt.
Und das geht meiner Meinung nach nicht weg.
Also ich meine, im besten Fall habe ich selber eine Vorstellung,
was mir das, was mir Cursor ETC eigentlich schreiben soll.
Wie soll das aussehen, was da rauskommt?
Und ich spezifiziere das und das Ding schreibt das dann runter.
So relativ emotionslos, würde ich sagen.
So ist es halt das, wie ich das auf der Arbeit am meisten benutze.
Da habe ich jetzt nicht großartig Interesse daran, mir zu überlegen,
könnte man hier so oder so programmieren.
Nee, da weiß ich nicht immer, aber manchmal weiß ich halt, ja,
das ist jetzt hier so zu programmieren und nicht anders, weil so wird es gemacht
und mach mal. Kein Bock das zu schreiben.
Ja, und das ist auch wichtig, dass man dabei lernt, eine Strategie zu formulieren.
Also es gar nicht mehr nur so geht mit, ja, mach mir mal jetzt ein Tool,
was das und das tut, sondern dass du eben auch diesen Weg beschreitest.
Du hast ja auch noch ein gutes Beispiel, wie du da jetzt gerade rangehst, Ralf.
Ja, ich hatte zwei Erlebnisse jetzt in den letzten Wochen. Das erste war sehr ernüchternd.
Da habe ich nochmal etwas mittelälteren Ultraschall-Code nochmal in Cursor reingeworfen.
So mit dem Ziel, okay, diese Skalierungsprobleme unter Linux von der GUI her, Umrechnungsfaktor.
Da ist Reaper echt irgendwie sehr, sehr krude aufgestellt. Du musst also jeweils,
wenn du eigene GUI renderst, und das machen wir ja in Ultraschall,
einzelne GUI-Elemente,
also Kapitelmarkeneditor und sowas, musst du für Windows, für Mac und für Linux
jeweils unterschiedlichen Code produzieren, damit das mit einer High-DPI-Resolution
vernünftig funktioniert, je nachdem.
Und gerade Linux ist ein totales Fledermaus-Land. In der nächsten Sendung erzähle
ich nochmal über meine Linux-als-Desktop-Experimente, die ich auch gerade mache.
Das soll jetzt kommen, nächstes Jahr, habe ich gehört.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Ich will mich da auch gar nicht drüber lustig machen. Ich werde das versuchen
mit dem nötigen Ernst dann hier auf den Tisch zu packen, wenn ich da soweit bin.
Und da ist Cursor, beziehungsweise genauer dann Cloud Sonnet 4,
war das die 4.0 oder war es schon die danach?
Was ist die aktuelle Cloud Sonnet-Version? Die sind noch schnell über 4.0 auch wieder drüber.
4.
Ist das noch die 4.0? Ist da so dermaßen brutal gegen die Wand gefahren.
Da funktioniert wirklich überhaupt gar nichts. Da habe ich dann ein bisschen
nachgefragt, was tust du da eigentlich gerade so und analysier doch erstmal den Code.
Und dann gab es einen lustigen Moment, ich bin in meinem Leben noch nicht so
beschimpft worden und so gedisst worden wie von Claude Sonnet 4 über dieses
Stück Ultraschall-Code.
Also Spaghetti-Code war ja noch eins der glimpflicheren Formulierungen.
Und ja, das ist jetzt kein perfekt durchgestalter Code, aber es ist schon alles
vernünftig in Funktion gekapselt und wiederverwendbar und Definition und so.
Also mir sagt Claude immer, dass ich recht habe und dass ich sehr gute Fragen stelle.
Ich habe auch geile Ideen.
Das war ja alles nicht der Fall. Ich wurde rüde beschimpft. Ich habe irgendwo
einen Screenshop gemacht.
Das ist ja auch immer ein Fortschritt.
Davor und danach nie wieder passiert.
Hätte ich eigentlich ganz gerne, dass mir das Ding mal sagt.
Das ist totaler Kack. Versager! Streng nicht mehr an.
Naja, und das zweite Erlebnis, was ich jetzt gerade erst die Tage hatte,
war ChitGPT5 ist ja rausgekommen.
Vor zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, irgendwie sowas in den Dreh.
Und ich bin da sehr ambivalent, muss ich mir auch noch wirklich für eine der
nächsten Sendungen nochmal detaillierter angucken.
Der Grundspinn davon ist ja, dass sie diesen gigantischen Modell-Zoo jetzt versuchen zu kaschieren.
Also JetGPT, wenn man sich das mal irgendwie auf Open Router oder so anguckt,
hat ja irgendwie 20, 25 verschiedene Modelle am Start gleichzeitig,
die du auch alle über API noch irgendwie ansteuern kannst und die alle jeweils
Feintuning haben für irgendeinen.
Obskuren Use Case und aber nirgendwo mal wirklich gut nachdokumentiert ist,
wo fährt denn nun eigentlich?
Und das ist ihnen mittlerweile irgendwie auch selber eingefallen und von daher
haben die große Neuerung, die ChatGPT5 reingibt, ist nicht,
dass jetzt irgendwo ein großes neues trainiertes Modell ist,
sondern dass sie davor quasi ein Agentenmodell geschickt haben,
der in Realtime entscheidet,
welches der durchaus bekannten Modelle dahinter eigentlich jetzt das Beste ist
für die Anfrage, die du gerade hast.
Keine doofe Idee, aber jetzt auch nicht irgendwie was bahnbrechend Neues an der Stelle.
Und es hieß dann aber, oh, Encoding sei das jetzt gut. Da habe ich gesagt, na gut,
ich habe gerade in einem anderen Projekt, was ich schon seit einem Jahr jetzt
ungefähr mache, habe ich ja noch nicht erzählt, muss ja noch gucken,
ob ich das irgendwann mal hier erzählte, das ist eine Elektron-App,
die also sehr so richtig als App daherkommt, aber speziell ein Use Case hat,
wo ich gucken muss, braucht die Welt das überhaupt?
Wo ich aber schon seit etlicher Zeit mal ein neues, etwas komplizierteres,
neues Feature dazu haben wollte. Dann schmeißen wir doch nochmal JetGPT5 drauf.
Das war auch die Woche, wo das kostenlos in Cursor drin war,
in der quasi Premium-Ultra-Deep-Nachdenken-Version.
Das schien mal so sinnvoll. Da habe ich also runterspezifiziert,
so, pass auf, hier ist der Code, schau erstmal gründlich rein,
schreib mal auf, was du hier so siehst.
Weil das war ja auch keine Historie von ChatGPT5 an der Stelle,
sondern eben von Claude Sonne. Da hat er schon mal eine ganz gute Analyse gemacht.
Da habe ich noch nachgeschrieben, ja, du hast noch übersehen XY,
guck mal hier, das gibt es auch noch. Ah ja, okay, gut, so, und was willst du jetzt haben?
So, dann habe ich das neue Feature runterspezifiziert und dann hatte ich einfach
mal den Gedanken, noch einen Halbsatz hinten dran zu fragen,
nämlich, ist das jetzt klar soweit oder ist dir noch irgendwas unklar?
Und das war, glaube ich, eine sehr, sehr schlaue Idee, die ich so vorher noch nicht hatte.
Dann hat er sich das nämlich angeguckt, die Spezifikationen,
und hat dann in der Tat, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob es jetzt fünf oder sieben,
ich meine, es waren sieben Fragen gestellt, wo er noch Unklarheiten hatte.
Und die waren wirklich sehr, sehr geil.
Da war keine einzige dabei, die jetzt irgendwie Bullshit war.
Es waren zwei so ein bisschen Captain Obvious.
So, ja, natürlich meine ich XY, schön, dass du nochmal fragst.
Aber ja, alles andere macht nicht so richtig viel Sinn.
So zwei oder drei waren so, dass man denkt so naja, okay,
schon sinnvoll, dass er danach fragt und die restlichen waren dann richtig gut
rausgefischte Edge Cases, die ich selber noch überhaupt nicht durchdacht hätte,
die ansonsten im normalen Prozess mir früher oder später dann wieder auf die
Füße gefallen wären, wo man ja noch wieder hätte nachbessern müssen.
Also da war ich echt beeindruckt von den Rückfragen, die er da gestellt hat
er, sie, es, was auch immer und als ich dann gesagt habe Genau,
das sind die Antworten auf deine sieben Fragen und jetzt code mal los.
One-Shot, perfekte Implementierung. Von der Geschichte, wo ich denke,
da hätte ich mit Claude Zonnet wahrscheinlich schon irgendwie so 20,
30 Minuten dran gebastelt.
Was war das jetzt für ein Code?
Das war JavaScript.
Aber halt schon mit irgendwie Fallsystem-Zugriff über Elektron,
etliches an Fremdbibliotheken rein, GUI-Framework oben drüber und sowas.
Also schon etliches an State, was irgendwie durch die Gegend geschoben wird.
Track-and-Drop-Funktion. Also das ist schon eine App, die wirklich eine App
ist. Und nur irgendwie sowas kleines, klick mich bunti.
Wie viel Zeit hast du mit dieser Spezifikation, bis er dann losgelegt hat, verbracht?
Also ich hatte da, da ich da schon länger drüber nachgedacht hatte,
so, das hätte ich ganz gerne, hatte ich die mehr oder weniger fertig im Kopf,
das ist runter tippen, vielleicht drei Minuten.
Das waren am Ende vielleicht auch so 15, 20 Zeilen, weil ich es einfach schon
sehr klar hatte, was ich eigentlich haben will.
Mit dem Nachfragen und dem Refinement?
Also der gesamte Zeitaufwand war dann sicher, weil die Antwort der Fragen,
die wusste ich dann auch alle, da musste ich also nicht lange drüber grübeln, so.
Ja, guten Edge Case gesehen, macht Sinn.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, keine fünf Minuten, 5, 6 Minuten, der ganze Prozess.
Du hast vorher drüber nachgedacht, bis du in der Lage warst.
Dass alles 3 Minuten... Darüber würde ich sagen so 2, 3 Wochen.
Also so immer mal wieder.
Weil ich so überlegt hatte, so okay, mache ich es jetzt so oder will man es eher so haben?
Also irgendwann rede ich nochmal über diese App, weil da ein paar lustige Prämissen,
glaube ich, verbaut drin sind, die ungewöhnlich sind fürs Jahr 2025.
Wo ich denke, so Back to... Also das Dateisystem spielt da eine wichtige Rolle.
Ja, also eigentlich ist das jetzt die Erfüllung des Traums des Hammock-Driven
Developments, was Rich Hickey mal ausgerufen hat.
Weißt du, also dass man eigentlich als Programmierer im Wesentlichen seine Zeit
so in der Hängematte verbringen sollte und über das Problem nachdenkt.
Und dann irgendwann, wenn man halt fertig ist, rauskommt aus seiner Tonne und
dann erzählt man es der Welt.
Und wenn man es jetzt sozusagen dann auch noch gleich in zehn Minuten gecodet bekommt, umso besser.
Ja, das habe ich schon mal erzählt. Also relevante Teile von Ultraschall sind
auf dem Fahrrad entstanden.
Weil ich hatte da halt so die letzten großen Release-Sprünge,
da war ich halt noch an der Stabi.
Das sind 20 Minuten Fahrraddistanz von mir zu Hause, die ich dann also jeden
Tag hin 20 Minuten zurück 20 Minuten.
Und da habe ich in der Tat viel im Kopf programmiert. So im Sinne von so,
wie baue ich jetzt irgendwie die Architektur? Und macht das Sinn oder macht das nicht Sinn?
Und dann hast du auf der Hinfahrt dir Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Dann acht Stunden machst du ganz was anderes.
Auf der Rückfahrt machst du nochmal ein Review.
Hast du nochmal neue Erkenntnisse? Und dann abends setzt du dich hin und kannst
es dann runterschreiben. In Anführungszeichen.
Also wenn du Liegefahrrad hättest, dann wäre es noch mehr hängelmattet.
Also das funktionierte bei mir sehr, sehr gut. Kannst dann keinen Podcast dabei
hören, was ich ansonsten irgendwie ganz gerne mache.
Beim Fahrradfahren, das geht dann nicht.
So sehnmäßig Podcast oder Musik hören und coden im Kopf, das klappt nicht.
Aber so als erstmal Dinge wirklich gründlich durchdenken und wenn du vier Tage
oder so vier Fahrradtouren brauchst, dann sind es halt auch vier Fahrradtouren
und vorher fängst du aber auch nicht an,
irgendwie in die Tasten zu hauen, sondern das fand ich eine sehr produktive
Art des Codings. so, das war auch vor Vibe-Coding.
Ja, so ein Moduswechsel ist immer wichtig, ob es jetzt wie Wach und Schlaf und
Duschen, nicht Duschen ist, einfach so Momente, wo man,
auch sich nicht groß ablenken lassen kann von irgendwas, abgesehen vom Verkehr,
aber man muss halt sich darauf konzentrieren, das hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ja, gucken wir mal, wie es weitergeht mit unseren AI-Coding-Sachen und ich bin
mal gespannt, ob es mir gelingt, mich da wieder rauszuziehen und wirklich in
so einen Knowledge-Moment reinzukommen.
Aber ich glaube, ich muss jetzt einfach nur noch so ein paar Sachen aushärten.
Und bin sehr optimistisch, so einen Flow reinzukommen, weil ich habe einfach
dieses Jahr, Vibe-Coding hat mir einfach zehn Jahre Zeit gespart.
Das ist so mein Gefühl. Teilweise würde ich sagen,
hat es sogar noch mehr aufgeholt, weil ich eigentlich noch einen sehr viel längeren
Zeitraum eigentlich 20 Jahre lang nie so richtig ernsthaft größere Softwareprojekte gemacht habe.
Immer mal wieder was begleitet, hier und da, was Kleineres. Aber du verlierst
dann halt einfach auch so dieses sekundäre Wissen.
Umgehen mit Development Environments, Coding, Editoren, all diese ganzen Tools
und GitHub und so sekundäres Wissen, was du halt einfach am Start haben musst,
um heute überhaupt noch mitspielen zu können in diesem ganzen Ding.
Vor 20 Jahren gab es diese ganzen Package-Manager, Online-Repositories,
GitHub, Git, wie überhaupt Version-Control, all diesen ganzen Kram gab es entweder
gar nicht oder halt nur in einem Zustand, in dem man das nicht haben will.
Wir hatten uns jetzt gerade Code angeschaut, den ich vor...
Du hast gesagt 30 Jahre.
...92 geschrieben habe.
Also 30 Jahre alten Code, ich war ein bisschen überrascht, um ehrlich zu sein.
C-Code, ja.
Ja, C-Code, den ich vor 30 Jahren geschrieben habe. Ich konnte mich nicht mehr
daran erinnern, dass ich den geschrieben habe, aber es sah nach meinem Code aus.
Ich habe schon einen deutlich schlechteren C-Code gesehen.
Hübsch geschriebene C-Code.
Kommentare.
Kommentare, alles drin, irgendwie ordentlich formatiert, Groß-Kleinschreibung,
alles klare Typen und so.
Nee, nee, da habe ich schon immer darauf geachtet. Das war schon immer pedant.
Mir war nicht klar, dass Leute damals schon programmieren konnten.
Vor 30 Jahren.
Ja, ja, da ist schon Code entstanden.
Auf der Steintafel, ja.
So, Luca, magst du uns noch von deinen Audio-Erlebnissen berichten?
Ja, klar. Also, Ralf, du hörst doch auch gern Musik, oder?
Es scheint so.
Auf CD.
Nee, auf Vinyl.
Auf Vinyl, okay.
Auf CD ist die Aussehen.
Ja, ihre Geschichte hatte ich aber, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt,
dass ich so einen teuren Dreher bei meiner Schwiegermutter im Keller,
den sie wegwerfen wollte.
Okay, aber beschreib mal das Setup ein bisschen, was du da hast.
Das Setup?
Ja.
Gut, das ist ein Torens, also so einer wie früher in Radiostationen lief.
Wenn ich den jetzt so runterneuert, wie ich den jetzt hochgebaut habe,
verkaufen würde, würde so 3500 oder sowas bringen.
Normale Kabel.
Warte mal, warte mal, dein Schallplattenspieler würde 3500 Euro im Verkauf erzielen?
Mindestens, ja.
Weswegen?
Weil das einfach eine Rarität ist und eines der besten Laufwerke,
die gebaut worden sind, ist das, was in Radiostationen zum Abspielen von Vinyl.
Also Sammlerstück quasi.
Ein totales Sammler-Liebhaberstück. Und da habe ich jetzt eine Holzzarge drunter
bauen lassen, also wirklich Handanfertigung gefräst, habe mir einen Plexi Deckel
bauen lassen aus Österreich.
Also der ist jetzt was wert. Vernünftige Nadel drin.
auf Stereo umgerüstet, weil Mono kann ich dann doch nicht ertragen.
So, dahinter hängt schlichte Kupferlitze aus dem Baumarkt. Also überhaupt nichts mit irgendwie.
Geht in Verstärker rein.
Es geht in der Tat, aber das ist auch nur reine Nostalgie in ein Röhren-Amp rein dafür.
Die andere Digitalkette, die ich natürlich auch habe für Streaming und sowas,
da ist nichts mit irgendwie Röhre dazwischen. Aber den habe ich aus Nostalgiegründen
hinter den Röhrenverstärker.
So ein relativ kleiner, der sich nicht entblödet, damit man das Glühen der Röhre,
was sehr, sehr subtil ist, wenn man sich das mal scheinbar besser sieht,
haben die dahinter eine LED verbaut.
das heißt also das Glühen, was du aus diesem Röhrenamp siehst ist eigentlich
nur eine LED hinter der Röhre weil die Röhre selber halt einfach viel zu dunkel
ist dass man da irgendwie was sehen würde,
so und aus dem gehen dann etwas bessere Lautsprecherkabel, aber wir reden hier
immer noch von irgendwie 2 Euro das Meter,
geht dann in den meinen Yamaha Amp rein, oder ein Onkyo also ich glaube ein
Onkyo ist es jetzt den ich dann für Vinyl im Direct-Modus betreibe,
das heißt also die ganzen Digital-Veredelungsstufen alle abgeschaltet.
So, dann gehen brauchbare Lautsprecherkabel vom Durchmesser her,
aber wie gesagt, das sind dann auch immer noch so 2 Euro pro Meter,
gehen dann zu meinen ALR Nummer,
8 ist es glaube ich, Boxen und das ist das eigentliche High-End-Stück bei mir.
Also die können theoretisch richtig geilen Sound.
Die machen auch, nicht nur theoretisch, sondern Die galten laut Audio-HiFi mal
als mit die besten Boxen, die in Deutschland gebaut worden sind und haben neu
damals 20.000 Mark gekostet.
Also ich glaube ja, du schöpfst das Potenzial da nicht aus.
Meinst du?
Also du sagst zwar, du hast irgendwie gute Audiokarten, aber wie hast du die verlegt?
Ich die verlegt habe.
Jetzt sag mir nicht, die liegen einfach da rum wie in so einer Höhle.
Die liegen in Kabelschächten. Schön mit Woman's Acceptance Faktor über die Ecken.
Also die liegen, auch noch Kurven gelegt wahrscheinlich. Alter,
wie so ein Höhlenmensch, wie so ein Tier.
Also du willst mir erklären, du hast keine Cable Riser im Einsatz.
Natürlich nicht.
Was? Gott, Gott.
Nein, ich glaube in der Tat, dass es bei HiFi muss man an genau den richtigen Ecken investieren.
Und das sind die Cable Rapper.
Lautsprecher, Lautsprecher.
Du willst nämlich nicht, dass deine Audiokabel einfach so auf dem Boden oder
auf dem Schreibtisch oder was weiß ich wo liegen.
Das willst du ja nicht, weil dann weiß man ja, dadurch wird der Sound schlechter.
Aber das ist zum Glück auch ein Problem, was gelöst ist.
Zum Glück.
Der Markt bietet eine Lösung an.
Der Markt regelt.
Du kannst dir für nur, ich sag erstmal was es ist und dann kannst du raten wie viel das kostet.
Es sind so kleine, ungefähr so Zentimeter breit, so leicht jojoförmige, runde Dinger.
Die legst du unter deine Kabel. Also dein Kabel legst du da drauf,
platzierst die irgendwie gut, damit dein Kabel geschützt ist vor dem Boden.
und die sind aus Kupfer mit Gold beschichtet.
Natürlich.
Und du kannst dir hier so ein Set kaufen für, wie viele?
Wie viele sind denn da drin?
Das ist schwierig, das steht hier gar nicht so genau.
Naja, Details.
Also da das hier nicht, ah ne, Set of Three, es sind drei Stück.
Drei Stück.
Drei Stück, okay. Also.
In welchem Abstand muss man die denn installieren, damit das irgendwie auch wirkt?
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich ein Zentimeter oder so.
Wahrscheinlich so, dass die Kabel halt nicht auf dem Boden liegen.
Es darf halt nie auf dem Boden liegen.
Aber was ist, wenn die sich dann dabei durchbiegen? Ist das nicht schlecht?
Da musst du halt mehr von den Dingern legen.
Okay, was gibt es für, also drei kriegt man für nur?
Also in diesem High-End-Sektor ist ja eben so das goldene Gesetz,
es darf einfach mal nicht zu günstig sein.
Das muss dann auch einfach mal richtig reinkrachen. Das heißt also,
ich würde jetzt vermuten, auf gar keinen Fall unter 50 Euro pro Stück.
Das heißt also 150 Euro wäre da so die Untermarke.
Es gibt für das, was man irgendwie den Leuten an Verarschung andrehen kann,
auch irgendwo eine Obergrenze, die würde ich bei so einer Geschichte jetzt bei 300 ansetzen.
Das heißt also irgendwas zwischen 150 und 300 Euro.
Also du bist kein wahrer Musikkenner.
Da darfst auch mal schaben.
Also ich meine, die Obergrenze, die kannst du noch ein Stück nach oben setzen.
Also Set of Three von diesen richtig geilen Cable Risern kostet in diesem Shop,
den ich gefunden habe, 750 australische Dollar das sind ungefähr 414 Euro.
Wo ist in Ordnung, stimmt.
Das sind das Euro.
Also pro Stück. Für drei. Aber seine Einschätzung stimmt in etwa pro Stück.
Stimmt. Es sind halt 140 Euro pro Stück. So einen kleinen Klummen Kupfer.
Das ist alles schon wild.
Ja, also das ist großartig.
es tut mir bedingt leid für die Leute, die sich da.
Wo gibt es denn das überhaupt?
Ich habe gerade einen Link hier mal reingeworfen in den Chat.
Für alle, die das jetzt kaufen möchten, ist natürlich ein Referral-Link.
Nee, es ist keiner.
Aber sie sehen schon schön aus. Jetzt, wo ich sie so sehe.
Die sehen wertig aus.
Telos Gold Plated Pure Copper Cable Stand Set of Three Far and Away the Best
Risers we have ever tried.
Guaranteed to improve your sound significantly.
Significantly.
Ja, also das ist, aber das ist auch nicht alles, was dieser Laden zu bieten hat.
Das ist nicht alles.
Nur jetzt die Kabel erhöhen, ich meine erstens hast du ja dann noch Geld über
und zweitens geht ja die Qualität jetzt nicht nur durch auf dem Boden liegende Kabel verloren,
sondern man kann ja auch an anderen Stellen noch ein bisschen optimieren.
Du hast auch noch mehr gefunden oder nicht?
Ja, genau. Also es gibt auch Sachen, die kannst du, ich würde sagen,
an einem Lautsprecher oder vielleicht sogar an einem Plattenspieler quasi direkt
applizieren, um punktuell die Klangqualität zu verbessern.
Da, wo es halt notwendig ist.
Und die Technologie ist wahnsinnig atemberaubend und interessant.
Möchtest du raten, was es ist, Ralf.
Gewichte, die man auf das Vinyl nochmal draufstellt.
Ein bisschen leichter.
Tja, keine Ahnung, was da der moderne Stand der Technik noch so alles hergibt.
Du kannst es aufkleben. Das ist so rund. Ungefähr so, weiß nicht,
so zwei, drei Zentimeter Durchmesser, glaube ich.
Und in diesem Aufkleber ist nichts.
Na dann.
Das ist ein Aufkleber. Dafür sind die auch ein bisschen günstiger.
Also ein Set, also so ein Sheet mit 20 Stück kostet nur 195 australische Dollar.
Da ist da noch was drin.
Genau. Ach, die sind auch ein bisschen kleiner, als ich gerade gesagt habe.
Die sind 5 Millimeter im, ich nehme an, Durchmesser.
Es gibt aber auch noch die 6 Millimeter Square Variante, die kostet nur 50 Dollar
mehr, die kann man dann auch nehmen.
Wenn ich mir das online angucke, du lügst ja, da ist nicht nichts drin,
sondern da ist Ytriumoxid, Holimiumoxid, Tantanumoxid und Sysprosoniumoxid drin.
Dysprosium und Lantanium.
Vier seltene Erdmineralien.
Quantumsticker sind das.
Das ist natürlich ein Quanteneffekt.
Das muss man wissen.
Muss man wissen, ja. Was auch irgendwie gleich der Übergang ist,
ich hatte vor zwei Jahren oder sowas, hatte ich das schon mal erzählt,
also es gab wirklich mal eine Zeit, wo ich mich viel in HiFi-Foren rumgelungert habe,
so, was ist jetzt eigentlich irgendwie so der beste Plattenspieler für XY und
gibt es wirklich irgendwie Dinge, die was nutzen und egal in welches HiFi-Forum
man sich da verirrt, es gibt eigentlich immer so die zwei Grundfraktionen, nämlich die Goldohren,
die an alles glauben und das, also die allerfeinste, Einzelnen Unterschiede
rausbekommen und dann halt so die Skeptiker,
die also nur auf Doppelblindtests irgendwie vertrauen und man ahnt,
welcher Fraktion ich mich da immer zugeordnet habe.
Aber wenn man da ein paar Monate unterwegs war, wunderte einen bei Corona und
den Querdenkern wirklich nichts mehr.
Das Potenzial an Menschen, an Dinge zu glauben, für die es nicht den geringsten
empirischen Beweis gibt, ist doch irgendwie nahezu grenzenlos auf dieser Welt.
Ich glaube, die Geschichte hatte ich schon mal erzählt. Ich habe mal in einer
WG gewohnt in Göttingen, wo ein...
eigentlich ansonsten ernstzunehmender, wie ich fand, Wissenschaftler immer völlig
euphorisch erzählt hat von seinen letzten Audio-Optimierungen und was die für
unfassbare Effekte gebracht hätten in seiner Audio-Kette.
Und ich werde also wirklich nie vergessen, wo er gesagt hat,
er hat also das Digitalkabel von seinem CD-Player zum Verstärker ausgetauscht.
Es hört nicht auf bei analogen Kabeln.
Das hier, das optische, wie heißt es?
SPD-Diff.
Ja, genau.
Tosslink.
Tosslink-Kabel. Und als er das umgestellt hat, sei seine Frau aus der Küche,
aus der Küche, zwei Räume weiter, zu ihm ins Wohnzimmer gelaufen und gesagt,
mein Gott, was hast du denn gerade an einem Sound gemacht?
Ich habe es bis in die Küche gehört, dass sich das besser anhört.
Diese Geschichte hat er mir erzählt. Einer der gerade in seiner Promotion.
Ein Tosslink-Kabel gegen ein anderes Tosslink-Kabel?
Weil er ein Tosslink-Kabel gegen ein anderes Tosslink-Kabel ausgetauscht hat.
Das hat einfach die Bits besser übertragen. Die Bits kamen echt darüber.
Die Reihenfolge der Null und Einsen waren einfach noch genauer gleich.
Genauere Einsen.
Ihr kennt vielleicht den Podcast Hoaxilla. Aus jetzt nicht mehr Hamburg, früher mal Hamburg.
Sind sie nicht wieder Hamburg?
Sind die wieder zurück? Ich habe da ein bisschen den Kontakt hin verloren,
aber ich war mal Gast bei denen.
Das habe ich ja auch schon mal gedroppt, die Folge, nämlich zum Thema Kabelklang und Audio-Voodoo.
Hoaxilla 127 ist das. Und da mache ich wirklich live in der Sendung ein lustiges Experiment,
in dem ich nämlich einfach mal mich gefragt habe, was wäre denn,
wenn denn nun wirklich Nullen und Einsen verloren gehen in diesen Tosslink-Kabeln
und es dort wirklich irgendwie einen Unterschied gibt und einzelne Bits mal umkippen würden.
Und dann bin ich halt hingegangen mit dem Audio-Editor oder Hex-Editor und habe
einfach mal halt einzelne Nullen und Einsen,
also nicht Hex, sondern wirklich halt umgeschaltet und in der Waffdatei nicht komprimiert,
so was passiert denn dann und habe das dann mal abgespielt und es war dann eben
nicht so, dass das Klavier plötzlich weiter hinten links verschoben war,
sondern das, was der Sound rauskam, war.
So, das heißt also, jeden Bitfehler hörst du mal einfach instantan oder du hörst ihn gar nicht.
Also entweder, der ist halt einfach vom Zufall her, je nachdem wo die Amplitude
des Sounds gerade ist, ist es halt dicht genug dran, dass es sich einfach total
versendet oder ist es so krass, dass du sofort einen Bass-Sound drin hast.
Wie in einer schlechten Kabelverbindung halt so.
Aber mitnichten ist dort ein Potenzial, Das ist jetzt also der Austausch eines
Dostlingkabels in der Küche durch die Ehefrau, dass sich das Klavier verschoben hat.
Aber dieses ganze Feld ist so absurd und ich versuche das so wissenschaftlich
wie möglich fundiert zu machen.
Wie gesagt, aus Nostalgiegründen ist es ein Röhren-Amp, auch wenn ich weiß,
dass es da wenig klangtechnisch bringt und alles Geld, was ich habe,
investiere ich in Lautsprecher. Es ist ja auch okay.
Wenn man sagt, mir gefällt das, ich finde das einfach gut. Aber wenn man sich
anfängt, in die Tasche zu lügen, von wegen...
Es ist ja alles so kompliziert. Weil also dann in diesen Foren gehen dann halt
so, ja, dann mach doch mal einen Doppelblindtest.
Werden dann die Goldohren gesagt. Wenn das alles so offensichtlich für euch
ist und ihr diese ganzen Unterschiede so klar, warum machen wir denn nicht einfach
hier, betreffen uns in Norberts Heifelstübchen in Göttingen und machen Doppelblindtest?
Wir haben einen Unterschied.
Die kann man noch messen. Aber diese Testsituation versetzt meine Goldohren so unter Stress,
dass ich dann einfach mal nicht mehr in diesem Musikhöher-empathischen Modus
unterwegs bin und darum muss der Test dann zwangsläufig scheitern.
Weil einfach die Testsituation als solche, so natürlich kennen wir solche Effekte,
außer empirischen Sozialforschung,
psychologischen Kognitionen und so weiter, dass sowas alles Verstärkereffekte,
Beobachtereffekte, da haben wir alles irgendwie drin, aber am Ende des Tages
ist es einfach nur Bullshit.
Tja, dabei hätte es ja jetzt noch...
Den Telos Quantum Resonator Conditioner gegeben, der also auch alle 15 Sekunden
demagnetisiert deinen Strom, dass der halt keine soundzerstörenden magnetischen Felder aufruft.
Und das hättest du schon für 13.000 Euro haben können.
Ja, und es kaufen halt irgendwie Leute. Es ist so wie die App im App Store,
die 999 Euro kostet und nichts macht außer, hallo, sie sind rich.
Irgendso ein Effekt wird da halt auch getriggert. So be it.
Wenn die Leute glücklich sind, also ich habe es lange aufgegeben,
da zu versuchen, irgendwie da kommst du auch nicht mehr an die Leute ran.
Wenn sich die Welt noch nebenbei zerstören würde, wäre es mir eigentlich auch egal.
Ja, und wenn es nicht irgendwie ein wissenschaftliches Weltbild untergraben würde.
Muss man eben gucken, ob ich von meinem schönen,
Torenz hier nochmal ein Bild reinwerfe.
So, das ist mein Dreher. Habe ich jetzt gerade hier nochmal in den Chat reingeworfen.
Dein Dreher.
Du meinst deinen Schallplattenspieler. Okay, Stück Holz mit dem Plastik oben drauf, okay.
Okay, naja.
Also ich finde es halt immer noch faszinierend, das Ding ist glaube ich von 54,
was jetzt auch einfach mal so mehr als ein halbes Jahrhundert alt ist,
sprich irgendwie 70 Jahre und dass der halt schon einen Sound produziert,
der einer CD durchaus ebenbürdig ist.
Verdammt nah an der CD.
Verdammt nah an der CD. das finde ich schon immer noch schön einfach und dann
irgendwie auf Discogs irgendwie sich schöne alte,
Vinyls irgendwie rauszupicken die irgendwie noch MINT-Status haben und noch
nie gespielt worden sind und dann hast du auch wirklich eine schöne Pink Floyd
Dark Side of the Moon Einspielung da drauf und das ist schon schick Ja.
Jeder muss seine Midlife Crisis anders Ja.
Die ist bei mir aber schon seit 30 Jahren Ja.
Naja, ich bin auch schon eine Weile dabei, aber ich bin ja, hätte ja auch nicht
gedacht, aber ich gehe dann doch klassisch eher mit dem Motorrad irgendwie,
das ist mehr lieber als der Schallplattenspieler.
So eine Harley jetzt? Ne, eine Harley ist ja uninteressant, aber seit langem
dürste ich ja schon nach einer Verbesserung im Elektromotorradbereich.
Weil das Angebot ist da, sagen wir mal, überschaubar.
Also es gibt so ein paar Modelle, die können zwar, viele sind aber absurd teuer
und dann gibt es welche, die sind nicht ganz so absurd teuer.
Und BMW hat ja jetzt beschlossen, dass sie nicht mehr weiter innovieren wollen,
sondern jetzt irgendwie nur noch dasselbe Fahrzeug im Blau rausbringen und das
dann irgendwie mit einer Pressebeteiligung ankündigen. Das ist einfach,
unglaublich. Aber jetzt kommen die Chinesen an. Und jetzt gibt es demnächst
was Neues im Motorradland.
Das wird langsam interessant.
Hier mit der Elektromobilität auf zwei Rädern.
Ich hoffe, es kommt jetzt bald.
Furchtbarer Name. Also der Laden heißt Horwin. Schon mal gehört?
Gibt es schon eine Weile im Elektroroller Bereich, so eine der Marken gewesen.
Haben mich bisher nicht sonderlich beeindruckt, deswegen bin ich hier auch noch
ein bisschen zurückhaltend.
Aber es ist schon mal ganz interessant, was sie angekündigt haben,
nämlich ein Fahrzeug, das heißt Zenmenti 0 oder Zero.
Und ja, das ist dann halt mal so ein,
Motorrad, was im Vergleich zu meinem derzeitigen Gefährt mal so doppelt so viel
Akku hat und vor allem ganz wichtig mit DC-Ladung daherkommt.
Das heißt, das kannst du dann halt an allen.
Ladesäulen, wo du auch ein großes Auto laden kannst, also mit Gleichstrom,
kannst du halt auch dieses Fahrzeug laden.
Und das macht natürlich einen riesen Unterschied, wenn du da irgendwie mit bis zu 40 Kilowatt,
reinballern kannst, dann kannst du halt wirklich Autobahn fahren und wenn du
halt dann wieder Strom brauchst, dann hast du halt mal eben Viertelstunde Pause
und dann hast du wieder irgendwie 100 Kilometer reingetankt.
Das ist so in etwa die Größenordnung, die sich da jetzt auftut.
Und ist irgendwie rasant und schnell und was nicht alles.
Aber das Problem ist, gibt es bisher halt nur in Testfahrten auf YouTube und
war halt für den Sommer angekündigt und kommt jetzt vielleicht mal im Herbst.
Aber es tut sich da langsam was.
Wir kommen langsam auch in diesem Bereich voran.
Bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Ich warte derzeit auf einen Testfahrttermin,
aber bisher gibt es noch keinen.
Ja, das nochmal so hinterher. Ne?
Ja, haben wir es dann? Sind wir durch?
Ich glaube, wir haben es. Ich habe noch ein letztes Geburtschwein.
Apple Super Drive, die CD-Defekt wird um es nicht mehr verkauft.
Kannst du nur noch auf Ebay kaufen.
Na siehste. Also alles richtig gemacht.
Naja, aber es ist hübscher als dein Ding.
Was aber nicht hübscher ist, ich habe noch ein Geschenk mitgebracht aus Schweden.
Für wen?
Ja, für dich.
Für mich?
Ja, für dein Meta-Ebene Accessoire. Guck mal hier, das ist eine ein Handtuch. Ein Handtuch.
Aus dem Ikea-Museum, wo auf der aufgedruckt ist, die Original-Schöttbullar-Rezeptanleitung.
Schöttbullar? Heißt das nicht Kött?
Naja, also ich habe gelernt oder glaube gelernt zu haben, dass es auf Schwedisch
Schöttbullar ausgesprochen wird.
Ein K wird wie Sch ausgesprochen?
Ja.
Ernsthaft?
Ist ja komisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer so ausgesprochen wird.
Aber in jedem Fall.
Kökshandtuch. Kochhandtuch.
Genau. Also gibt es nur in dem Museum. Wird irgendwann mal wahnsinnig viel wert sein.
Und das haben die da in allen Sprachen, oder was?
Das haben die da in vielen Sprachen. Nicht in allen, aber in vielen Sprachen.
Nicht in allen. 30 bis 40 Fleischbärchen für vier Portionen.
250 Gramm Rinderhack, 250 Gramm Schweinehack, ein Ei, 200 bis 300 Milliliter
Sahne oder Milch und Wasser.
Genau, da fängt es schon wieder an mit diesen Fuzzy-Beschreibungen.
Ja, ja, da wird es so, die Logik bricht wieder auseinander. Und oder Milch und
Wasser oder wie oder was?
Und wie ist das Verhältnis?
Also ich meine, was heißt denn 200 bis 300 Milliliter Sahne oder Milch und Wasser?
Heißt das, Sahne und Wasser müssen zusammen 200 bis 300 Milliliter haben?
Oder Milch und Wasser?
Muss ich Sahne, 200 bis 300 Milliliter Sahne, Klammer auf, oder Milch, Klammer zu, und Wasser?
Ja, da ist doch Syntax-Error in 10.
Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich dachte, wir bringen es doch mal in die Sendung.
Okay, dann zweieinhalb... Ohohohoho. Zweieinhalb Esslöffel Zwiebel.
Was?
Naja.
Bitte?
Also, an der Stelle...
Ich hätte gerne...
An der Stelle ein Liter Pommes.
Hast du eine Flasche dabei?
Habe ich auch erst gestutzt, aber auf der anderen Seite ist das eine immerhin
schon mal präzisere Angabe, als zu sagen, irgendwie eine Zwiebel,
weil nimmst du jetzt eine große Zwiebel, nimmst du eine kleine Zwiebel,
Gemüsezwiebel sind ja nochmal riesig fett, die sind ja wahrscheinlich nicht
gemeint, wir wissen es aber auch nicht genau.
Also erstmal gehäuft oder nicht, gestrichen.
Also ich meine, wie gebogen ist der Esslöffel? Es gibt solche und solche.
Es gibt flache Esslöffel, es gibt tiefe Esslöffel.
Was ist ein Fack normalen Esslöffel?
Ja und wie fein geschnitten hast du den? Man muss ja auch nun irgendwie die
Packdichte berücksichtigen, die der Zwiebelstücke.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wir kennen das Endprodukt. So, wir wissen also bei
den Chödbola sind keine dicken Zwiebelstücke drin.
Also pulverisiert. Es wird also eher fein geschnitten sein und das Rezept,
wenn du es hinterher weiterliest, sieht vor, dass sie auch angedünstet werden.
30 Gramm Paniermehl, zwei gekochte Kartoffeln, Komma kalt.
Und wie groß sind die Kartoffeln?
Mehl nicht kochend, kalt gekochend. Sind sie doch nicht kalt.
Kalt gekochte.
Steht da drauf.
Nein, da steht gekochte Kartoffeln, Komma kalt. 4 bis 5 Essliter Butter,
Esslöffel Butter, Margarine oder Öl, Salz, weißer Pfeffer. Ohne Angaben.
Genau.
Eine Prise. Piment. Warum ist das in Klammern und was ist Piment?
Das ist glaube ich optional.
Ist das nicht der Pfeffer?
Weißer Pfeffer, Piment, aber warum ist das dann nicht in der gleichen Zeile? Okay, Zubereitung.
Wir lesen das jetzt komplett durch hier.
Wie das läuft. Zur Bereitung ein paar Esslöffel Ein paar Esslöffel Ein paar Esslöffel,
Bräunen Butterbräunen Zwiebel hineingeben und anbraten Bis sie leicht Farbe
annimmt Butter, Zwiebel rein, Kartoffeln zerdrücken Und das Paniermehl in etwas,
Etwas Wasser einweichen Alle Zutaten zu einem glatten Teig Verarbeiten und kräftig
Kräftig Mit Salz, weißem Pfeffer und eventuell grob gemahlenem Piment würzen.
Darum optional.
Also Piment ist kein...
Das ist nicht der weiße Pfeffer, was ist denn Piment?
Ja, nur eben nachgucken.
Würzkörner, Nelkenpepper oder Wunnerpepper. Okay, ich habe irgendwie die holländische.
Nelkenpeffer, okay. Die unreifen Beeren des Pimentbaumes.
Den Teig zu runden Bällen formen und die Bälle auf ein mit Mehl bestäubtes Schneidebrett legen.
Anschließend die Fleischbällchen langsam in viel Butter braten. Etwas Butter.
mit Sahnesoße, Kartoffeln und Preiselbeermarmelade servieren.
Wo kommt jetzt die Sahnesoße auf einmal her?
Die muss man separat machen.
Aha, na toll, das ist noch nicht mal vollständig.
Ja, kochst das fertig und dann merkst du.
Also ich hab's ausprobiert gestern, das Bild, was ich hier auch eben gepostet hatte.
Hättest du ja gleich die richtigen Mengen hier eintragen können.
Also ich war neugierig auf diese Kartoffelkomponente, weil die finde ich ungewöhnlich.
Ach, das stimmt.
Dass man also in Hackbällchen auch selber nochmal irgendwie Kartoffeln rein,
also ich hatte jetzt nur festkochende Kartoffeln, das war glaube ich nicht hilfreich,
das heißt also die habe ich mit noch so viel Quetschen nicht so klein bekommen.
Und du hast sie auch warm gekocht.
Da fing das schon an.
Ich habe sie auch warm gekocht, ja. Also da, das geht wahrscheinlich noch anders,
wenn man mehlig kochende nehmen würde.
Aber ansonsten fand ich, hat das jetzt keine neue Qualität gegenüber meinem
sonstigen Rezept gemacht.
Also ich mache sehr gerne in kleine Hackbällchen ordentlich Senf rein.
Das fehlte mir da in der Tat.
Darum fand ich, schmeckten die ein bisschen lasch.
Es gibt bekannte Star-Köcher, die sagen, dass in gehacktes Bällchen auch schon Ketchup rein müsste.
Jetzt gibt es auch eine Fraktion, ich bin also Fraktion Senf,
aber irgendwas noch mal als ein bisschen zusätzlich ein Pepp macht das schon Sinn.
Also von daher, ja, ich war jetzt nicht restlos überzeugt.
Wie gesagt, im Air Fryer wurden die auch, fand ich nichts. Das war schon,
die aus der Pfanne waren besser. Röstarom for the win.
Also typografisch hätte ich hier noch ein bisschen was zu meckern,
aber es geht eigentlich.
Also es ist ein bisschen überflüssig, dass sie jetzt zwei Worte noch getrennt
haben, wo hier so viel Whitespace ist, also da hätte man das auch mehr flattern lassen können.
So sieht's einfach, verstehst du, also so ist es so, irgendwie versuchen wir
Blocksatz, aber es ist eigentlich kein Blocksatz.
Es ist kein Blocksatz. Und dann trennen wir trotzdem,
noch die Worte und so weiter. Also das ist ja, so wir scannen das jetzt mal hier, modern.
Okay.
So, ich werfe das nochmal in den Chat gerade ab.
Also es ist nicht die komplette Typografie-Hölle, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall noch was zu meckern.
Ich hätte auch oben noch ein bisschen mehr Abstand gelassen.
Naja, egal. Vielen Dank, Fleischbällchen.
Jetzt muss ich mir Fleischbällchen machen.
So, jetzt bin ich auch, glaube ich, durch mit meinen Kipp-O-Ways hier für die Sendung.
Luca kriegt nix.
Ich habe verpennt, zwei einzupacken. Ich entschuldige mich aufs Schärfste.
Wie zwei? Ach, du hast noch mehr von diesen Handtüchern?
Ich habe zwei mitgebracht, eigentlich. Eins für Roddy und eins für dich.
Und jetzt habe ich das zweite, aber schlicht...
Ich kann das ja Luca geben.
So können wir es machen. Luca kann das mitnehmen und dann nächste Sendung.
Luca, willst du Fleischbällchen?
Handtuch haben?
Möchtest du nicht haben?
Er will keine Fleischbällchen. Er ist ja nicht für Fleischbällchen.
Er ist ja mehr so für vegetarisches Essen. Von daher passt das schon.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, auch der Epilog ist gelaufen. Und dann war es das. Erstmal wieder.
wir werden uns bemühen nicht so viel Zeit,
verstreichen zu lassen bis zur nächsten Sendung, wir haben auch schon ein paar
Termine im Auge, das wird schon irgendwie alles und ja, der Sommer war groß
und jetzt werden wir mal wieder produktiv Nur?
So nehme ich.
Insofern würde ich sagen, machen wir das mal hier mit dem Outro Luca,
vielen Dank fürs Kommen Gerne.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's, die Freakshow 295 und wir hoffen,
ihr hattet Spaß und Schratz.
Uns mal wieder in die, unten in die Kommentare rein, wie man so schön sagt.
Vor allen Dingen gute Begriffe für diese Fail.
Genau, das brauchen wir, ganz wichtig.
Also, und tschüss.
Tschüss.